SUBCOMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
A GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLAIN TO THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES HERE
TODAY IN THE CAPITALISM MEMBERS
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
TODAY I'M HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AS IS ONE OTHER MEMBER OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE DR RICHARD
PAN- CENTER MELENDEZ WILL BE.
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. DOES
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALL
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. IT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED IT USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FUNCTION. IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO UN MUTE. PRESS ON
YOU BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
pTHE COMMITTEE WILL PROBABLY BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY REMOTELY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
REMOTELY THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE FOUR
ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. NINE FIVE SIX ZERO
SEVEN SIX NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
ANDORRA COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AGAIN
YOU MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING FROM THE POOR THE
HEARING PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. TO POURTANT WE HEAR
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE MANNERIST
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. BEGINNING
THAT TODAY WILL BE HEARING THE
GOVERNOR'S APRIL BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED CARE HEALTH CARE.
MICHELLE CARE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA- OKAY NOW WE WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST ITEM- THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT- WE
APPROPRIATIONS AND OTHER
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS- WELCOME
ARE TESTIFIED EARNERS TODAY THE
FIFTY. AIMS. AFTERNOON I WILL
GO AHEAD AND START MY NAME IS
MONICA ERICKSON I AM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
AND I WILL BE PROVIDING A
OVERVIEW OF PETS
REAPPROPRIATION SENT TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS FOR ISSUE ONE.
FIRST ITEM I WILL ADDRESS IS
THE REAPPROPRIATION OF FEDERAL
FUNDS. I REQUEST
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FEDERAL FUND ITEM DUE
TO AVAILABILITY OF THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF
AN AWARD HE PREACH. AND ALREADY
BREACHED ANY STATE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM GRANT
AGREEMENT AND HAS FULLY EIGHTY
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
BREACH AS OF JANUARY. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. LESS A REAL. OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT TO
UTILIZE THESE FUNDS TO AWARD
MORE STATE LOAN REPAYMENT
APPLICANTS IN OUR UPCOMING
FISCAL YEAR FOR THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO CYCLE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ME ON THIS ISSUE.
DR GRANT. PRIDE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE A BRING UP
TODAY BUT I WOULD MAKE A NOTE
THAT THERE IS ONLY ONE BREACH
IN THE PROGRAM WHICH IS OF
COURSE NOW BEING REPAID SO IT'S
RE PROCREATIVE AND SUCH A LARGE
PROGRAM I THINK THAT'S A PRETTY
REMARKABLE STATEMENT ABOUT THE
PROGRAM ITSELF AND THE PEOPLE
WHO RECEIVE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
OKAY RIGHT THE FUNDS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY RIGHT AND I
WILL GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE TO
THE SECOND ITEM THE SECOND ITEM
IS EXTENSION OF THE ENCUMBRANCE
LIQUIDATION PERIOD FOR THE PIER
PERSONNEL PROGRAM THE PURE
PERSONAL PROGRAM HAS AN ONGOING
APPROPRIATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED A REQUEST FOR AN
EXTENSION OF LIQUIDATION FOR
THE PROGRAM FOR UP TO SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE AN EXTENSION FOR
ONE GRANT. YOU TOOK OF IT
NINETEEN RELATED ISSUES. I
REQUEST TO AMEND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND REMOVED THE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
LIMIT DUE TO OTHER AWARDEES
EXPRESSING THE NEED FOR AN
EXTENSION. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS PROPOSAL. IT
SEEMS PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
THANK YOU. WONDERFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WILL GO AHEAD
AND CONTINUE TO THE THIRD ITEM
WHICH ARE THE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS- WE HAVE A FEW
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE
ARE REPORT REQUESTING- ONE OF
THEM IS AND BUDGET BILL ITEM
FORTY ONE FORTY OR ONE OLD ONE
SCHEDULE THREE. WE
INDIFFERENTLY NATIVE ERR WE
LIKE TO CHANGE THE PROGRAM
NUMBER FROM. THIRTY EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE TO THIRTY EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE WHICH REFLECTS THE
CORRECT PROGRAM THAT'S LISTED
IN THE BUDGET BILL. THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT ONE. NO PERFECT
THEN THIS TECHNICAL CHANGE IS-
WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE THE NAME
THAT'S LISTED IN THE BUDGET
BILL FROM ALZHEIMER'S HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAM TO
GERIATRIC CARE WORK FORCE
PROGRAM IT PROVISIONAL ONE OF
ITEM FORTY ONE FORTY ONE ALL
ONE EACH ADDED PROVISIONS FOR
OF ITEM FORTY ONE FORTY ONE A
ONE THE OLD ONE. THIS CHANGE
AGAIN DESCRIBES THE PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. ANY
QUESTIONS ON THAT ONE. NO THANK
YOU OKAY WONDERFUL I MOVE ON TO
THE LAST TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DID
NOT INCLUDE REIMBURSEMENTS OF
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ITEM FORTY ONE FORTY ONE A
ONE OH ONE FOUR THREE. DUE TO A
TECHNICAL. ERROR WE ARE
REQUESTING THIS ITEM TO BE
INCREASED BY FOUR HUNDRED K. TO
REFLECT THE CORRECT LEVEL OF
APPROPRIATION THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING. AND THAT'S ALL I
HAVE FOR MY PRESENTATION. IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOU THANK YOU. OKAY. MOVING
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M ELIZABETH LANDS
BURKE DIRECTOR BOSCH. AS
INDICATED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET OFFICE GROWING
PORTFOLIO MAKES IT TIME TO
RECAST JOSH BUT AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF WE AND WE'VE
GIVEN CAREFUL CONSIDERATION ON
HOW TO DO THAT AS WELL AS
REVIEWS ARE PROGRAMS FOR AREAS
WHERE WE CAN STRENGTHEN THEM-
WE HAVE REVIEWED THE CALIFORNIA
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION REPORT. EARLIER
REPORTS AND OTHERS MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE TO
CHANNEL THE BEST THINKING AND
THE NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDER
INTERVIEWS AND ALL OF THAT
INPUT IN FORM THE PROPOSALS
THAT WE ARE BRINGING FORTH.
ASHTEAD LOOKS IMPROVE OUR
AFFECT. IN PROVIDING THE DATA
AND PROGRAMS TO DEVELOP THE
STATE'S NEEDED HEALTH HEALTH
CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATION OF OUR DATA
ASSETS AND OUR WORKFORCE. SO WE
THINK THAT WITH THE ADDITION OF
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND THE PROPOSED
CHANGES ON WORK FORCE PROGRAM
DATA ASSETS THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE POISED TO BE A THOUGHT
LEADER ON HEALTH ACCESSING
INFORMATION. SO I'M GONNA-
START WITH BOTH QUESTIONS ONE
AND TWO AND GOING THROUGH EACH
ELEMENT OF OUR PROPOSAL THANK
YOU AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE OTHER QUESTIONS. SO THE
FIRST ELEMENT- IN OUR PROPOSAL
WOULD RECAST AND EXPAND THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE CLEARING
HOUSE AS THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH.
WORKFORCE RESEARCH AND DATA
CENTER. SO THE CAL HEALTH WORK
RESEARCH AND DATA CENTER WOULD
SERVE AS THE STATE'S CENTRAL
HUB OF HEALTH WORKFORCE DATA.
WE PROPOSE REQUIRING ALL HEALTH
CARE LICENSING BOARDS TO
COLLECT OF COURSE AT A
FEDERALLY RECOMMENDED DATA
ELEMENTS. FOR HEALTH WORKFORCE
ANALYSIS AND TO PROVIDE THIS
DATA TO THE TOSH AT THE
CLEARING HOUSE'S NEVER HAD THE
DATA THAT WE NEEDED AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
SYSTEMATIZED AND HAVE A
BASELINE SET OF DATA. THE
RESEARCH AND DATA CENTER WOULD
PROVIDE BETTER AND TIMELIER
DATA ANALYSIS TO INFORM STATE
POLICY REGARDING ISSUES OF
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE EQUITY IN
DISTRIBUTION. WHAT ALSO HELPED-
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY IF
THAT IS APPROVED AS WELL AS ARE
ALL PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE ARE
HEALTH PAYMENTS DATA PROGRAM.
THE RESOURCES REQUESTED HERE
WOULD ALLOW US TO PERFORM
VALUABLE TESTING ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS AND INFORM POLICY AND
PROGRAMMATIC DECISIONS. WE ALSO
HAVE A PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH A
SINGLE STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING COUNCIL
WHICH WOULD- REPLACED THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE SONG BROWN COMMISSION. SO I
STARTED SEEKING EFFICIENCY BY
OPERATING THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
DIRECTLY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT-
AND MAINTAINING THE LICENSING
REVENUE STREAMS BUT BUT
DISCONTINUING THE FIVE OH ONE
SEE THREE STATUS OF THE
FOUNDATION AND ALL ADDRESS THAT
IN MORE DETAIL WITH QUESTION
NUMBER THREE. AND THEY WERE
ALSO PROPOSING TO TRANSITION
FROM THE CURRENT SONG BROWN
CONNECTION TO THIS NEW HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING COUNCIL. THE COUNCIL
WOULD PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON
STATEWIDE EDUCATION AND HEALTH
WORKFORCE TRAINING NEEDS ACROSS
KEY AREAS INCLUDING GENERAL
PHYSICIAN EDUCATION PRIMARY
CARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND
WOULD ADVISE ON INCREASING THE
SUPPLY AND DIVERSITY OF BOTH
PHYSICIAN AND NON PHYSICIAN
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS THE
PLACEMENT OF PROVIDERS IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREA. SO
WE WANT TO BE POSITIONED TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
NEW RESIDENCY PROGRAMS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA NEEDS- MORE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE STATE'S OTHER
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS- I WANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE
TOP TEN RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION. IS TO
HAVE A BODY THAT IS ALWAYS TO
PROVIDE STATEWIDE STRATEGIC
LEADERSHIP ON GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION TRAINING PROGRAMS. WE
WILL CONSIDER THE COUNCIL'S
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS AS IT
ADMINISTERS THE WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. THE CURRENT BOARD AND
COMMISSION THE H. PATH FORWARD
AND OUR SONG BROWN COMMISSION
PROVIDE DIRECTION ON A SUBSET
OF OPTIONS PROGRAMS. BUT NO ONE
ENTITY IN THE STATE- IS
CURRENTLY ANALYZING- ADVISING
ON THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE BOTCHED
ITS PROGRAMS FOR COORDINATING
WITH OTHER STATE ENTITIES THAT
HAVE HEALTH WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
AND THAT IS WHAT WE SEEK TO DO
WITHIN. ACCOUNTS ALL WHILE
MAINTAINING A THIS IS CRITICAL
ALL OF THE PROGRAMS OVERSEEN BY
THESE TWO COUNCILS BUT BY
HAVING ONE UNIFIED ADVISORY
BOARD INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
MORE FRACTURED APPROACH WE
THINK THIS IS BETTER GOVERNMENT
MORE EFFICIENT- IMPORTANT TO
TAKE THAT STRATEGIC YOU. WE
ALSO ARE PROPOSING TO INTEGRATE
THE STATE OFFICE OF RURAL
HEALTH. AND THE J. ONE VISA
WAIVER PROGRAM IN JOSH HAS
PRIMARY CARE OFFICE. SO
CONSOLIDATING THE STATE OFFICE
OF RURAL HEALTH WHICH IS
CURRENTLY AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN THE
PRIMARY CARE OFFICE. WILL
PROVIDE A CENTRALIZED IN BETTER
TARGETED APPROACH TO WORKING
WITH RURAL COMMUNITIES ON THEIR
HEALTHCARE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE NEEDS AND DOES SO- BY
LEVERAGING OUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND WE WOULD BE
IN GOOD COMPANY FORTY OTHER
STATES ALREADY COMBINED THESE
FUNCTIONS. IN ADDITION ASPECTS
EXPERTISE- MAKES IT WELL SUITED
TO ADMINISTER THE J. ONE VISA
WAIVER PROGRAM WHICH ASSISTS
DOCTORS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
AND OBTAINING A J. ONE VISA. TO
TO PRACTICE MEDICINE IN
CALIFORNIA WERE ALREADY
ANALYZING WHERE WHERE THE
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS ARE
AND WE WOULD BE WELL POISED TO
SORT OUT HOW TO BEST- POSITION
THOSE THOSE DOCTORS. WELL I GOT
A COUPLE OF PROPOSALS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR DATA PROGRAMS-
SO WITH EXISTING RESOURCES
USHERED PROPOSES SOME TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE CHANGES ON DATA
RECORDING TO ENHANCE DATA
QUALITY. IMPROVE ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE DATA AND REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON DATA
PROVIDERS SO SPECIFICALLY- IN
TERMS OF THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
COST TRANSPARENCY STATUTE- WELL
KNOWN AS SB SEVENTEEN. WE
PROPOSE TO ADD DATA POINTS THAT
WOULD HELP IDENTIFY THE
THERAPEUTIC TYPE OF DRUGS.
FACTORS DESCRIBING THE REASON
FOR A PRICE INCREASE. REASONS
FOR NOT DISCLOSING INFORMATION
AND CLEAR AUTHORITY FOR THE NEW
DEPARTMENT TO ASSESS. REPORTING
FOR COMPLETENESS. WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING TO UPDATE SB
SEVENTEEN- TO IMPROVE DATA
QUALITY COMPLETENESS BY
CLARIFYING DEFINITIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR REPORTING AND
ADDING INFORMATION TO SUPPORT
COMPARISONS OF BRANDED VERSUS
GENERIC DRUGS SO WE'VE BEEN-
COLLECTING THAT SB SEVENTEEN
DATA FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS AND
THESE ARE OBSERVATIONS ABOUT
SOME IMPROVEMENTS TO STREAMLINE
THAT COLLECTION PROCESS AND
PROVIDE THE TRANSPARENCY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SOUGHT. WE ALSO
HAVE A PROPOSAL- PERTAINING TO
OUR CORONARY ARTERY BYPASS
GRAFT OUTCOMES ARE REPORTING TO
PROVIDE US WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
TO PERFORM OUTCOMES REPORTING
FOR NEW AND EMERGING CARDIAC
PROCEDURES INSTEAD OF BEING
STUCK- IN TERMS OF REPORTING ON
THE SAME CARDIAC PROCEDURE WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PAY THAT AS
THE TECHNOLOGY CHANGES. FOR
EXAMPLE WE THINK IT WOULD BE
ADVANTAGEOUS TO A LOOK AT THE
TRANSCATHETER AORTIC VALVE
REPLACEMENT PROCEDURE. AND THEN
FINALLY WE'RE PROPOSING TO
UPDATE STATUTES PERTAINING TO
VITAL STATISTICS TO ENSURE
TIMELY EFFICIENT TRANSMISSION
OF BIRTH AND DEATH DATA. IN
ORDER FOR BOTH PUBLIC OR- FORTY
RESEARCH- ON ISSUES SUCH AS
MATERNAL QUALITY OF CARE AND
INPATIENT MORTALITY. LOOKING AT
ALL OF THIS IN OFFICE GROWING
PORTFOLIO- WE DO FEEL IT'S TIME
TO CHANGE AGAIN THE GOVERNOR'S
INDICATED TIME STUFF GRADUATED
HE WILL FROM AN OFFICE WITH
DEPARTMENT AND WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD THE NAME OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS INFORMATION OR H. HI WE
THINK THAT BETTER REFLECTS OUR
MERGING HEALTH POLICY
LEADERSHIP ROLE. THE
DEPARTMENT'S WORK IS CENTERED
ON ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
ACCESS TO STATE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES ACCESS TO THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE THAT WE
NEED ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
QUALITY CARE ACCESS TO
FINANCING FOR HEALTH
FACILITIES. AND THE INFORMATION
TO MAKE ASSESSMENTS ABOUT
HEALTH OUTCOMES FACILITIES
WORKFORCE AND FINANCE. SO THAT
WAS MY PRESENTATION ON
QUESTIONS ON NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- JUST BRIEFLY CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED DURING
THE PANDEMIC WITH REMOTE THAT
IT WAS BEING DISTANT AND
EVERYTHING GOT AND HOW HOW HOW
IS WHAT WE LEARNED GONE INTO
YOUR THINKING. ABOUT PLANNING
FOR THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR I THINK THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF OUR RESEARCH
NEEDED INTO- THE INCREDIBLE.
INCREDIBLY QUICK PAYDAY TO
TELEHEALTH- BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE IS STILL A NEED FOR IN
PERSON OF COURSE PROVIDERS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND SO I HAD TO
WORK CONTINUES TO BE TO.
IDENTIFY THE MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS- AND TO- AND
BUT BUT I THINK WE DO NEED TO
LOG HELLO HEALTHCARE. IT'LL IS-
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING- ACCESS
TO CARE I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THE PANDEMIC HAS
CERTAINLY SHOWN US ABOUT
WORKFORCE IS THE INCREDIBLE
NEED WE HAVE FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE- I THINK IT
SHONE A LIGHT ON INCREASED ON
THE PAIN OF RACIAL. INEQUITIES
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
THAT WE'RE SUFFERING AN
INCREDIBLE NEED WE HAVE TO
REALLY GROWS UP THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE- IN SO MANY AREAS-
ANOTHER QUESTION PRODUCTION
ANYONE FROM. THE WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND I LOST
MY TRAIN OF THOUGHT UNTIL UNTIL
IT HAPPENS- SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE COMMISSIONS THAT YOU'RE FOR
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUTTING TOGETHER SHOULD TO HAVE
EVERYTHING IN ONE PLACE WHICH
MAKES PERFECT SENSE- HAVE YOU
STARTED TO BEGIN TO DO SOME OF
THAT WORK SO THAT. THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF TURF ISSUES GOING ON
AND HAS THERE BEEN A
COLLABORATION AND HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND JUST THE DOW
I THINK IT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THAT NOW BUT IT IS BEARS
BEING SAID AS I GOT ANOTHER
REPORT FROM MY DISTRICT OFFICE
ABOUT THE OVERWHELMING AMOUNT
OF EDT CASES COMING IN RIGHT
AND SO WE THINK ABOUT STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND WE THINK ABOUT
ANOTHER STATE DEPARTMENT AND
WE'RE WE'VE OT HIGH HOPES- BUT
AS WE POTENTIALLY MOVE TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTATION. HELLO MAKING
SURE THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE
TALKING TO EACH OTHER. AND
WORKING WITH THIS LITTLE TURF
ISSUES AND SILOS AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO I
THINK- THE MOVING ABOUT THE
STATE OFFICE OF RURAL HEALTH
OVER TOSH AND IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE WHERE WE DIDN'T FACE
ANY TURF ISSUES WE REACH OUT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SET FORTY EIGHT OTHER
STATES DO IT THIS WAY. WE THINK
WE CAN PROVIDE THE MOST
EFFICIENT- CARE- TO CALIFORNIA
BY BY PULLING THESE OFFICES
TOGETHER AND THEY ABOLUTELY
AGREED SO THAT'S A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
SIMILARLY WORK TALKING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ABOUT TRYING TO GET. BASELINE
DATA FROM ALL OF THE- STATE
LICENSING BOARDS UP A PROPOSAL
EVERYTHING MAKES GOOD SENSE- IN
TERMS OF THE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS AND STARTING TO
TRANSITION THEIR OF COURSE WE
CAN OFFICIALLY DO SO. UNTIL THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS- IS AGREED
UPON BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS ABOUT HOW TO-
HOW TO HAVE THE NEW COUNCIL
TAKE THAT STRATEGIC APPROACH-
AGAIN WE THINK THAT THERE'S
BEEN GOOD RESEARCH AND POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT HAVE BEEN
BEEN PUT OUT AND IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON. US TO TRY TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU THIRTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- DIRECTOR FOR
PRESENTATION I DID A FEW
QUESTIONS- RELATED- YOUR
PRESENTATION AND TO THE
DIRECTION IN WHICH US FIVE NOW-
THIS NEW DEPARTMENT NAME IS
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD- SO
FIRST OF ALL IN APPRECIATE YOUR
GETTING THE DATA FROM THE
VARIOUS LICENSING BOARDS I
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
HOWEVER I ALSO MAKE NOTE TO SAY
ACTUALLY A LICENSEE AND ALSO
SOMEONE SEARCHED ON. BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS THAT- VERY THE
MINISTRATIONS ENTERTAINING VERY
LARGE INCREASES AND LICENSING
FEES FOR- PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
ACTUALLY PRACTICE- SO. I GUESS
FIRST QUESTIONS IS THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THE COST OF
COLLECTING THIS DATA AND THEN
ANALYZING THIS DATA WILL THIS
BE BORNE BY THE GENERAL FUND OR
OTHER RESOURCES OR IS GOING TO
BE BORNE BY THE LICENSEES
THEMSELVES ALREADY. LOOKING AT
LICENSING YOU KNOW FEE
INCREASES OF NO NOT JUST A
COUPLE PERCENT BUT YOU KNOW
1020304050% NGL OR EVEN HIGHER
YEAH LICENSE FEE INCREASES IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. I WILL GIVE
INITIAL ANSWER ON SATURDAY AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION THAT
I MAY DIAL A FRIEND WITH THEM
DEPUTY DIRECTOR VALLIER
ERICKSON- TO JUMP IN FOR ME BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING TO USE OUR OWN
DATA FUNDS- AND I DON'T BELIEVE
ANY OF THESE COSTS ARE COMING
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS OR ANY LICENSING FEES
PAID BY. LICENSEES TO THE TO
THE LICENSING POINTS OUT IF I'M
INCORRECT- DEBBIE BUT DIRECTOR
ERICSON. PLEASE PLEASE CORRECT
ME. NO GARAGE OKAY OKAY ALL
RIGHT. OKAY YES IT MONICA SO
YOU KNOW YOU ARE CORRECT-
DIRECTOR LANCE BURKE SO THE
ONLY THING WE HAVE ARE TWO
COMPONENTS TO THIS WORK WE ARE
GOING TO BE PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL WE HAVE AN ONGOING
CONTRACT WE'RE GOING TO BE
SETTING UP FOR THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT WE WILL BE
REIMBURSING DCA FOR THEIR WORK.
AND THAT I BELIEVE IS COMING
OUT OF THE DATA FUND AND THEN I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A PROPOSAL OF
IN ADDITION TO THAT ONE TIME-
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE
THEIR SYSTEM TO DEAL OUT. IN
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE STATE AND THOSE
ARE THE ONLY TWO THINGS THANKS
REPORTER ALL RIGHT APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU- THAT SAID I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
IMPORTANCE- OF THE STATE AND I
PRESUME THAT THE DATA THAT
YOU'RE COLLECTING AT LEAST- THE
INDIVIDUAL DATA WILL BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL THAT'S NOT SUBJECT
THE P. R. A. OTHER TYPES OF-
EXPOSURE CORRECT. ABSOLUTELY
OKAY- THE OTHER COULD NEXT
QUESTION IS ACTUALLY- YOU
TALKED ABOUT SENSUALLY
CENTRALIZING- THE- CREATING ONE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION TRAINING COUNCIL TO
REPLACE ESSENTIALLY THE SONG
BROWN COMMISSION AND- THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
FALLS COMMISSION OTHERS. CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THE COMPOSITION OF
THIS COUNCIL BECAUSE OF YOU
KNOW WHAT THE SONG BROWN
COMMISSION HATS REPRESENTATIVES
REPRESENTING SPECTACULAR VERY
IMPORTANT SECTORS- NORTH FOR
ABLE TO PROPONENTS FUNCTION
RIGHT THERE'S REPRESENTATION
FROM PRIMARY CARE RESIDENTS-
MEDICAL SCHOOLS THAT PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS AT CETERA- SO
WHAT IS GOING TO BE THE
COMPOSITION OF THIS CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE POLICY
COMMISSION SO THAT- THERE'S AT
APPROPRIATE. REPRESENTATION.
AND EXPERTISE ON THIS
COMMISSION. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND SO ARE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WITHIN. TO HAVE
THE COMMISSION- THE THOSE
COUNCIL APPOINTMENTS MADE BY A
COMBINATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S-OFFICE SENATE RULES THAT
ASSEMBLY SO WE'VE LAID OUT
AREAS OF EXPERTISE THAT WE
THINK ARE CRITICAL- AS YOU KNOW
IT'S ON BROWN- COMMISSION HAS A
WONDERFUL PERFECT. RECOMMITTED
EXPERTISE SO WE WOULD WANT TO
CONTINUE TO TAP. INTO AS MANY
OF THOSE FOLKS WHO- MEET MEET
THE COMMISSION NEEDS THAT WOULD
WHICH IS GOING TO BE BROADER SO
IT'S NOT JUST GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON PRIMARY CARE ALSO
LOOKING AT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND ALLIED PROFESSIONS- I-THE
MASCARA REYES ALL TO JUMP AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE INDICATED.
A COUPLE OF SPECIFICS ABOUT THE
POSITION KERRY CAN HELP US WITH
THAT HE'S- I'M SURE. HI I AM
KAREN REYES- ACTOR HEALTHCARE
WORK FIRST ON THE DIVISION
ASHRIDGE AND- AS AS- DURECT
ANNOUNCED BURKE SAID- SCOPE IS
WE'RE LOOKING TO. LOOK AT
EXPERTISE IN OUR FOLKS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH GRANTED
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION WITH
TRAINING PROGRAMS WITH PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
ORGANIZATION FOR EXAMPLE- AND
THEN THE OTHER STATE OFFICES AS
WELL THAT ENGAGING HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ON
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
SYSTEM X. CETERA. OKAY SO THE
SPECIFICS ARE NON- ANALYSES AT
THIS POINT- BUT- PERHAPS YOU
CAN PROVIDE THEM THAT MIGHT BE
SOME SUBJECTIVE SOME DISCUSSION
DEPENDING ON. EXACTLY WHAT THE
DETAILS ARE SO APPRECIATE THAT
THE AT THE OTHER ISSUE THAT
ACTUALLY ONE TOUCH ON SO YOU
KNOW PREVIOUSLY OCCUPIED-
PRIMARILY. LOOKED AT SENSUALLY
THE PIPELINE ITSELF RIGHT SO WE
HAVE SOME GROUND WE HAVE OTHER
TYPES OF PROGRAMS AS WELL AND I
KNOW LATER WE'RE GONNA BE
TOUCHING ON- AND YOU'RE ALSO
GONNA BE DOING A LOT OF DATA
COLLECTION- AND THEN- THERE'S
YOU KNOW SOME DISCUSSION
AFFORDABILITY THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE TAKING ON LATER AND I
BELIEVE THIS OFFICE WAS. IT'S
GOING TO BE IN THIS. AND IN
YOUR VIEW OF WHAT'S NO LONGER
IN OFFICE ANYMORE DEPARTMENT-
HOWEVER IS IT IS WELL AS FODDER
FOR THAT THE SUCCESSOR LARGE
FINES DEPARTMENT GOING TO DO TO
LABOR- ANALYSES. REGARDING V.
AROUND THE WORK FORCE SO I MEAN
I DO WORKFORCE RES I DID
WORKFORCE RESEARCH BEFORE I
CAME TO LEGISLATORS I THINK A
LITTLE EXPERTISE NOT SOMETIMES
WE COME TO WORK FORCE PEOPLE
FOCUS. ON THE PIPELINE BUT ALSO
POINT OUT. THAT YOU CAN TRY TO.
THE TO TRY AND- BUT THERE ISN'T
A MARKET FOR THEM THE PAY ISN'T
APPROPRIATE- WORK. THE THE
POSITIONS AREN'T THERE SO ONCE
CAPPED OFF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO HIRE- AND
SO FORTH THEN YOU CAN TRY TO
PUSH ALL THE PEOPLE YOU WANT TO
TRY TO GET INTO THE PIPELINE
BUT- THEY'RE NOT GOING INTO THE
PIPELINE OR TO COME OUT THE
PIPELINE DOING UNTIL THE ONE
ELSE DON'T ENTER. BECAUSE THE
JOB OPPORTUNITIES AREN'T THERE-
TO PAY THE BENEFITS THE WORKING
CONDITIONS AT CETERA. SO
ESPECIALLY SINCE YOU'RE NOW
THIS NEW DEPARTMENT OF ACCESS
AND INFORMATION YOU HAVE AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GIVING YOU
ACCESS A LOT OF INFORMATION CAN
DO LABOR ECONOMIC ANALYSES- IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT THE- THE
WORKING. CONDITIONS YOU KNOW
THE PAY AND SO FORTH AT HAND
HOW COMPETITIVE WE ARE AND
BECAUSE AFTER ALL MOST OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE HIGHLY SKILLED SO
THEY DON'T HAVE TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA THEY CAN GO MOVED TO
OTHER STATES. IF WE DON'T
CREATE THE RIGHT KIND OF MARKET
FOR THEM. SO SILVA SAMPLE LET'S
LOOK AT THE- TALK ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RIGHT. ARE WE
ARE WE COMPETITIVE IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR ANOTHER
AREA THAT ACTUALLY I KNOW THAT
WERE PARTICULARLY CHALLENGED.
IS THIS WITH AN AGING
POPULATION WITH A MASTER PLAN
AGING BUT WE HAVE A REAL
CHALLENGE RECRUITING PEOPLE TO
WORK AND- OUR LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES RIGHT- AND SOME OF
THAT MAY BE DUE TO THE FACT
THAT. WE HAVEN'T INCREASED US
TECHNICALLY REIMBURSEMENT FOR
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY SO HE
CAN ACTUALLY INCREASED PAY. SO
ARE WE GONNA BE LOOKING IS THIS
NEW DEPARTMENT CAN BE LOOKING
AT THESE ISSUES. IF YOU'RE.
PART OF YOUR MISSION IS LOOKING
AT WORKFORCE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE CALL. AND PANEL
YES I. WE DO. WILL PRETTY
HOMELESS. AT THOSE. AND DEMAND
I'M HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE DATA.
SO WE HAVE CALLED OUT HERE.
PROPOSED CHANGES IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE DATA FROM LICENSING
BOARDS. THAT WOULD INCLUDE- YOU
KNOW RETIREMENT PLANS- SOME.
MEASURES OF SATISFACTION AS
WELL AS THE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
THAT WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL.
ALSO TO WORK WITH- ET DE. AND
THE UNIVERSITIES TO GET DATA
FROM THEM- I. HAVEN'T
CONSIDERED A LOT OF NEEDING TO
LOOK AT- FACTORS SUCH AS PAPER
OF COURSE THAT IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF FOR FINDING THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT. COMING INTO THE
PROFESSION BECAUSE OF THAT SO I
APPRECIATE YOU FLAG NAPPIES.
AND THEN I GUESS THE FOLLOW UP
TO THAT IS I APPRECIATE EVEN DO
THIS ANALYSIS BY HOPE THOSE
WILL ALSO BE. REPORTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND PERHAPS YOU CAN
SPEAK TO WHAT YOU THINK THE
REPORTING RELATIONSHIP. SHOULD
BE ON THESE THINGS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. YES WE- THE
PURPOSE OF THAT OF THE DATA
CENTER WOULD BE TO MAKE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MAKE THE
DATA OFF BROADLY AVAILABLE- WE
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FROM OUR
STAKEHOLDER INTERVIEWS THAT
FOLKS. WANT US NOT TO BE A
CONVENER AND TO MAKE THOSE
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS- TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO YES WE WILL BE.
BE ISSUING PUBLIC UP. ISSUE A
PUBLIC REPORTS INCLUDING TO THE
LEGISLATURE OKAY WELL I THINK
THAT NOT JUST POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK WE WERE
THE ONES WHO ALSO HELPED SHAPE
POLICY BUT THE DATA ITSELF THAT
IMPLIES IT IS GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT. OKAY ALL RIGHT. WELL
CERTAINLY WE CAN SPEND A LOT
MORE TIME TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
VARIETY THINGS ARE DOING BUT-
AT LEAST THIS IS FOR STARTIN
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ANSWERS AND I LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP ON. ON ON
SOME OF THIS WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR IN JUST A ONE
MORE QUESTION BEFORE WE MOVE ON
AS- WITH DOCTOR PRANCE QUESTION
ABOUT OUR OUR- OUR SENIOR
GROWING SENIOR POPULATION AND
THE NEED TO GROW SENIOR
WORKFORCE. WE ALSO LOOK AT AT
AT PROFESSIONS THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY CERTIFICATE OR
LICENSE OR. AND HOW YOU HOW WE
GO ABOUT. I COULDN'T MAKING A
DRIVE TO HAVE MORE OF A OF
THOSE CA KINDS OF HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO A COUPLE OF PIECES
THAT ONE IS THERE IS A SEPARATE
PROPOSAL- AROUND THE GERIATRICS
WORKFORCE IN PARTICULAR- AND
WE'VE DONE SOME GOOD LEARNING
ABOUT THE DEEDS THEY'RE OPPOSED
TO HELP. EDUCATE THE CURRENT
PRIMARY CARE WORKFORCE TO GET
GERIATRIC. RATING AS WELL AS TO
TRAIN SPECIALIZED GERIATRICIANS
I YES WE DEFINITELY ARE LOOKING
AT THE FALL SO THE FOR THE
FULL- PANOPLY OF TYPES OF
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS.
INCLUDING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS- AND ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE DOCTORS AND PSYCHIATRISTS.
OKAY AND WILL WILL DISPUTE
APARTMENT ALSO BE LOOKING AT
THINGS POTENTIALLY LIKE. TITLE
PROTECTION. I'M NOT FOLLOWING
YOUR TOTAL PROTECTION PARDON ME
SORRY TO IT'S A PET PEEVE BUT
TO GET A TO BE OF A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PERSON TO GET IN. MSW AN
LCSW- IN MOST OF OUR OUR-
CLASSIFICATIONS IN THE STATE-
YOU JUST HAVE TO HAVE A DEGREE
IN YOU MAY BE CALLED THE SOCIAL
WORKER. SO SOME OF US WHO WHO
SPENT A LOT OF MONEY ON
EDUCATION AND TRAINING SEN- IS
SOMETIMES FEEL LIKE IT DOESN'T
HAVE QUITE AS MUCH VALUE IF
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO CALL
THEMSELVES THE SAME THING.
WITHOUT THE SAME QUALIFICATIONS
IF YOU WILL. SO I'M JUST
WONDERING IF YOU LOOK AT
ANYTHING LIKE THAT LIKE KIND OF
PROTECTIONS AS THEY RELATE AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF LEGISLATION TO
A LEGISLATION. AROUND THAT
AROUND SCOPE AND KIND OF
PROTECTION SO WILL THIS OFFICE
TO BE LOOKING AT SOME OF THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES AS WELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HIGHLIGHTING
THAT- WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
A LOOK AT IT IT WASN'T-
ASSEMBLY WE HAD HAD IT JUST
FADED DOING BUT IT. WENT
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK
AT IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ACCORDING. RIGHT TO MOVE ON.
THANK YOU SEE THAT THREE THIS
YES OKAY SO IN TERMS OF THE
PROPOSED DATA CENTER- THE DATA
CENTER REVIEWS DATA FROM.
DEALING ARE ARTS LICENSING
BOARDS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
SUPPLY GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION
AND DIVERSITY OF THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE. THE CENTER WOULD USE
THESE DATA AND PARTS WHEN FARM
PROGRAM POLICY DECISIONS
REGARDING THE STATE'S HEALTH
WORKFORCE. THE CENTER WOULD
ALSO USE LICENSURE DATA AS AN
INPUT TO CREATE PUBLIC FACING
DASHBOARDS MAPS AND REPORTS
WHICH WOULD INFORM STAKEHOLDERS
ON THE SUPPLY AT THE STATE'S
HEALTH WORKFORCE. WE WOULD ALSO
USE THIS DATA TO PREPARE
REPORTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING COUNCIL HELP INFORM
POLICY DIRECTION AND DECISIONS
FOR CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. BOB UTILIZES VITAL
STATISTICS BIRTH AND HEALTH
DATA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
SUPPORT ALBUMS REPORTING FOR
PATIENT MORTALITY MATERNAL.
POLITY AND THE CARDIOVASCULAR
OUTCOMES REPORTING PROGRAM AS
WELL AS TO ASSIST WITH DATA
LEAKAGE THE VITAL STATISTICS
DATA WILL ALSO BE USED BY THE
HEALTHCARE PAYMENTS DATA
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT ANALYSIS ON
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN COST
QUALITY AND PATIENT OUTCOMES.
ALL SUPPORT DEFICIENCIES TO
ADVANCE ONGOING POPULATION
HEALTH RESEARCH AND DATA USE.
CREAM CDPH JOSH PARRIS. ALSO
SET OF HEALTHCARE INFORMATION
ESSENTIALLY MANAGED AS PART OF
THE OSHER ENTERPRISE DATA
WAREHOUSE WHERE WE HAVE STRICT
SECURITY ACCESS ENCRYPTION AND
OTHER CONTROLS IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF THE
DATA HOLY AUTHORIZE JOSH HAS
STAFF HAS ACCESS TO THE DATA
AND TO PROTECT INDIVIDUAL
CONFIDENTIALITY WE AGGREGATE
AND DE IDENTIFY ANY PUBLIC
REPORTING A RECORD LEVEL DATA.
THESE PROCEDURES ARE OVERSEEN
BY OPTIONS CHIEF INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER AND PRIVACY
OFFICER IN A FORCED TO BUY WITH
ALL STATE FEDERAL AND OTHER
APPLICABLES LAWS. I'M GOOD
ACTUALLY GET NOTHING THANK YOU
AND I AND I THINK THAT ALSO
COVERED ONE OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS I PREVIOUSLY ASKED-
THIS IS YOUR LOOKING AT THE
LICENSING DATA I AM I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT- S. I GUESS ONE
OF THINGS HOPEFULLY YOU'RE
pWELL LOT THERE'S A LOT OF
POSITIONS WERE LICENSE PLATE
STATE CALIFORNIA WHO ACTUALLY
DON'T LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. THEY
MIGHT BE NEWLY DONE SO WE NEED
TO YEAH SO THE NUMBER OF
LICENSES ISSUED ITSELF
OBVIOUSLY- DOESN'T REFLECT THE
WORK FORCE AND THEN. THE
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE ACTUALLY
DON'T SPEND A LOT MAY SPEND A
FRACTION OF TIME CLINICAL CARE
SELVES AGAIN BE SURE ONLY
COLLECT THE DATA. THAT WE'RE
NOT FALSELY- XP. THE ABOUT OF
CLINICAL. NO WE HAVEN'T IS A
LOT DIFFERENT FACTORS AFFECTED
I GUESS I WOULD FALL UNDER THAT
PERCENTAGE OF PHYSICIANS- THE
ACTUALLY I THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S
ABOUT 22% OF POSITIONS. SPEND
LESS THAN HALF TWENTY TWENTY
HOURS PER WEEK PROVIDING
CLINICAL CARE. I GUESS I WOULD.
FALL INTO THAT CATEGORY AS WELL
AS A S. AS IN MY WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT- AGAIN THINKING
ABOUT THAT AND THEN. MAKING
NOTE THAT- I THINK A THIRD OF
ALL PHYSICIANS ARE OVER THE AGE
OF SIXTY SO DEPENDING ON WHEN
THEY PLAN TO RETIRE IF WE COULD
LOSE A BUNCH. THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR FROM THE LICENSING-
BOARDS. YEAH YES ABSOLUTELY
SENATORS SO WE WOULD COLLECT ON
DATE OF BIRTH SO WE WOULD HAVE
THE AGE WE WOULD COLLECT- THE
AREAS WHERE THEY'RE PRACTICING-
SO. SO ZIP CODE AND ACTUAL
CLINICS WHERE THEY'RE
PRACTICING AND THERE IS A BREAK
DOWN- IN TERMS OF FUNCTIONS
THAT FOLKS ARE ARE PERFORMING
CLINICAL VERSUS ADMINISTRATOR
VERSES. THE WORK OUTSIDE OF THE
PROFESSION. OKAY AND I WOULD
NAY NOTICED SOMEONE AGAIN HIS
LICENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE YEAH THEY DID
USE THE LEAST BUT MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA DOES. DO SOME
SURVEYS BUT- I'M NOT SURE HOW
MUCH VERIFICATION THEY'RE DOING
I'M NOT SAYING THAT PEOPLE WITH
FALSE. RIGHT YEAH SOMETIMES
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO GET YOUR
LICENSE RENEWED SO YOU MAKE
SOME GUESSES AND YOU. PLUG THAT
IN JUST A YOU CAN GET THROUGH
YOUR LICENSING APPLICATION. SO
YOU MAY NEED TO DO SOME DATA
CLEANING ARE CROSS CHECKING
MORE IN DEPTH TO BE SURE. THAT
AGAIN I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
DOING IT TO BE DISHONEST I
THINK JUST THAT IF YOU'RE RE
LICENSING YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO
GET YOUR LICENSE TIME. YOU KNOW
THAT NIGHT OF THE FOR THE
DEADLINE GETS AND TO HIT SUBMIT
BEFORE- VERSES THAT YOU KNOW
THINKING DEEPLY ABOUT- I DID A
LOG OF HOW MUCH TIME I SPEND
DOING ALL MY DIFFERENT. THINGS
OVER A WEEK. I WILL TELL AND.
OKAY SO YOU M. IS THAT IF THE
SHOULD MOVE ON ISSUE FOUR. OKAY
SO IF NUMBER ASK ABOUT THE- FOR
THIS. OF FOUNDATION- SO JUST
OVER BIT OF BACK THAT HELPED
HER. EDUCATION FOUNDATION WITH
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN TO PROVIDE A CLEAR WAY
FOR PRIVATE TAX DEDUCTIBLE
DONATIONS THE SUPPORT
SCHOLARSHIPS AND LOAN REPAYMENT
AWARDS FOR EXPIRING HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. AS IT TURNS OF
UNNECESSARY FOR STATE PROGRAMS
TO BE UNDER A FIVE ONE THREE
THREE TO PROVIDE THE TAXES AND
TREATMENT DONATE. AND BECAUSE
OF THE FIVE ONCE THREES. THE
ACCOUNT AND AUDIT REQUIREMENTS
OF EACH HAVE BEEN COSTLY AND
BURDENSOME. WE JUST DON'T THINK
IT MAKES THAT FASTBALL SENSE TO
HAVE A SEPARATE NONPROFIT.
ENTITY BY ALL OF THOSE. FEDERAL
STATE WILL WORK. SUCH AS IN ANY
PLAN OUT OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. THIS CALL RESOURCE
REQUIRE TO. THE AND FINANCIAL
AUDIT. TAKE AWAY FROM THE
FUNDING OF. FOR ALLEGED. APPLE
THAT WOULD SOMEDAY JUST DOESN'T
SEEM THERE'S A IN THE HAVE A-
FRONT PAGE. FIND OUT THESE. WE
THINK IT MAKES THE FASTBALL TO
THE- DAHLE ALL FORTY. RIGHT
THAN OVER ACTIVE. BE A
PREPARATION FORCE PROGRAM. SUCH
AS STEVEN HOW TOM'S. MARIEHAMN
PROBE ARE. GREAT CRITICALLY.
AND WITH. AS THEY CAN NOW IT
WAS AS PART OF OUR- SENATE
HEALTH. WORKFORCE PRO. AND WE
THINK THAT INTEGRATE THE FROM
AND OVER. PROGRAM PART. WOULD
ALLOW APPLE TO HAVE A COMPANY
YOUR ALL THE PRO. AND WOULD
ALLOW OUR EFFECTIVE AND IF CAL
THAT'S NOT. ACROSS PORTFOLIO.
THANK YOU. NUMBER. FIVE THE
HEALTH WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING COUNCIL ROLE WOULD BE
TO ADVISE ON THE DIRECTION OF
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION AND
HEALTH WORKFORCE TRAINING FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND NATIONAL
WORK FORCE PROGRAMS THE COUNCIL
ROLE WOULD BE GREATLY EXPANDED
FROM THE COMMISSION VOLTS
RECOMMEND THE BEST USE CASH
THAT WORKFORCE FUNDS INCLUDING
SONGS BROWN. TO PREPARE THE
STATE FOR ITS FUTURE NEEDS. BY
THE COUNCIL PRO. HEALTH
WORKFORCE. AND COORDINATING THE
STATE'S EFFORTS NOT JUST WITH
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
FUNDING FOR PHYSICIANS BUT ALSO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONS. SO RATHER
THAN HAVING THE COUNCIL TO THE
ACTUAL REVIEW OF AWARDS OF
APPLICATIONS AND AWARDS IT
WOULD RECOMMEND HOW TO TARGET
THE FUNDS FOR EXAMPLE WHICH
HEALTH PROFESSIONS OR PROGRAMS
WHERE YOU. NEEDS THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM WOULD CONTINUE AS IT IS
WITHIN AUSTIN HAS- COLLECTING
APPLICATIONS SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS AND MAKING FUNDING
DECISIONS. ANY FUTURE CHANGES
IN APPLICATION CRITERIA WOULD
INVOLVE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
AND PUBLIC. OSCAR SHARE OUR OF
BROWN OTHER WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
WITH THE COUNCIL GAVE THEM
DEVELOPING STATEWIDE HEALTH
WORKFORCE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THIS IS A BACK TO SAID EUROPEAN
SPECIALLY EARLIER SO THE
CURRENT STATUTE FOR THE
COMMISSION CALLS FOR A VARIETY
OF MEMBERS INVOLVED KEEP
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION.
NURSING POSITIONS ASSISTANT AND
NURSE PRACTITIONER TRAINING AND
ARE PRACTICING CLINICIANS ALONG
WITH PUBLIC REPRESENTATIVES SO
THE INTENT OF THE COUNCIL IS TO
BROADEN AND DIVERSIFY THE
MEMBERSHIP. TO INCLUDE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS ON GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION HEALTH
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND HEALTH
DELIVERY. THAT WERE ENVISIONING
THAT WOULD INCLUDE GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM
DIRECTORS REPRESENTATIVES OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRAINING
PROGRAMS REPRESENTATIVES OF
ADVANCED. ALLIED HEALTH
TRAINING PROGRAMS. REPUBLICAN
PRICE HEALTH DELIVERY ALREADY.
AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT
ENGAGE IN HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SUCH AS THE H. YES-
AND THE UC AND CSU SYSTEMS. OUR
COMPOSITION OF COUNCIL MEMBERS
WOULD ENABLE ASHTEAD TO TAKE A
HOLISTIC APPROACH FOR
DEVELOPING HEALTH WORK FIRST
WORKFORCE PRIORITIES AND ALLOW
FOR FLEXIBILITY IN MATCHING
COUNCIL COMPOSITION WITH THE
FUTURE NEEDS OF THE STATE. I
GUESS THE FIRST THING I WOULD
ASK IS TO MAKE SURE. WE ALL
ALSO HAVING STATEWIDE REGIONAL
REPRESENTATION AS WE LOOK AT
THE DIVERSITY AND THE
COMPOSITION OF THE NEW BOARD.
YEAH IT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT-
MADAM CHAIR AND SO WE WENT
WOULD WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY IN IN MAKING THE
APPOINTMENTS- TO ADVISE ON ON
REGIONAL DIVERSITY BUT HE
AGREED THAT VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS. OKAY OKAY I THINK
WE'RE GOOD. SHOWING THE ONE
DOLLAR HEALTH CARE FERTILITY.
OUR TO HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND L. A. L. OF
COURSE. DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO COMMENTS THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU FOR OIL. HI
COREY THIS YEAR WITH THE L. A-
JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS ON
THIS PROPOSAL I'LL BE VERY
FAST- YOU KNOW IN THIS PROPOSAL
WE JUST KNOW THAT YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE ANY MAJOR. CONCERNS
TO RAISE YOU KNOW WE FIND THAT
THE GOALS OF ESTABLISHING THIS
NEW DEPARTMENT WHICH ARE YOU
KNOW GENERALLY TO ESTABLISH A
DEPARTMENT WITH A STRONGER
CAPACITY FOR BOTH RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION OF. YOU KNOW STATE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE ISSUES
AND AFFORDABILITY CONCERNS
MAKES SENSE YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE ADDITION OF THE
OFFICE AFFORDABILITY. YOU KNOW
FURTHERMORE YOU KNOW WE FIND
THAT THIS OFFICE DOES ACTUALLY
PRESENT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION MORE ACCOUNTABLE
ON ISSUES RELATED TO HEALTH
CARE ACCESS YOU KNOW
AFFORDABILITY AND ON THE
COLLECTION OF HEALTH
INFORMATION YOU KNOW THIS IS
PARTICULARLY THE CASE FOR OUR
WORKFORCE RELATED ISSUES. YOU
KNOW ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ENTITIES AND IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WHICH WHICH ALSO
WORK ON THESE ISSUES- YOU KNOW
WHICH INDICATE THAT THE
PROPOSAL WOULDN'T FULLY
CONSOLIDATE THIS RESPONSIBILITY
INTO ONE DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW
WITH THIS RECASTING THE NEW
DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW WOULD
PRESENT ITSELF AS A CENTRAL
POINT OF CONTACT TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THESE ISSUES-
WHICH MAY HELP FACILITY
FACILITATES ACCOUNTABILITY. I'M
TO THE LEGISLATURE ESPECIALLY
IN RECEIVING EVALUATION
MATERIALS OUT OF WORKFORCE IN
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. THE NEW DEPARTMENT
WOULD COLLECT INFORMATION ON.
SO THAT THAT'S ALL INCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY- AND I
BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
BILL KRAMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE HEALTH POLICY PURCHASER
BUSINESS GROUP RYAN WHICH LARA
AND NOLAN HI CHECK. ED TANISHQ-
THE LOCAL A JENNIFER MILEY AND
JASMINE PALLID. THE CREAMERY
THERE TO START US OFF. YES I AM
HE AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO OFFER COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSED TOPS OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. I'M BILL KRAMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH
POLICY AT THE PURCHASER
BUSINESS GROUP ON HEALTH.
FORMALLY KNOWN AS THE PACIFIC
BUSINESS GROUP ON HEALTH. WE
ARE NOT FOR PROFIT COALITION
BASE IN CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
NEARLY FORTY LARGE PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS AND PUBLIC ENTITIES.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED COSTS OF HEALTH CARE
FOR ABILITY. AS ALL OF YOU
KNOW. WE HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE COSTS
ARE TOO HIGH. CREATING
FINANCIAL BARRIERS FOR PATIENTS
TO GET NECESSARY CARE. HI COSTS
ALSO PUT A SEVERE FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS ESPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT PROVIDE
HEALTH BENEFITS TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND FAMILIES. THAT'S
CRIED CROWDING OUT BUSINESS
INVESTMENT JOB GROWTH AND
WORKERS WAGES THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT HEALTHCARE IT'S ABOUT THE
ECONOMY JOBS AND WAGES. WE KNOW
THE HEALTHCARE COSTS COULD BE
LOWER MUCH LOWER WHILE
MAINTAINING THE QUALITY OF CARE
AND ACCESS TO NEEDED CARE.
NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THE AMOUNT OF UNNECESSARY
SPENDING. IS NEARLY 2230% WE
ALSO KNOW THAT SOME HOSPITALS
AND PHYSICIAN GROUPS ARE ABLE
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
SERVICESAT MUCH LOWER COST
THAN OTHER PROVIDERS. IT ALSO
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY
PRESENTS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT THE COST OF CARE
ARE REASONABLE AND AFFORDABLE.
AND THERE MIGHT BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS OTHER STATES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED OR PROPOSED SIMILAR
OFFICER COMMISSIONS. AND THE
PROPOSED DESIGN OF CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY BUILDS ON THEIR
EXPERIENCE. IT MIKE'S OPINION
THE CALIFORNIA MODEL IS LIKELY
TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN
PARTICULAR WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSED OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WILL BE AFFECTED
BECAUSE- IT SCOPE IS BROAD.
IT'S TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
QUALITY ACCESS AND EQUITY NOT
JUST COSTS. SECOND WE WILL SAID
APPROPRIATE TARGETS WITH
MEANINGFUL INCENTIVES FOR
MEETING THE TARGETS. AND THIRTY
WILL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDERS FOR
HELP IN MEETING THE TARGETS.
THERE'S ONE ELEMENT OF THE BILL
I'D LIKE TO MENTION THAT WE
BELIEVE SHOULD BE STRENGTHENED.
OF THE ROLE THE ADVISORY BOARD
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT SUCCESS ON
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY IT'S IMPORTANT
IT'S MEMBERS ARE ACTING IN THE
INTERESTS OF THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. SPECIFICALLY THE BOARD
SHOULD ENSURE THE INTERESTS OF
PATIENTS CONSUMERS AND
PURCHASERS THOSE WHO RECEIVE
HEALTH SERVICES AND PAY FOR
THEM. OUR PROPERTY
REPRESENTATIVE. I RECOMMEND
THAT WE FIND WAYS TO ENSURE A
DEVICE REPORT IS ACTING ON
BEHALF THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND
THE PUBLIC INTEREST PROJECT. IN
SUMMARY CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING
A SEVERE CRISIS OF HEALTHCARE
COSTS WALDIE ACCESS AND EQUITY.
I BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSED
TOPS OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY REPRESENTS AN
EXCELLENT WAY TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS. THANK YOU FOR ATTENTION
TO THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE AFTER
THE PANEL SPEAKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY. M.
THIS SHOULD I INVESTED THAT
DIZZY MINISTRATION WANNA SPEAK
FIRST OR JUST WANT TO GO OVER
TO THE PANELISTS. OR WHATEVER
WHATEVER MANAGER FOR PRINCES
WERE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE CHANGES WHATEVER IN
WHATEVER ORDER YOU PREFER.
ANOTHER WE STARTED WHEN WE HEAR
FIRST AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL
CLOSE WITH YOU HOW'S THAT OKAY
OKAY. ALL RIGHT THAT RAIN WHICH
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS RYAN WHAT'S NICE
SERVICE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. CJ APPRECIATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY. BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY IS
IMPORTANT ISSUE FACING
CALIFORNIA. DRESSING THIS
PROBLEM IS NO EASY TASK AND
WHILE OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AS OUTLINED. BY A
YOUTH IN AB ELEVEN THIRTY AND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S TRAILER
BILL ATTEMPTS TO CREATE A
PATHWAY FOR CURBING THE RISING
COST OF HEALTHCARE. WE BELIEVE
THERE ARE CRITICAL CHANGES
NEEDED. AT THIS PROPOSALS TO BE
BOTH SUCCESSFUL AND SUSTAINABLE
OUTLINED IN TODAY'S GENDER ARE
THREE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS FOR
CJ. AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
SOME INSIGHT DURING THESE
REMARKS. AND ALSO TAKE
QUESTIONS WHEN APPROPRIATE.
FIRST I SUPPOSE WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THERE COULD BE
DETRIMENTAL AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR EXAMPLE THIS
BILL SUGGESTS THAT THE
HEALTHCARE SPENDING TODAY. IS
IN THE RIGHT AMOUNTS IN IS IN
THE RIGHT PLACES. AS MANY
KNOWLEDGE CODE NINETEEN HAS
SHOWN THAT CURRENT SPENDING ON
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IS INSUFFICIENT
FOR MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
IN FACT THIS IS ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION AS
WE'VE SEEN THEIR BUDGET
PROPOSAL. TO INVEST MORE THAN
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND.
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
UNDER THE SUPER BOWL THESE
TYPES OF INVEST WOULD OWN BE
IMPLEMENTED IF OTHER SPENDING
IS REDUCED FORCING A CHOICE
BETWEEN NEW BENEFICIAL SPENDING
AND CUTS TO EXISTING SERVICES.
SECOND WE WERE ASKED TO
CONSIDER OTHER MODELS WELL
WE'VE SEEN SIMILAR WELL
INTENTIONED POLICY LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES UNDER
THE MEDICARE'S NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN SUSTAINABLE GROWTH RATE
POLICY S. YOUR POLICY. AND EVEN
THOUGH THE S. G. R. WAS
DESIGNED TO CONTROL COSTS
GROWTH MEDICARE PAYMENTS FOR
POSITIONS IN HOWEVER FAILED. TO
ADDICT ACCURATELY ADDRESSED THE
INPUT COSTS CHANGES IN A ROLE
WITHIN INCREASED SPENDING DUE
TO NEW LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
SZOLD AFTER SEVENTEEN YEARS OF
SHORT TERM CONGRESSIONAL FIXES
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA- CONGRESS
ABANDON THE FLOOD POLICY
BECAUSE OF TOO MUCH INSTABILITY
FOR DOCTORS. THIS LEADS TO THE
FINAL QUESTION ARE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. WE APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSIONS TODAY WITH DOCTOR
WITHIN HIS TEAM AS WELL AS THIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FALL INTO FOUR MAIN
AREAS FIRST THE OFFICE DOES NOT
TREAT ALL HEALTHCARE ENTITIES
EQUITABLY. SPECIFICALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO PROVIDERS AND PAYERS
OUR AMENDMENTS EQUALIZED THESE
AT THE TREATMENT OF PAYERS AND
PROVIDERS TO ENSURE CONSUMERS
AND PURCHASERS REALIZED THE
BENEFITS. EVERY SECTOR SHOULD
MEET THE SAME STANDARDS TO BE
IN THE SAME BOAT ALL RUNNING
TOGETHER. SECOND HEALTHCARE
ENTITIES NEEDED. AND STABLE
PATHWAY TO CHANGE CHANGE CANNOT
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION SHOULDN'T
JEOPARDIZE ACCESS TO OR THE
QUALITY CARE. THIRD THE OFFICE
SHOULD MINIMIZE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND PREVENT
PERVERSE INCENTIVES AS AN
EXAMPLE. ARE IN THE OFFICE TO
ESTABLISH SECTOR BASED TARGETS
INCENTIVIZE COST SHIFTING
BETWEEN SECTORS INSTEAD THE
OFFICE SHOULD FOCUS ON
PROMOTING COLLABORATION NOT
SOLIDIFYING SILOS. AND FINALLY
THERE SHOULD BE ADDITIONAL
CHECKS AND BALANCES TO INSTILL
CONFIDENCE AND BUY IN FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ARE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FOCUS ON ADDING AN
APPEALS PROCESS GREATER
TRANSPARENCY ENSURING A MORE
BALANCED PERSPECTIVE WITH THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. WE THANK
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
TIME AND REALLY DO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BLUESHIELD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS MARLON
PAYCHECK AND I'M A SENIOR- AND
SENIOR MEMBER OF THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS TEAM WE FEEL THAT
CALIFORNIA IS A NONPROFIT
HEALTH PLAN GUIDED BY ITS
MISSION TO REIMAGINE HEALTH.
INTO A SYSTEM THAT IS WORTHY OF
OUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHILE
BLUESHIELD REPRESENTS FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION CUSTOMERS IN
THE STATE OF FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS WE HAVE A GOAL AND
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AT
AN AFFORDABLE RATE OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS WE'VE
COLLABORATED WITH PROVIDERS
BUSINESS LABOR GROUPS AND
CONSUMER GROUPS TO CREATE A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO HEALTH
CARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
CONTAINING COSTS AND ALL THAT
ALSO BRING HEALTHCARE IN THE
DIGITAL AGE THIS CAN BE DONE BY
LEVERAGING- CALL PATIENT
CHARACTER HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE. AS ENVISIONED IN AB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ONE AND HERE
THIS COST CONTAINMENT PROPOSAL
IN FRONT OF YOU WHICH WE
SUPPORT AND WE THINK IT TAKES
CONCRETE STRESSED THAT IN A
DRAFTING RISING HEALTH COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA I DON'T THINK- THAT
HEALTH COSTS ARE UNSUSTAINABLE
HEARING THE STATE AND NOT
HELICOPTER OUTSTRIPPING WAGE
GROWTH- IT'S ALSO CLEAR THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
IS NOT COMPREHENSIVE ENOUGH TO
HOLD ALL CONTROVERSY COUNTABLE
IN THE STATE. PROGRAMS
REPRESENT- 20% OF PREMIUM. ARE
TO FEDERAL AND STATE OVERSIGHT-
MULTIPLE A OR- AND GREAT REVIEW
WHEN IT TO COST. THE OTHER. 80%
OF THE- OF COSTS HAVE THE SAME
TREND. OR REVIEW PROCESS. MS
OUR REFLECTION OF COST TO THE
SYSTEM WHETHER THAT BROWN
INSURERS HOSPITALS PROVIDERS OR
DRUG PRICES. GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT INTO
THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE UNDER THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY ABOUT PORTABILITY
NEED COST SAVINGS TO CONSUMERS
WHETHER THAT BE A REDUCTION IN
PREMIUM OR SLOWER RATE
INCREASES- THE LONG ANY APPLE
WE HAVE AND THIS IS FROM THE
STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS. CENTER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR VERSION
OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY THEY HAVE SEEN IT
HEALTHCARE SPENDING ANNUAL
GROWTH RATE DECLINE FROM AMONG
THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION THE
FOURTH LOWEST GENERATING UP TO
SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION AND
AVOIDED COMMERCIAL SPENDING
BETWEEN. TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHT P. HELLO YES.
PLANS WILL DE BE SUBJECT TO OF.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL- BANK
HOWEVER UNDER THE FRAMEWORK OF
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY ALL CREDIT COST
DRIVERS WILL BE UNDER GOD
OVERSIGHT AND GREATER
TRANSPARENCY WHICH WE THINK
REALLY WILL LEAD TO LOWER COSTS
IN THE SYSTEM. ULTIMATELY THIS
PROPOSAL IS CREATING A PUBLIC
PLATFORM TO REALLY LOOK AT ****
TRENDS DRIVERS OF THOSE TRENDS
AND STRATEGIES TO BRING THOSE
TRENDS DOWN. AND WE THINK THAT
THAT TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT AND
PUBLIC PLATFORM WELL REALLY
PROMOTE CHANGE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND HELP US PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY HEALTHCARE AT AT THE
SENIOR BOWL RATE- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- JANICE WAS CMA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JANICE
RONCO VICE PRESIDENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND COVERAGE ON
BEHALF OF THE NEARLY FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AT SEEM IS SUPPORTIVE OF
EFFORTS TO CURB COSTS WITHIN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM INCREASED
COMPETITION REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY IS AN
INCREASE CARE COORDINATION WE
DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL AND HAVE ASKED FOR
AMENDMENTS IN A NUMBER OF
AREAS. FIRST THE DEFINITION OF
PROVIDER IN THE PROPOSAL IS
OVERLY BROAD IT WOULD INCLUDE
ALL PHYSICIAN PRACTICES. WE'VE
ASKED FOR AMENDMENTS TO NARROW
THE DEFINITION OF PROVIDER IN
ORDER TO FOCUS ON THE REAL COST
RIGHT FIRST AND TO REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES. THERE ARE
VARIOUS ECONOMIC STUDIES THAT
INDICATE THAT HEALTHCARE COSTS
OF CALIFORNIA ARE DRIVEN
LARGELY BY THE CONSOLIDATED
HEALTH CARE MARKET IN WHICH
HEALTH INSURER THE HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET IS HIGHLY
CONCENTRATED. AND AS SUCH AS A
COSTS BETTER AND MORE THAN TWO
THIRDS OF COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE HOSPITAL MARKET
IS CONSIDERED HIGHLY
CONCENTRATE ON ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AND
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
GUIDELINES ACROSS TARGETS THAT
APPLY TO ALL PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES ARE OVERLY BURDENSOME
ON ENTITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
MARKET POWER TO SET PROVIDER
RATES. AND THEY'RE INCONSISTENT
WITH HOW OTHER STATES HAVE
HANDLED SIMILAR EFFORTS. AT
TUESDAY'S WERE RELEASED TODAY
THAT SHOW THAT WHEN HOSPITALS
ACQUIRE IS SURE PRACTICES COSTS
INCREASED. AND DONE INCORRECTLY
A PROPOSAL IN THIS VEIN- COULD
LEAD TO MORE SITUATIONS OF.
SMALLER PRACTICES BEING GOBBLED
UP BY OTHERS. I'M ANOTHER ISSUE
IS THAT WHEN COST CONTAINMENT
IS THE SOLE FOCUS WHEN YOU'RE
SENDING THE COST TARGETS WHEN
QUALITY- AND ACCESS ARE
ACTUALLY A PART OF THE TARGET
SETTING AS- AS A IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY- THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
A SEPARATE- PART OF THE BILL
WHERE THEY'RE- PART OF A
REPORT. FOR THE COST ANY- YOU
CAN INADVERTENTLY HARM QUALITY
AND ACCESS A CMA SUPPORTERS.
MANAKALA EXPANSION TO FOR
INSTANCE UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATIONS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE SHORT TERM
INCREASE COSTS OF PROVIDING
CARE. TO THOSE WHO LACK ACCESS.
TO HEALTH CARE- AND NO FROM
SHOULD BE. FOR SERVING A NEW
INSURED. WE ONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE OLD PRIZE HERE. TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT QUALITY EQUITY AND
ACCESS. THEM I ALSO BELIEVES
THAT WHO MAKES THE DECISION
ABOUT THE COST TARGET MATTERS
WE SUPPORT PUTTING THIS
CRITICAL DECISION IN THE HANDS
OF A STATEWIDE ELECTED OFFICIAL
WHETHER THAT BE THE GOVERNOR OR
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
EXPERIENCE TELLS US THAT HAVING
ONE APPOINTEE WHO'S NOT
DIRECTLY ACCOUNTABLE. TO THE
VOTERS IS NOT THE IDEAL WAY TO
GO UNDER PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
THAT WAS LESS FOCUSED ON HEALTH
CARE THAN THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION WE SAW FIRST
WITH HEALTH INSURANCE RATE
REVIEW. THAT THE ELECTED
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER WHO HAD
FAR FEWER COVERED LIVES IN THE
POLICIES THAT HE REGULATED THAN
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE WAS ABLE TO SAVE
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES FAR
MORE MONEY IN PREMIUM SAVINGS
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE. WE SAW IT AGAIN
WITH HEALTH INSURANCE MERGER
APPROVALS WHERE THE ELECTED
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER WORKED
WITH THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND MOST SUCCESSFUL AT
PREVENTING MERGERS. THAT WOULD
INCREASE HEALTH CARE COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE EITHER
APPROVED THE MERGERS- OR TOOK
NO POSITION ON THEM. THOSE ARE
JUST ALTERNATELY BLOCKED BY
COURTS CONSISTENT WITH WITH THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER WAS
ARGUING FOR. THE SYSTEM WE
BUILD HERE NEEDS TO LAST BEYOND
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION-
THERE ARE ALSO SOME TIMING
ISSUES AND WE THINK THAT THE
APC APC THE NEEDS TO BE UP AND
RUNNING BEFORE THE STATE. WOULD
BE IN A POSITION TO FINALIZE-
WHAT WE SHOULD BE CONSIDER.
CONSIDERING AND SETTING THE
COST TARGETS A CMA LOOKS
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE
DEMONSTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO BUILD SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
DRIVE COSTS DOWN FOR CONSUMERS
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
VOCAL- OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON WITH
THAT DENNIS O'MALLEY. PLEASE
WITH THE LABOR FOR IT. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. WORKING ON THE NEW
BUTTON HELLO CARE EGGMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MALLEY AND I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TOWARDS ISSUE THROUGH
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THE OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY THE CULMINATION
OF YEARS OF WORK ON BEHALF OF
LABOR AND STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE
MADE. MANY ATTEMPTS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO CONTROL
THE SKYROCKETING COSTS OF
HEALTH CARE. ALL THIS WORK HAS
LED US TO THIS POINT OF TAKING
A STRATEGIC DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH TO ANALYZE THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
TO GET AT THE ROOT PROBLEM OF
AFFORDABILITY QUALITY ACCESS
AND EQUITY. IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS FOR
EMPLOYER COVERAGE INCREASED BY
TWO HUNDRED AND 49% BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO AND TWO
THOUSAND SAYS SEVENTEEN. SIX
TIMES THE RATE OF INFLATION.
FOUR YEARS OUR MEMBERS HAVE
FORGONE WAGE INCREASES IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TO
MAINTAIN AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY HEALTH COVERAGE USUALLY
WITH MAJOR FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCES. MANY OF OUR
BARGAINING DISPUTES WITH
EMPLOYERS ARE TIED DIRECTLY TO
EMPLOYERS TRYING TO SHIFT THE
RISING COST OF HEALTHCARE ON TO
WORKERS IN THE FORM OF HIGHER
PREMIUMS AND HIGHER DEDUCTIBLES
AND CO PAYS. THIS IS NOT A
SUSTAINABLE WAY TO DO BUSINESS.
A HANDFUL OF STATES INCLUDING
MASSACHUSETTS MARYLAND RHODE
ISLAND AND OREGON HAVE STARTED
TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS BY TAKING
A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE
WHOLE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
PLEASE MODEL SERVE AS EVIDENCE
THAT SYSTEMS AFFECT STATE WHY
TARGET FOR REDUCING RATES.
INCREASING COST TRANSPARENCY
AND SUPPORTING EVIDENCE BASED
DATA COLLECTION CAN AND WILL
HELP CONSUMERS EMPLOYERS
WORKERS AND TAXPAYERS. THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN ADDRESSING THE SOARING
COST OF HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. HOWEVER WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ABILITY TO
PROTECT THE JOBS OF OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE AT THE
EXPENSE OF COST CONTAINMENT.
HEALTHCARE JOBS. ARE GOOD
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WITH HIGHLY
SKILLED AND VALUED PROFESSIONAL.
OFTENTIMES COST CUTTING
PROVISIONS MEANS THAT WORKERS
JOBS ARE TARGETED AS A COST
SAVINGS MEASURE WHICH LEADS TO
SHORT STAFFING HIGH TURNOVER
AND LOWER QUALITY OF CARE. WE
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS A
FAMILY MEMBER WITH THE OFFENSE
AND STRENGTHENING LANGUAGE THAT
RESPECT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT THE OFFICE SUGGESTS THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS TARGET OR ITS
APPROACHES AND NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT THE HEALTH WORKFORCE.
WORKFORCE IS STRENGTHENED BY
THIS PROPOSAL. INTO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTION ON HOW THE
OFFICE WOULD IMPACT WORKERS
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE IN THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES
FACE SIRIUS AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES ON ALL FRONTS DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC FROM HOUSING FOOD
TRANSPORTATION CHILD CARE AND
OTHER BASIC LIFE NECESSITIES.
THE RISING COST OF HEALTHCARE
IS UNSUSTAINABLE AND CONTINUES
TO BE AN ONGOING NATIONAL AND
STATE PROBLEM. LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME WORKERS AND CONSUMERS
ARE ESPECIALLY HARD HIT HARD
WITH THE HIGH COST OF CARE.
SUCH HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE
FURTHER CONTRIBUTING TO HEALTH
CARE INEQUALITY AS WORKERS FOR
THE WAGE INCREASES TO PAY FOR
INCREASING PREMIUMS DEDUCTIBLES
AND CO PAYS THAT FUND THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. ACCORDING TO
THE UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER
WORKERS WITH JOB BASED COVERAGE
AND THEIR EMPLOYERS WILL SPEND
AN ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS ON
PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET
COSTS AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS TO
PREMIUMS ULTIMATELY COME OUT OF
WORKERS POCKETS AS A PART AS
THEY ARE PART OF WORKERS TOTAL
COMPENSATION. IF WE DO NOT
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF HIGH COST.
COMBINED SPENDING COULD REACH
TWO HUNDRED AND SIX BILLION
DOLLARS BY TWENTY THIRTY FOUR.
BY IMPLEMENTING A MECHANISM
THAT WOULD CURTAIL THE RISING
COST OF CARE AND SHARING THOSE
COST SAVINGS BUT THE WORKERS
WHO'VE BEEN PAYING INTO THE
SYSTEM. WE BELIEVE THE CREATION
OF THE OFFICE WOULD RESULT IN
MEANINGFUL FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR
TAXPAYERS EMPLOYERS AND OUR
MEMBERS. WITH LOWER PREMIUMS
AND OUT OF POCKET COSTS THE
STATE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IN
FACT THE SAME ANALYSIS FROM UC
BERKELEY'S LABOR CENTER THAT I
CITED EARLIER ESTIMATES THAT IT
WOULD BE FORTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE THE AUTHOR
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CELICA BALANCE OF COST
CONTAINMENT. TO PROTECT WORKERS
AND HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE AS
WELL AS CONSUMERS AND PATIENTS
IN THE STATE. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU PASSED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MS YASMIN ALLEN
IS A PELLET. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ME PALLID WITH
BACK CAL. THE STATE WIDE
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COLA WE ARE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF CREATING THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
EVERY CALIFORNIA CONSUMER WITH
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE IS
BEING HIT BY THE RISING COST OF
HEALTHCARE THANK HIGHER
PREMIUMS DEDUCTIBLES AND COPAYS
AND FEELING THE IMPACT OF
STAGNATING WAGES. SO MANY
CONSUMERS FORGO CARE BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT AFFORD IT.
RESTRICTIONS DOCTORS VISITS LAB
TESTS OR OTHER NECESSARY KERR.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AIMS TO TAKE A
HOLISTIC APPROACH BY CONTAINING
HEALTHCARE COSTS RESULTING FROM
YEARS OF NEGOTIATIONS AND
GAUGING INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT WHAT CAN WORK THE OFFICE
WOULD SET ENFORCEABLE COST
TARGETS FOR THE ENTIRE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY AND HAVE
THE ABILITY TO LEVY FINANCIAL
PENALTIES OR OTHER CORRECTIVE
ACTION IF AN ENTITY EXCEEDS THE
TARGET. TARGETS WOULD BE SUPPLY
SECTOR AND WOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT REGIONAL VARIATION
RECOGNIZING THE DIFFERENCES AND
COMPLEXITIES IN CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. UNLIKE RATE
SETTING WHICH DETERMINES HOW
MUCH A DOCTOR'S VISIT OR
HOSPITAL STAY IS THE TARGET
SERVES AS AN OVERALL GOAL OF
THE INDUSTRY MUST MEET BUT
PROVIDES THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ACHIEVE IT IN A WAY THAT WORKS
BEST. WELL ALL PARTS OF THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE OFFICE AND THE
COST HER GUESTS HEARD ME SOME
PARTS OF THE INDUSTRY UNDERGO
MORE SCRUTINY THAN OTHERS FOR
INSTANCE CALIFORNIA HAS AN
EXTENSIVE AND ROBUST RATE
REVIEW PROGRAM FOR HEALTH PLANS
AND HEALTH INSURANCE. WHICH HAS
PROVIDED A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION AND OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS FOR CONSUMERS HOWEVER
FOR PROVIDERS LIKE MEDICAL
GROUPS AND HOSPITALS THERE'S
MUCH LESS OVERSIGHT AND.
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CUSTOMER'S.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE. AGENCY OVER
SPECIFIC PARTS OF THE INDUSTRY
BUT NO AGENCY TASKED WITH
LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE HEALTH
CARE SECTOR MUCH LESS SETTING
GOALS FOR AFFORDABILITY QUALITY
AND EQUITY. AND WE WILL NEVER
MEET A GOAL THAT WE DON'T SIX.
THANK TO THE COMMITTEE'S
QUESTIONS WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSED OFFICE WOULD HAVE
BROAD IMPACTS FOR CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA. FIRST AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY RESEARCH ANALYSIS
FROM BOTH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE FOUNDATION AND THE UC
BERKELEY LABOR CENTER SHOW THAT
USING AN APPROACH LIKE THE
OFFICE COULD SAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. RESULTING IN LOWER
PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS. ON THE SECOND QUESTION
IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
ARE THE ONES PAYING THE BILLS.
IT HOSPITALS AND MEDICAL GROUPS
RAISE THEIR PRICES INSURERS
JUST RAISE PREMIUMS OR INCREASE
COST SHARING. EMPLOYERS MAY
TAKE ON WAGES OR INCREASE YOUR
PREMIUM OR DEDUCTIBLES FOR
WORKERS. ONE RESULT HAS BEEN
THE GROWTH OF HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLANS EXPOSING CONSUMERS
TO EXTREMELY HIGH COSTS OFTEN
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
EXPOSURE BEFORE COVERAGE EVEN
KICKS IN. THE DATA SHOWS AGAIN
AND AGAIN BUT THE MAIN COST
DRIVER AND HEALTH CARE IS NOT
HIGH UTILIZATION BUT HIGHER
PRICES. AND THOSE HIGH PRICES
ARE NOT CORRELATED WITH MORE
CARE OR BETTER CARE. WELL THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM INDUSTRY HAS
GOTTEN VERY SOPHISTICATED ON
HOW IT CAN MAXIMIZE PROFITS FOR
EXECUTIVES AND SHAREHOLDERS THE
OFFICE WILL FOCUS THE INDUSTRY
ON HOW TO PROVIDE A REAL
AFFORDABILITY TO CALIFORNIA.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
PLEASED TO PROPOSE TO SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
DIRECTOR SO I WENT OUT OF ORDER
BUT MAYBE IT'S NICE FOR YOU TO
COME BACK NOW. AND BE ABLE TO.
DO PRESENTATION ABOUT WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD FROM. THE ADVOCATES SAY
LIKE IT. AND THEN PROVIDERS NOT
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND- EVERYONE GOT A BREAK FROM
HEARING FROM ME AND I GOT TO
HAVE A DRINK OF WATER SO. HAPPY
TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON ON
WHERE WE ARE IN THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY.
PROPOSAL WHICH WE KNOWLEDGE
THAT THE COMMITTEE PREVIOUSLY
HEARD IN FEBRUARY- SO JUST TO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE NOT YET
MODIFIED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. BUT IS
NOTED WE'VE BEEN COLLABORATING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT'S
OFFICE AND TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
OFFICE- SO THESE CONVERSATIONS
ARE UNDER OUR ONGOING. BUT I'M
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHANGES THAT. HAVE BEEN MADE ON
THE BILL AS A RESULT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS. SO WE'VE HEARD A
LOT EARLY ON ABOUT CONCERNS
ABOUT THE REPORTING TIMELINE.
OUR DUTY IMPACT OF THE- SO
FOLKS OF WE WE'VE HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT THE IMPACT THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. SO IN TERMS
OF THE DATA AND THE YEAR IS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO. WE'RE
PROPOSING TO HAVE- DATA
COLLECTED. FOR TWENTY TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TO RELEASE TRY TO
LOOK AT THE WHAT THE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC WAS IN TERMS OF
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE. DATA
THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATED WITH HIS
INITIAL DATA SET. FOR WITH THE
BASELINE DATA SO WE'RE LOOKING
TO PUSH OUT- SO THAT THE YEARS
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WHAT ESTABLISH THE
BASELINE- AND OFSHE HEAD WOULD
REPORT ON THIS DATA- IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE FIRST YEAR
THAT THERE WOULD BE- A
MEASUREMENT AGAINST OUR COST
TARGET WOULD BE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR DATA. AND THEN THE
FIRST TIME THERE WOULD BE
SECTOR SPECIFIC TARGETS BE
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN SO ALL THAT
TO SAY IS WE'VE HEARD FROM
FOLKS YOU KNOW PANDEMIC DATA IS
NOT- SHOULDN'T BE THE BASS
LINE. AND SO WE PUSHED ALL
THOSE TIME FRAMES OUT. WE'VE
HEARD A VARIETY OF TYPES OF
FEEDBACK ABOUT THE COMPOSITION
OF THE ADVISORY BOARD AND
AGREED WITH ADDING TWO MORE
MEMBERS TO BRING THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE-
ADVISORY BOARD TO ELEVEN- ONE
MEMBER WHAT EXPLICITLY
REPRESENTED PURCHASER OF HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE YOUR BENEFITS.
WITH EXPERIENCE AND HELPFUL
EVERY FINANCING MANAGEMENT OR
ADMINISTRATION AND WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING TO ADD ON THE CALPERS
CHIEF HEALTH DIRECTOR OR THEIR
DESIGNEES- ON THE HEALTH CARE
COST TARGETS. WE'VE AGREED WITH
CLARIFYING THAT THE ARCH THAT
DIRECTOR CAN YOU JUST COST
TARGETS BY GEOGRAPHIC REGION
SUBREGION SUBREGION- AND
SECTORS. IN THE EVENT THAT THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR DETERMINES
THE COST TARGET TO DIFFER FROM
THE COST TARGET RECORD
RECOMMENDED BY THE BOARD THE
DIRECTOR WOULD HAVE TO ISSUE A
PUBLIC REPORT ON ALTERNATE COST
TARGETS DEMONSTRATING THAT THE
ALTERNATE TARGET WOULD RESULT
IN GREATER SAVINGS HEALTHCARE
CONSUMERS. THAN THAT SET BY THE
BOARD WITHOUT REDUCING THE
QUALITY OF CARE. WE'VE ALSO
HEARD CONCERNS REMAIN ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT APPROACH SO REALLY
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
FUNDING FOR SMALLER PROJECT THE
OFFICE WOULD BE- VERY
PROGRESSIVE IN NATURE- WE WOULD
SEEK TO ASSIST HEALTHCARE
ENTITIES. THAT COME INTO
COMPLIANCE INCLUDING THROUGHOUT
REACH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS BEFORE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES UNLESS
THE VIOLATION IS EGREGIOUS. AN
EXAMPLE OF A GRADE JUST
VIOLATIONS WHEN MERITED
MINISTRY TO PENALTIES WOULD BE
REPEATED FAILURE TO FILE A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN FOR
EXAMPLE OR REPEATED FAILURE TO
IMPLEMENT- I CORRECTED.
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS. FOR
INVESTMENTS IN CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WE ALSO AGREE
WITH REQUIRING THE SPENDING
BENCHMARKS FOR PRIMARY CARE TO
CONSIDER CURRENTLY FORM UNDER
FUNDING OF PRIMARY CARE
SERVICES AND ISSUE RAISED BY-
THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND ON
HEALTHCARE WORK FOR STABILITY
WE AGREE THAT IN PURSUING
AFFORDABILITY WE WOULD
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO BOTH
MAINTAIN AND INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS
AND TO RESPECT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS. WE ALSO
AGREE WITH THE CLARIFICATIONS
AS TO WHAT THE OFFICES ROLE
WOULD BE WITH RESPECT TO
CONSOLIDATION MAKING CLEAR THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN OFFICE AND
THOSE KIND OF EXISTING
JURISDICTIONS IN THOSE AREAS.
SO THIS IS SUMMARIZES SOME OF
THE ISSUES WE'VE WORKED OUT-
WHICH I THINK REFLECTS A LOT OF
ENGAGEMENT ON BY ALL OF THE
PARTIES REPRESENTED HERE TODAY
AS WELL AS OTHERS AND AGAIN
REALLY WANT TO STRESS THAT
THERE ARE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS.
LEGISLATIVE ENGAGEMENT IS
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
OFFICE AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO BE
HERE TO LISTEN TO YOUR FEEDBACK
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JOHN CAN WE GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI
AN APARTMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE L. A. O. THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN HAVE COREY SHE
CAN FROM THE L. A. ALL THREE
VERY BRIEF AGAIN- WE JUST HAVE
A FEW BRIEF COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL GENERALLY YOU KNOW IN
A MAJOR CONCERNS TO RAISE JUST
A FEW. CONSIDERATIONS TO BRING
UP GOING FORWARD- YOU KNOW WE
FIND THAT THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THIS OFFICE WHICH YOU KNOW
GENERALLY AS THE GOAL OF
CONTAINING ESCALATING HEALTH
CARE COSTS ACROSS THE STATE
MAKES SENSE IN CONCERT- IS A
METHOD TO RESPOND TO THE
STATE'S AFFORDABILITY ISSUES-
YOU KNOW WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCE REQUESTS
YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY RAMPING UP
TO. OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
POSITIONS IN ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN A FEW YEARS-
AND THAT THIS OFFICE IS LIKELY
GOING TO BE VERY
ADMINISTRATIVELY COMPLEX TO
IMPLEMENT- THERE ARE A
MULTITUDE OF ENTITIES AS
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. BE THERE PROVIDED
ME THEY PROVIDERS OR PAYERS AND
THIS OFFICE IS GOING TO NEED TO
DETERMINE YOU KNOW WHAT
INFORMATION TO COLLECT AND WHAT
TARGETS THESE ENTITIES WILL
NEED TO MEET A WHICH IS GOING
TO BE A VERY SIGNIFICANT LIFT-
YOU KNOW AS SUCH YOU KNOW GOING
FORWARD THE LEGISLATURE ME ONE
OF MONITOR SORT OF THE PROGRESS
TOWARDS FULLY IMPLEMENTING-
THIS PROPOSED OFFICES. STUDENTS
GOING FORWARD YOU KNOW THIS
COULD INCLUDE CHECKING IN WITH
SOME DEGREE OF REGULARITY ON
WHETHER THE LEVEL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES
ATTACHED TO THIS PROPOSAL ARE
OUR PROCREATE- YOU KNOW THIS
WOULD BE ESPECIALLY HELPFUL
GIVEN THAT YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TO SOME
EXTENT. BASING ITS RESOURCE
REQUEST WAS ALSO ON ACTIVITIES
IN ANOTHER STATE- WHICH MAY NOT
BE DIRECTLY COMPARABLE SAID TO
CALIFORNIA'S SITUATIONS. THAT
THAT SOME ALL OR COMMENTS. ON
THIS ISSUE THANK VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND DIRECT
I WOULD HAVE- COMMITTEE I THINK
WE PROBABLY. ALL WE ALL SEE THE
NEED FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS
AND ANNA- IN MY EARLIER
CONVERSATIONS WITH DOCTOR
WOULD. TWIN THE QUESTIONS I ASK
WHAT TOOK US SO LONG TO GET
HERE ECAUSE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PLACE AND CAN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO BE
HAVING. BUT OF COURSE. IT'S YOU
KNOW IT'S ALWAYS IN IN GETTING
IT DONE- CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE
BITABOUT AND I KNOW. I KNOW
WE'RE TALKING. ALSO ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF A- OF ACCESS AND
EQUITY- BUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
A SITTING DIFFERENT TARGETS FOR
DIFFERENT REGIONS AROUND THE
STATE. ONE OF THE ISSUES OF
COURSE WE HAVE IS NOT HAVING
ENOUGH HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AND IN MORE RURAL AREAS AND IN
MORE. AREAS WHERE- MAYBE THE
QUALITY OF LIVING ISN'T QUITE
AS GLAMOROUS OR R. OR THE PAY
IS NOT QUITE AS HIGH- CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THEN HOW DO HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE MAINTAIN.
A PROVIDERS IN ALL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA HAS WE REALLY LOOK
GOING TOWARD COST CONTAINMENT-
HOW ARE WE MAKING SURE WE
BALANCE. REGIONAL EQUITY AS
WELL AS COST CONTAINMENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I
THINK IT'S A CRITICAL ISSUE AND
ONE THAT WE DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT
AS MUCH TODAY BUT WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR AGAIN THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE OFFICE IS- NOT
TO HAVE A RACE TO THE BOTTOM
RIGHT WE DON'T WANT TO CONTROL
COSTS. BY PUTTING ADDITIONAL
PRESSURE ON THE SYSTEM SUCH
THAT WE LOSE PROVIDERS QUITE
THE OPPOSITE SO AS YOU NOTED WE
DO HAVE COMPONENTS THAT LOOK TO
MEASURE QUALITY- AND EQUITY AND
WE WANT TO LEVERAGE THE WORK
BEING DONE BY FIVE MEDIC CAL
AND- COVER CALIFORNIAN DMH SEAT
AND OTHERS IN TERMS OF QUALITY
IN EQUITY METRICS. AND THEN IN
TERMS OF PRIMARY CARE YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTION AND THE
OFFICE WOULD SPECIFICALLY
MEASURE AND PROMOTE OF A
BASELINE SPENT ON PRIMARY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SO THERE'S A
LOT OF RESEARCH SHOWING THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE ENOUGH
INVESTMENT IN PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND THAT
THAT INVESTMENT IN TURN HELPS
BRING DOWN COSTS AND SO WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT- ON A
REGIONAL BASIS JUST TRY TO
ADDRESS EXACTLY THE QUESTION
THAT. YOU CONCERNED THAT YOU
POSE. OKAY THANK YOU I'M.
MASTAKA PANDACAN. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I DO HAVE QUITE A
FEW QUESTIONS. PRECIADO THAT'S-
AND I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION- AND- I GUESS I
WOULD JUST FIRST OF ALL- START
OFF BY SAYING YOU KNOW MY
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IS THAT
I'M A PHYSICIAN. AND I TAKE
YOUR PEOPLE UNDER SEC- I ALSO
TRIED PREVENT DISEASES WELL
EFFECTIVE FEATURES AND THAT'S
WHAT SPEND MOST MY TIME BUT
ALSO KNOWLEDGE THAT PROBABLY
FROM SPENDING POINT OF VIEW IF
THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY- HAVE
HEALTH CARE NEEDS. IN FACT-
LET'S REMEMBER THAT PEOPLE
CHRONIC DISEASE- SPEND ABOUT
7080% OF HEALTHCARE COSTS-
THERE ABOUT 40% OF
CALIFORNIANS- SO AS WE TRY TO
CAP OFF COSTS JUST KEEP IN MIND
WHO WERE TALKING ABOUT. IN FACT
THE SICKEST 10% SPEND ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF ALL HEALTH CARE
SPENDING SO- SO JUST BEGAN A
REMINDER OF WHO WERE IMPACTING-
AND THEIR ACCESS TO CARE AS
WELL. I ALSO THINK IT'S
INTERESTING I DO NOTE THAT INTO
TESTIMONY- WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- MEDICARE AND SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT MEDICARE'S
FACED- IN TERMS OF THEIR
PAYMENT- THE SVR WHO WAS A
FAILED ATTEMPT BY CONGRESS TO
TIE. PAYMENTS TO- ESSENTIALLY
THE G. P. AND- OVER SEVERAL
YEARS IN FACT OVER MORE IN A
DECADE THAT BECAME A DISASTER
AND FINALLY CONGRESS HAD TO
STEP IN AND FIX THAT- BECAUSE
IT WAS IT WAS AN ATTEMPT TO TRY
TO QUOTE PEAK YOU KNOW THINGS
MORE AFFORDABLE OR TO. LIMIT
SPENDING BUT BECAUSE IT IN
ACTUALLY TIED IT TO AND
ECONOMIC DATA MARKER THAT WAS
NOT RELATED TO ACTUAL HEALTH
CARE NEEDS IT CERTAINLY CAUSED
ALL SORTS OF PROBLEMS THE OTHER
THING ACTUALLY APPROVE APROPOS
WAS IS REGARDING- PAYMENT
RATES. AS WELL FOR DIFFERENT
REGIONS- AND MEDICARE ACTUALLY
THE ESTABLISHED REGIONS WHEN
MEDICARE WAS ESTABLISHED
ANSWERS ENOUGH SACRAMENTO AT
THE TIME I KNOW SOME PEOPLE
CALL US A COW TOWN IT'LL THE
CORE CAL TOWN BUT- YOU KNOW WE
WILL CONSIDER RULE ACTUALLY
WHEN MEDICARE WAS ESTABLISHED.
IN FACT- THE PROBLEM WAS IS
THAT THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR AREAS LIKE SACRAMENTO EVEN
THOSE WE BECAME MORE URBANIZED
AND- AND ACTUALLY COSTS A
PRACTICE WENT UP WE WERE STILL
REIMBURSE. WISE FOR MEDICARE TO
BEING- SAY AS THE OTHER
COMMUNITIES THAT DIDN'T REFLECT
OUR THE COST OF A PRACTICE SO.
AGAIN I THINK REGIONAL
ADJUSTMENTS ARE GONNA BE
IMPORTANT BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
REFLECT THIS AND I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR BRING OUT- ISSUE THAT
OFTEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
SOMEONE HAS SOME COST ANALYSIS
AS- YEAH RULED PRACTICES. WHAT
CHEAPER BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT THE
ONLY YEAH. THAT RENTAL COSTS
OTHER TYPES OF EXPENSES ARE ARE
PERHAPS LESS BUT THEN THAT
BECOMES A DISINCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE TEND TO GO INTO
PRACTICE. IN THIS AREA SO. THAT
WILL BE HAVE TO BE MONITORED
CAREFULLY- BUT I GUESS THE
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE THE DIRECTOR-
MENTIONING ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
L. TALKING TO- DOCTOR WOULD DO
IS CARRYING A BILL- THAT- WE'RE
THE SENATE HERE. SO THERE'S TWO
HOUSES THE LEGISLATURE I TAP
INTO CHAIRED A HEALTH COMMITTEE
IN THE SENATE TO AND DOES SO I
HAVEN'T HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
AT ALL WITH THAT. DIRECTOR
LANDS VERY ABOUT THIS- WHEN AM
I GOING TO HEAR FROM YOU ABOUT
A DETAILED POLICY DISCUSSION.
IN REGARD TO THIS AND IS THE
PLAN ADMINISTRATION TO SIMPLY
IMPLEMENT THIS THROUGH THE
BUDGET ARE THERE IS DOCTOR
WOODS- ASSEMBLY RELIGIOUS-
BILL'S GOING TO BE THE VEHICLE
AND SO WE'LL HAVE A- FULL
POLICY DISCUSSION. HERE IN THE
SENATE AS WELL IN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. SO CAN YOU
PLEASE. TELL ME WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTENTIONS ARE.
WELL SAID MANAGE YOU KNOW THE
IS BUDGET PROPOSAL. IT IS A
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
THERE IS THE PARALLEL. OF
POLICY BILL AS AS YOU REFERENCE
AND SO AT THIS POINT. IT'S UP
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PROCESS TO WORK ITS WAY THROUGH
AS AS WHICH VEHICLE MOVES OKAY
WELL AND YES IT IS THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE END THAT
WILL DECIDE- BUT WHAT IS. THE
PREFERENCE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE DO NOT HAVE
A STATED PREFERENCE AT THAT AT
THIS TIME SAID OR OKAY SO- AND-
SO I GUESS I WOULD MAKE NO THEN
IS THAT- CERTAINLY WE WOULD
WANT TO POLICY VETTING. OF THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE SENATE- SO
WHICH WHICHEVER THROUGHOUT
EVERY VENUE- WHAT IS THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE PROPOSAL
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT-
SUMMER WOODS BILL AT THE TIME
IT'S A- PASSED OUT OF THE-
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND
ASSEMBLY. WAS DESCRIBED
MERRILEES WORK IN PROGRESS I
HEAR YOU SAY THEY'RE STILL.
EVEN THOUGH YOU DID SAY A FEW
THINGS THAT WERE HAPPENING.
IT'S STILL WORK IN PROGRESS MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM TALKING TO
STAFF IN THE SUB COMMITTEE THAT
IT THAT THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
MISSING PIECES- WHAT WHAT POINT
TIME WE HAVE A FULL PROPOSAL SO
WE COULD DO A FULL POLICY
GUIDING. SO IN TERMS I DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD- ALSO WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING TO HIS OFFICE- AS WELL
AS TALKING TO STAKEHOLDERS. SO
AS YOU NOTED THERE WERE SOME-
THAT. AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
TAKEN AND IN POLICY COMMITTEE
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE
MAY BE AN ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS. BEING TAKEN ON
THEIR PREPARATIONS AND WE ARE
WORKING TO TRY TO SORT THROUGH
ALL OF THE- POLICY ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. OKAY SO I GUESS I'M
ONE OF THOSE WHEN SHOULD I
EXPECT SINCE I ALSO SUB UPSET
ON THE SUB COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
CHAIRED HEALTH COMMITTEE WHEN
CAN I EXPECT A FULL POLICY
PROPOSAL. TO REVIEW- PRIOR TO
BEING EXPECTED TO VOTE ON IT.
WHETHER IT'S IN POLICY OR AND
WHETHER IT'S IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE OR AND- POLICY
COMMITTEE. AS NOTED SENATOR WE
ARE WE ARE WORKING- AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN TO TRY TO RESOLVE ALL
THE ISSUES I DON'T HAVE AN
EXACT DATE FOR YOU BUT
CERTAINLY NOTE- THAT THEY NEED
TO TRY TO RESOLVE THE PLAN.
THAT THE REMAINING ISSUES SO DO
I HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM YOU TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH ME
ASSURE THE HEALTH COMMITTEE IN
THE SENATE. OF COURSE INSTITUTE
ABOUT BEFORE- THIS. BEFORE THIS
COMES UP FOR A VOTE AND THE
LEGISLATURE WHETHER IT'S AND
BUDGET OR IN POP INCIDENT AND
IN THE- SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. OF COURSE IN YOUR
PANTS OKAY. ALL RIGHT- I DO
HAVE SEVERAL. QUESTIONS TO HELP
ME FLESH OUT AT LEAST SOME OF
THE POLICY ISSUES. HERE SO YOU
KNOW YOU DO REFERENCE THERE
WERE. CERTAIN CAL STATES FOR
SPENDING TARGETS INCLUDING
CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE. WHAT
KIND OF DATA DOES YOUR- DOES
DID THE ADMINISTRATION OR YOUR-
NOW DEPARTMENT I GUESS MY NAME
IS A DEPARTMENT. OF THE OFFICE.
WITH THAT DO YOU FEEL WILL BE
REQUIRED IN ORDER TO APPROACH
POLICE. ESTABLISH. EVIDENCE
BASED SPENDING TARGETS. SO WE
SEEK TO COLLECT SOME DATA ON
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE AND SO
THAT IS BOTH ACCESSING DATA
THAT'S AVAILABLE- THROUGH YOUR
REACHES ENTITIES NOW BUT IT'S
REALLY IT'S PRIMARILY
COLLECTING DATA FROM THE
PAYERS- AS YOU. THE TOTAL COST
OF CARE INCLUDES- PREMIUM
PAYMENTS SO THAT AS YOU KNOW
THE APCD R. R. H. P. D.
DATABASE PROGRAM IS PRIMARILY
LOOKING AT CLAIMS. AND THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND IN GATHERING
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE DATA
WILL LOCK IN ADDITION TOUGH
CLAIMS PAID- WILL ALSO LOOK AT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. PREMIUM
PAYMENTS COPAYS THAT ARE MADE
BY- THE CONSUMERS. AND WILL
LOOK AT BOTH CLAIMS. AND NON
THINGS OKAY. OKAY SO ON THE
SIDE WHAT WHAT IS WHAT IS THE
STATUS OF THE PLAYERS CLAIMS
DATABASES IT UP AND RUNNING
FULLY OR YOU FULLY COLLECTING
OR WHEN YOU EXPECT THAT TO
HAPPEN BYE IT IS NOT FULLY UP
AND RUNNING AND I'M GONNA SEE
IF MIKE VALLEY CAN. CAN JUMP
AND ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
EXACTLY WHEN WILL HAVE ALL THAT
DATA BUT JUST TO NOTICE AS YOU
AND I DISCUSSED BRIBERY WE
DON'T NEED ALL THE DATA FROM
THE- FROM THE- H. P. D. IN
ORDER TO HAVE THAT CAPTURE THE
TOTAL COSTS OF WHERE AND WHEN
DID YOU EXPECT ALL THE DATA.
MIKE VALLEY ARE YOU THERE. I AM
HERE THANK. YOU THANK YOU
DIRECTOR LANDSBERG AND THANK
YOU CENTER BRADFORD FOR THE
QUESTION- REGARDING THE
HEALTHCARE PAYMENTS- DATABASE
IMPLEMENTATION- CALIFORNIA'S
AUTHOR CLAIMS IT REYES WE ARE
ON TRACK AND MAKING PROGRESS TO
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE THE
DATABASE BY JULY. ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AS DESCRIBED IN.
IN STATUTE WERE WERE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- AS WELL AS
COLLEAGUES OF THE CALIFORNIA
PART OF TECHNOLOGY ON. ON THE
DETAILED IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE FOR THE DATABASE
ITSELF. A NUMBER ALSO ON TRACK
TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS FOR
DATA COLLECTION CURRENTLY UNDER
DEVELOPMENT AND WILL BE A
PLACE. DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO WE WOULD
EXPECT TO HAVE AT LEAST THREE
YEARS OF HISTORICAL DATA
AVAILABLE WHEN. A DATABASE
FINANCIALLY COMPLETE JULY
TWENTY THREE OKAY APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU. I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT WHILE THERE WAS WELL
SAID THAT YOU DON'T NEED ALL
THE INFORMATION I WAS EXPECTED
NEEDS A SUBSTANTIAL. PORTION
THIS INVESTORS- INFORMATION SO
THAT'S THAT THAT IS AND THEN
SOMEONE NEEDS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT SO JUST COLLECTING THE DATA.
DATA. ANALYSIS TAKES TIME AS
WELL SO THERE'S- A BRIEF TIME
TO. JANUARY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY FOUR. SO ASIDE
FROM THIS PAYMENT DATA- YOU
KNOW HEALTH CARES ABOUT HEALTH.
SO ASIDE FROM THE PAYMENT DATA
WHAT WHAT OTHER INPUTS ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR THAT YOU TINK ARE
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A
SPENDING TARGET. WELL AS YOU
KNOW WE WILL BE COLLECTING DATA
ON ON QUALITY AND EQUITY- AND
SO WE WILL WANT TO DO THAT IN
TANDEM BEFORE THERE IS ANY
ENFORCEABLE COST TARGET THAT IS
SET AND WHAT KIND OF- AND YOU
CAN USE. SO FOR EXAMPLE QUALITY
DATA. WHAT KIND OF QUALITY DATA
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR THAT YOU
THAT YOU NEED TO COLLECT. SO WE
WANT TO LEVERAGE EXISTING
EFFORTS- TO NOT UNNECESSARILY
DUPLICATE SO I KNOW THE NEXT
ITEM YOU'RE HEARING IS ABOUT
THE NHC'S PROPOSAL IS THAT
QUALITY AND EQUITY METRICS WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
EFFORTS UNDERWAY WITH MEDIC
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA WITH
HEALTH FIRST. SO WE WILL HAVE A
SUBSET OF OUR STAFF- AND
RESEARCHERS THAT ARE LOOKING AT
US SAID OF QUALITY DATA- AGAIN
WANTING TO LEVERAGE EXISTING-
SELECTED. OF MEASURES BUT WE
NEED TO HAVE THOSE IN PLACE SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
QUALITY IS NOT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED OKAY AS WE OPPOSE THE
PAST ARE NO I AM AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK ONE NO
TO SOMEONE WHO'S ALSO DONE
RESEARCH IN QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT- IS THAT. QUALITY
DATA IS OF COURSE MOST USUALLY
AVAILABLE AND DISEASES THAT ARE
FAIRLY WIDESPREAD- THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE IT.
CERTAINLY IT'S A LOT EASIER TO
COLLECT THE GETS MORE
CHALLENGING WE TALK ABOUT RARE
CONDITIONS FUND US THEY'RE JUST
MUCH SMALLER PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE- THAT- THERE- AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU LOOK AT NCQA
OR YOU LOOK AT HE TO YOU KNOW
THE IS VERY STATUS AT C.
DISCOURSE BASED ON MINISTRY OF
DATA- YOU KNOW IT'S- WELL
CERTAINLY THE- CAN BE. HELPFUL
AND YOU LOOK AT THE LIKE. OR
DIABETES USUALLY HAVE LIKE AND
LARGE NUMBERS WHEN YOU START
TALKING TO SMALLER NUMBERS.
ALTHOUGH HUMILIATE ALL THE
SMALL OF THE SMALL NUMBER
CONDITIONS ALTOGETHER IT'S ARE
ACTUALLY STARTS TO BECOME A
FAIRLY LARGE NMBER- BUT THE
QUALITY DATA IS MUCH MORE
CHALLENGING. AND THE SOMEONE
WHO'S ACTUALLY BEEN INVOLVED
IN- DOING QUALITY DATA
ANALYSIS. I THINK HOPEFULLY IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
BE KNOWLEDGE TO FIGHT AND IT
DIDN'T AND THE STUDIES OF THE
TASK FORCE IS THAT WE'RE NOT
OVERLY FOCUS JUST ON THE-
CONDITIONS THAT. THAT OBVIOUSLY
THEY DO HAVE A LARGER IMPACT.
ON ON SPENDING BUT THE OTHER
ONE'S HUMILITY. ALSO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON SPENDING.
YES THERE IS A THIS IS ALWAYS
THE HEARING YOU HAVE A LOT OF
IMPORTANT EXPERTISE AND SO WE
DO PLAN TO BRING IT YOU KNOW
WORK OFF OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MODELS AND SO I THINK YOUR
POINT IS VERY WELL TAKEN THAT-
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT
WIDESPREAD DISEASES LIKE LIKE
DIABETES AND OTHER CHRONIC
CONDITIONS AS WELL AS- THERE'S
LESS FREQUENT BUT BUT VERY
IMPACTFUL. LOCATIONS AS WELL SO
I JUST MAKE NOTE THAT THERE MAY
NOT BE DATA AT YOU KNOW THERE
THERE MAY BE DATA VOIGTS OKAY
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S HARD TO
COLLECTED ON THESE. SMALL
CONDITIONS I'M NOT SAYING THAT-
AND I THINK SO YOU NEED TO BE
SURE THERE'S ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY
TO DEAL WITH THE DATA VOID
ISSUE- THAT YOU DON'T SIMPLY
SAY HELP BECAUSE THERE'S NO
DATA THEREFORE WE DON'T HAVE
TO. ARE WE YOU KNOW THE
EXPANDING PART- YOU'D BE
BASICALLY I THOUGHT U. ZERO
ALTO OR- OR UNDERESTIMATE SO I
JUST WANNA POINT THAT OUT AND
THEN CERTAINLY EQUITY WHICH I.
KNOW WILL HERE FROM THE NDC.
THE I OFTENTIMES SOME ISSUE
HARM PLACE BECAUSE- THE VERY
SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE LESS
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
OFTENTIMES HAVE LESS ACCESS TO
PEOPLE ACTUALLY STUDY HOW WELL
THEY'RE DOING. UNFORTUNATELY
AND- SO. AGAIN EQUITY
FRAMEWORK. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE SO. I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT AS A
SOMEONE WHO IS- ASIAN. TO
REPLICATE CHAIRS THE ATI CAUCUS
AND- IT IS- ASIAN THAT-
ACTUALLY I THINK ONLY IS VERY
SMALL FRACTION OF STUDIES HAVE
YOU GO LOOK AT THE LITERATURE
PUBLISHED LITERATURE. ACTUALLY
INCLUDE ATI IS A CATEGORY THAT
THEY STUDIED. WE'RE USUALLY NOT
THERE. WE DON'T EXIST. AND YET
OUR COMMUNITY WHICH REPRESENTS
60% OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE GONNA
BE COUNTING ON YOU TO NOT TO
MAKE US DISAPPEAR. EVEN THOUGH
THE RESEARCH DATA ISN'T THERE
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T STUDIES.
AND I HOPE I CAN COUNT ON YOU
TO NOT DO THAT TO US. LOU THANK
YOU FOR FLAGGING OUT OF. SELF
AGAIN AS A DATA VOIGTS RIGHT.
NOW THE OTHER ISSUE I ACTUALLY
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT IS- THE
ADVISORY BOARD AND IT WAS
BROUGHT UP BUT- WHAT. HE'D
SPEAK TO THE INDEPENDENCE OF
THE ADVISORY BOARD TO YOU KNOW
I'M I'M ELECTED OFFICIAL SAYS
ONLY RESPONSIBLE TO VOTERS AND
I BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE NEED TO
BE ACCOUNTABLE- BUT WE ALSO
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
ARGUMENT THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
OVERLY- INFLUENCED BY POLITICAL
AND FOR THE ADDRESS WITH
BASICALLY SHOULD BE DRIVEN BY.
EVIDENCE AND DATA SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO WHAT IS THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD FROM LET'S SAY THE
GOVERNOR OR OTHER ELECTED-
BODIES. CERTAINLY CENTER PAINS
OF THE CURRENT- PROPOSED
STRUCTURE THAT WE PUT FORWARD
DOES HAVE THE ADVISORY BOARD
BEING PRIMARILY APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY WITH US
A FEW EX OFFICIO. MEMBER ON THE
FX TERMS WHERE THEY CANNOT FEED
THAT DID ARE THEY SERVING AT
WILL OR THE- ACTUALLY ONCE ARE
POINTED THEY- HAVE SUFFICIENT
TERMS IN THAT ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO. DISMISSAL UNLESS OBVIOUSLY
IF THEY COMPASSIONATE TO COMMIT
SOME EGREGIOUS ACT OR SOMETHING
SO IS THERE DEBT LEVEL OF
INDEPENDENCE. I BELIEVE THERE
ARE FIXED TERMS YES OKAY ALL
RIGHT I WOULD CERTAINLY AGAIN
WHAT IS POLICY THINGS I WOULD
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT. AND THEN THAT DID COME
UP WITH THE F. DEFINITION OF A
PROVIDER AND AGAIN I HAVEN'T
SEEN THE SPECIFICS- SO- AND IT
WAS MEN. BY CMA. THAT FOR
EXAMPLE A SOLO PRACTICE DOCTOR
WOULD BE CONSIDERED A PROVIDER-
IT IS SOAKING FIRST OF ALL CAN
YOU TELL ME THAT'S TRUE AND
THEN LET'S SEE A DENTIST IS A
DENTIST A PROVIDER UNDER JUST
DEFINITIONS THAT WOULD FALL
UNDER THE SAME THING. AND THEN
FINALLY A CHIROPRACTOR WITH
THEY ALSO FALL UNDER THE
DEFINITION AS WELL. SO AN YOU
SELL INDIVIDUAL SOLO PRACTICE
PHYSICIAN INDEPENDENT PRACTICE.
DENTIST AND THE CNTRACTOR. BUT
ALSO UNDER THE PHOENICIAN. YOUR
LAST POINT I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THE YES THE LITTLE
ADVISORY BOARD MEMBERS WOULD
SERVE- FOR FOUR YEARS SO WANTED
TO PUT THAT OUT THERE IN TERMS
OF WHETHER A SINGLE
PRACTITIONER WOULD. BE SUBJECT
TO THE COST TARGET- NO THEY
CERTAINLY WOULD NOT- THE BILL
THAT WE ARE RELEASED IN. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE OF THE
MEASURES RELEASED IN EARLY
FEBRUARY LEAVES OPEN THE
DEFINITION OF A HEALTH CARE
ENTITY THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
COST TARGET WE WILL LEAVE THAT
UP TO REGULATIONS- WE
UNDERSTAND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. THERE'S THAT THAT
DEFINITION B. B. SEVEN STATURE
IS ARE WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING- ON WHAT THE NUMBER HOW
LARGER PRACTICE SHOULD BE
INCLUDED. IN THAT DEFINITION OF
HEALTH CARE ENTITY. OKAY AND
THEN AND THEN- SO. SO THAT SEEM
A REPRESENTS. DOCTORS ABOUT
DENNISON CHIROPRACTORS. YEAH DO
THEY NOT DOWN THERE SO YOU KNOW
YOU SMALL GROUPS EVEN HAVE
LARGE YOU HAVEN'T HAVE LARGE
GROUPERS LARGE GROUPS OF THOSE
ENTITIES AS WELL. YEAH I DO NOT
BELIEVE WE PLAN TO INCLUDE
DENTISTS- AND WE AGAIN WILL
WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
DEFINITION. OF EXEMPTED-
REGULATION EXEMPTION PROVIDERS
IN THE IN THE REGULATIONS- SO
THE LINES OF BUSINESS WILL BE
IDENTIFIED I DON'T. THE H. P.
FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE CHOSEN NOT TO
START DOCUMENTS- DENTISTRY- AT
THE OUTSET- AND NOR NOR
CHIROPRACTORS. OKAY AND- AND
THAT WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT
BILLIONS ARE SPENT IN
ALTERNATIVE MEDICINE. EXPENSES
IS THAT GOING TO BE ALSO UNDER
THE OVERSIGHT OF THIS- OF THIS
BODY- THAT IS A SUBSTANTIAL.
PORTION OF HEALTHCARE SPENDING.
I'M CURRENTLY THE DEFINITION OF
THE TOTAL COST OF CARE DOESN'T
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT A CONSUMER CHOSE
TO SPEND ON THEIR OWN OUTSIDE
OF THEIR HOME OKAY REYES SAYS
IT'S OUTSIDE HEALTH COVERAGE SO
THEREFORE FOR EXAMPLE CONCIERGE
PRACTICES WOULD NOT FALL UNDER
THIS. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
I'M HAPPY FOR MY FAILURE OR
WRITE ABOUT THE TO CORRECTLY I
DON'T THINK WE'VE REACHED THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL OKAY SO AND
THEN I GUESS AND I REALIZE
THAT. BUT THEN WE STARTING TO
EQUITY ISSUE. RIGHT AFTER ALL
WHO CAN AVAIL THEMSELVES IN
OTHER WORDS WE'RE GOING TO BE A
SYSTEM WHERE WE SAY GUESS WHAT
IF YOU'RE NOT RICHARD RICH
ENOUGH YOU CAN BUY OUT IF
YOU'RE NOT RICH ENOUGH YOU'RE
STUCK UNDER A CAPS. CORRECT
WELL CONCIERGE PAYMENTS ARE
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE USUAL
COPAYS- OKAY LIKE THAT AGAIN I
JUST POSE THAT OUT THERE TO
THINK ABOUT OKAY SO YEAH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE BEING ABLE
TO BUY THEMSELVES OUT.
ESSENTIALLY OKAY- THE OTHER
ISSUE IS THAT- SO IN TERMS OF
THAT OTHER INPUTS- THIS PEOPLE
ARE DEVELOPING THESE COST
TARGETS. YOU KNOW YOU HAVE. A
YEAH AND YOU KNOW THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WE KNOW THAT ONE
DRIVER HEALTHCARE COSTS THIS
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE CHANGING
TECHNOLOGY. ANOTHER ONE IS FOR
EXAMPLE NEW DISEASES HAVING
CERTAINLY THAT HOPEFULLY IS
QUITE EVIDENT TO ANYONE RIGHT
NOW AS WE ARE FACING COVET AND
CORONAVIRUS. YOU KNOW IT HIV
BEFORE AND SO FORTH- HOW AND
THEN IT SO HOW HOW DO YOU SEE
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS WHEN YOU HAVE- AND
PROJECT YET AND EVENTUALLY I
DID WORKFORCE PROJECTIONS
BEFORE IN MY- PREVIOUS RESEARCH
AS A THE FOR KIND OF THE
LEGISLATURE- SO. OFTEN TIMES
AGAIN THESE ARE PLACES WHERE
YOU'RE YOU'RE PLAYING YOU KNOW
BEST PLANS GO AWRY. BUT IF YOU
DON'T DO THINGS RIGHT THEN YOU
SUDDENLY SAY GUESS WHAT WE
DON'T NEED MORE ID DOCTORS AND
THEN HIV STARTS SHOWING UP AND
WHAT KIND OF IMPACT THAT HAS
ON. ON POPULATIONS. SO HOW HOW
WE ACCOUNT FOR TECHNOLOGY WHICH
IS MAYBE SOMEWHAT LOW MORE
PREDICTABLE AND YOU DISEASES
AND TRYING TO PROJECT AND
TRYING TO ESTABLISH THESE KIND
OF SPENDING TARGETS TO BE SURE
THAT WE DON'T DENY CARE. OR
UNDER RESOURCE CARE FOR
POPULATIONS ANY PARTICULAR
VULNERABLE. TO THESE CONDITIONS.
YES ARE NONE SO IT IS REASONWERE INTEREST IN COLLECT THE
DATA ON CURRENT. YEAR IS- AT
SOME POINT OF COMPARISON WHO
KNOWS- WHAT WHAT WILL BE COMING
OUR WAY SO WE THINK THAT WILL
BE IMPORTANT BASELINE DATA AS
WELL AS TO HOPEFULLY HAVE- IF
WE IF WE GET BACK TO A NEW
NORMAL IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE HAVE. HAVE
THAT BASELINE DATA- WE
CERTAINLY THINK THERE WILL BE.
IT WOULD WE WOULD. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AS THE ADVISORY BOARD
LOOKS TO SET THE COST TARGET TO
ALLOW FOR THE INCREASE
HOPEFULLY IS GOING TO EXACTLY
WHAT WE WANTED TO GO TO- IT
WOULD ACTUALLY IMPROVE CARE
WHICH WOULD BE- IT. A VALUABLE
INNOVATIONS AS WELL AS A-
INVESTMENT IN TECHNOLOGYSO ONE
OF THE PIECES THAT THE- OFFICE
WILL ALSO BE DOING IS TRYING TO
PROMOTE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
METHODS- WE THINK THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT VEHICLES. TO HELP.
INCENTIVIZE INVESTMENTS- IN IN
TECHNOLOGY AND THEN THE MOST
INNOVATIVE EFFECTIVE. MEDICAL
STRATEGIES. OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW SHE SAID THE WORD
HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY IS A LITTLE
SCARY BECAUSE HOPEFULLY. I
THINK WE NEED TO PLAN FOR THIS
WE NEED TO HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
ANTICIPATE FOR THIS THIS WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT ADVISE YOU
COMMITTEES RESPONSES. TO THIS
THAT THEY DON'T TO AT IT OR NOT
AND NOT NOT UNRESPONSIVE TO
THIS SO HOPEFULLY IT'S MORE
THAN. HOPEFULLY SO I SAID
HOPEFULLY BECAUSE- THEY DíAS
TO SAY THAT WE SHOULD INSIST.
THAT WE ARE CORRECT FOR THIS-
AND THEN CERTAINLY ONE PART
THAT SHOULD BE VERY PREDICTABLE
AS THE AGING POPULATION AND
INCREASING DEMAND FOR THAT SO.
AS. WE LOOK AT HEALTH- IT'S- I
MEAN THAT'S ONE RE WHY. IS
GOING TO BE FASTER INFLATION
BECAUSE THE POPULATION IS NOT
GONNA BE THE SAME NEXT YEAR
IT'S A YEAR OLDER AND WELL YES
WE DO HAVE PEOPLE DYING AT ONE
END AND PEOPLE BEING BORED THE
OTHER. WE KNOW THAT THE OVERALL
AGE AVERAGE AGE OF OUR
POPULATION IS INCREASING. OVER
A OVER TIME AND THAT- AND THAT
IS THEY'RE DOING THAT THE COSTS
TARGETS. AT THAT WE NEED TO
JUST WITHOUT GIVING ANY NOTICE
AYE AYE HE HEARD THE TESTIMONY
AND THAT'S IT I KNOW IT'S
COMMONLY SAID THAT- WE ALWAYS
SPEND 30% HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE
NECESSARY- BUT I WOULD BE NO
STATUS IN MY CONVERSATIONS
WITH- PREVIOUS SECRETARY DULY-
AT. THE CHALLENGES FINDING
WHICH 30% RIGHT I MEAN WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY START LOOKING
INDIVIDUAL CASES I KNOW IT'S
COMMONLY THROWN OUT THERE. BUT
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE STUDY WHICH
ACTUALLY THEN THEY'LL SAY OKAY
HERE'S THE 30% OF THE WASTEFUL
PART. RIGHT BECAUSE WHEN YOU
PUSH COMES TO SHOVE AND EOPLE
TRY TO FIND IT IT'S NOT SO EASY
TO FIND. AND THEN. THE OTHER
THING IS THE OTHER QUESTION
YOU'VE MADE SOME REFERENCE TO
THIS OKAY SO. LABOR COSTS- WE
KNOW THAT MANY PEOPLE AND
HEALTH CARE ACTUALLY AGAIN.
REPRESENTED BY THE UNIONS WHICH
IS A GOOD THING I MYSELF AM A
MEMBER OF THE LABOR UNIONS- SO
ARE WE ARE SO IF AN ENTITY
ACTUALLY HAS A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT. AND THAT
LEADS TO AN INCREASE IN WAGES
AND BENEFITS. THAT
AUTOMATICALLY INCREASE THEIR
COST TARGET REFLECTOR INCREASE
IN LABOR EXPENSES ESPECIALLY
SINCE 60% OF HEALTHCARE IS
LABOR. SO WE THERE IS OF
CURRENTLY LANGUAGE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOODS BILL THAT LOOKS
TO- HAVING TO RECOGNIZE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING CHANGES
AS AS AN INPUT TO BE CONSIDERED.
JUST TO BE CONSIDERED WELL AS
AS AN ECONOMIC INDICATOR AS
PART OF THE ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
THAT'S DONE OKAY- EVALUATE THE
COST ARGUE. OKAY SO- I JUST
WANT TO BE A LOT SO YOU YES
SOMEONE'S NEGOTIATING AND THERE
FOR IT IS I THINK WE NEED TO BE
CLEAR TO THE PEOPLE TO THE- TO
THE- EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
NEGOTIATING AS WELL AS THE
UNIONS THAT- THAT DOESN'T
BECOME AN EXCUSE FOR NOT BEING
ABLE TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN IN
GOOD FAITH OR TO- TO LIMIT-
BECAUSE- YEAH. THEN WHAT
HAPPENS IS LIKE YOU HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT YOU
GO TO ADVISORY COMMITTEE BAG
DEVICE OR CAN BE DIVIDED
COMMITTEE DECIDES YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY YEARS LATER
FINALLY OKAY WILL GIVE. YOU AN
INCREASE BECAUSE OF THAT IT'S
CETERA. AND THEN PEOPLE SAY
NEXT COLLECTIVE ARE GAS. SO WE
DON'T GO THROUGH THAT AGAIN- SO
I THINK WE NEED TO BUILD IN
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE MORE-
ASSURED- FOR PEOPLE THAT- THAT
WHEN THERE'S A- YOU KNOW FAIR
BARGAINING CONTRACT THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE REFLECTED. SO THAT
THEY CAN GET- SO THAT- THAT
DOESN'T BECOME A BARRIER TO- TO
NEGOTIATING A FAIR CONTRACT- I
CERTAINLY CAN ASK MANY MANY
MORE QUESTIONS BUT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
SENATE- AND- IS TERRENCE AND
HELPED ME ON THE POLICY ISSUES
PRIOR TO ANY VOTE. ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND- AND- SO LOOK FOR
TO PERHAPS EXPLORING. OTHER
ADDITIONAL ISSUES AND AGAIN IS
THAT YOU MENTIONED- SUMMER
WOODS BILL HAS NOT MADE IT OVER
THE SENATE YET SO WELL YOU MADE
REFERENCE TO IT- ASIDE FROM THE
BROADER OUTLINES- I HAVE NOT
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DELVE
INTO IT MORE DEEPLY AND FACT-
PROBABLY. WANT TO SEE WHAT THE
VERSION COMES OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS. AND ASSEMBLY-
SO I KNOW WHAT I'M WORKING WITH
THEIR BUT I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAM MY STUFF OR JUST
YOUR STAFF THIS AFTERNOON SET.
SOMETHING UP OKAY THANK YOU.
COURSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AT.
CLEARLY THERE'S A LAW OF
INTEREST ON THIS TOPIC- IN BOTH
HOUSES IN BOTH HOUSES SO WE
WILL CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT- THAT. THE MEMBER WOODS
BILL MAKING OVER TO THE SIDE
FOR A FULL POLICY HEARING- BUT-
AGAIN JUST TO REITERATE THE-
THE NEED I THINK WE ALL HAVE.
TO REALLY GRAPPLE WITH THIS
ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY- BOTH AS
DR PAN SAID PUT OUR AGING
POPULATION. AND THEN ALSO AS WE
SPOKE BEFORE ABOUT MAKING SURE
WE HAVE ENOUGH PROVIDERS- AND I
GUESS IS THE POINT I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE IS THAT WE
LOOK AT EQUITY. ACROSS THE
STATE WITH A LOT OF ATTENTION
TO OUR DIFFERENT REGIONS- FIVE.
IT WITH A DIFFERENT REGIONS AND
THAT IT'S IT DOESN'T EXIST
PROVIDERS DON'T EXIST IN A SILO
RIGHT THEY WORKING AND OF.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT OFTENTIMES
ARE LESS RESOURCE AND
OFTENTIMES ARE TREATING PEOPLE
AS START DEPEND HAS SAID BEFORE
WHO HAVE EVEN HIGHER. HEALTH
NEEDS- AND IT'S HARDER TO KEEP
PEOPLE THERE OF PROVIDERS
THEIR- BECAUSE OFTENTIMES OUR
SCHOOLS DON'T REFLECT. THE HIGH
QUALITY. THAT SOME FOLKS ARE
LOOKING FOR WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
COME OUT OF- COLLEGE WITH A
WHOLE LOT OF DEBT SO UP IT JUST
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT IN. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ALL THE OTHER
FACTORS THAT GO INTO OUR HEALTH
OUTCOMES BECAUSE AGAIN AS WE
LOOK AT COSTS WE CAN'T FORGET
ABOUT. OUTCOMES AND WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT HERE. M.
AND THEN JUST TO SAY THAT
SOMEBODY WHO SERVED ON A
STOCKTON CITY COUNCIL WHEN WE
WENT INTO THE VERY PAINFUL
BANKRUPTCY A LOT OF THAT. WAS
DUE TO THE MORTGAGE MELTDOWN
BUT THERE WAS ALSO SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT RELATED TO OUR OUR
HEALTHCARE COSTS- SO I
CERTAINLY HOPE AND WE'RE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE WORKING IN. COLLABORATION
I KNOW WE'VE GOT. SOME FOLKS
FROM LABOR. BUT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UP AND DOWN STATE.
ARE AT THE- ON THE PRECIPICE OF
NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE IT WITH
OUR HEALTH CARE COST SO MAKING
SURE THAT WE TAKE THOSE THINGS
INTO. CONSIDERATION ALSO. AND
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT JUST
MAINTAINS A GOOD HEALTHY WORK
FORCE AND GOVERNMENT WORKERS
AND CONSERVANCY FOR ABLE TO.
PROPERLY AND HAVE ADEQUATE
HEALTH BENEFITS. OKAY AND WITH
THAT I THINK WILL MOVE ON AND
TAKE YOUR IMAGINATION IN
DIRECTIONS. OKAY NOW WE ARE
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER AT
WHICH IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE. AFTERNOON
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK WE CAN'T.
YES GREAT SO I'M VERY MUCH NOT
BE ON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
ARE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR DANCE
OTHER IS WELL. SO WE'LL START
WITH JUST A QUICK OVERVIEW OF
OUR CLOSE ALL THE ANNUAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLAN HEALTH EQUITY
IN QUALITY REVIEWS. KOPEN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED
LONGSTANDING HEALTH INEQUITIES
SEEN AMONG PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE
PANDEMIC HAS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION THAT IS CREATED
SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND HEALTH
INEQUITIES CONTRIBUTING TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER
INFECTION AND MORTALITY RATES.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO ADDRESSING HEALTH INEQUITIES
AND IS PROPOSING STATUTORY
CHANGES TO AUTHORIZE THE DMH C.
TO ESTABLISH AND ENFORCE AT
PRIORITY SET UP HEALTH EQUITY
AND QUALITY MEASURES INCLUDING
SETTING ANNUAL HEALTHEQUITY
QUALITY BENCHMARK STANDARDS.
AND ENFORCING HEALTH PLAN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STANDARDS-
STRUCTURING CHANGES WOULD APPLY
TO FULL SERVICE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANS LICENSE BY THE
GMAC. INCLUDING HEALTH PLANS
THAT CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. APPROACH
STATUTORY CHANGES ARE FOLLOWING
THEIR REQUIREMENTS. DO YOU MAY
SEE WILL CONVENE A HEALTHEQUITY
QUALITY QUALITY COMMITTEE IN
THE FIRST HALF OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE DMH SIAPA PRIORITY SET OF
STANDARD HEALTHEQUITY IN
QUALITY MEASURES AND ANNUAL
BENCHMARKS. ALI COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL INCLUDE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S PURCHASERS
CONSUMER ADVOCATES HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLAN REPRESENTATIVES
PROVIDER REPRESENTATIVES AND
THOSE WITH EXPERTISE IN QUALITY
MEASUREMENT AND IN HEALTH
EQUITY AND DISPARITIES IN THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. AND
OTHER OTHER AGENCIES AS
APPROPRIATE. THE DAMAGE HE WILL
CONTACT WITH AN EXTERNAL
CONSULTANT WITH EXPERTISE IN
THE SUBJECT AREA TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENT PLANNING ORGANIZING
AND FACILITATING THE COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. BASED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS THE
DIRECT SEQUEL STARSHIP SET OF
QUALITY MEASURES HEALTHEQUITY
QUALITY BENCHMARKS FOR ALL FULL
SERVICE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANS. THE PLANS WILL ANNUALLY
SUBMIT A REPORT CONTAINING DATA
AND INFORMATION ON THE MEASURES
AND ANNUAL BENCHMARKS TO THE
DAMAGE C. BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- MEASUREMENT HERE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. DO YOU MAY
SEE WILL HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS
AND TAKE ENFORCEMENT ACTION
WHEN HEALTH EQUITY AND QUALITY
BENCHMARKS ARE NOT ARE NOT MET.
THIS INCLUDES MONITORING
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS AN
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS WERE NEEDED
AND TAKING PROGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AGAINST NON
COMPLIANT HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS AS APPROPRIATE. DMACC
WILL PRODUCE ANNUAL HEALTH
EQUITY IN QUALITY COMPLIANCE
REPORT BEGINNING JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE DEAL MAKES IT
WILL MAKE CHANGES TO THE
OVERCROWDING QUALITY MEASURES
AND ANNUAL BENCHMARKS UNTIL THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE CODIFIED IN
REGULATION. IN ADDITION TO
PLANTS AND THEIR SUBCONTRACTORS
HEALTH PLANS WILL BE REQUIRED
TO OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN NATIONAL
COMMITTEE FOR QUALITY ASSURANCE
OR NCQA ACCREDITATION BY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. BROKE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
THE GMAC WILL COLLABORATE WITH
OPTIONAL DAC ASKAR CALIFORNIA
CALPERS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IN ESTABLISHING THE
PRIORITIES SET A STANDARD ALL
THE MEASURES AND BENCHMARKS.
THE DH WILL COORDINATE THE
INMATES YOU TO CONDUCT SIMILAR
FOR K. ORGAN HEALTH SYSTEM-
THAT ARE NOT REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
HE KNOCKS KEEN LICENSE. THE
DEAL MAKES THE REQUEST THE
FOLLOWING. EXPENDITURES A
THIRTY FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FUND TO ESTABLISH AND ENFORCE
HEALTHEQUITY QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR ALL DMACC LICENSED. FULL
SERVICE IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. TWO
POSITIONS AND HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TWO POSITIONS AND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. FIFTEEN POSITIONS
AND THREE MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
NINETEEN AND A HALF OF THE
SHINS AND FOUR MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. NINETEEN AND HALF OF THE
SHINS AND FOUR MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND BEST FOR
YOUR TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AND SIX MILLION THREE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY SIX ONE SEVEN.
NINETY FOUR POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AND WILL ALMOST SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT AND
TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
POSITIONS FIVE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND IN
FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY
NINE. THIS REQUEST INCLUDES
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TO
DISPLAY YOUR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FOR CONSULTANT. TO ASSIST
WITH PLANNING ORGANIZING AND
FACILITATING THE COMMITTEE. AND
TO ADVISE THE DEPARTMENT ON
ESTABLISHING A PARTY SET OF
POLICY MEASURES. THIS REQUEST
ALSO INCLUDES CONSULTANT
FUNDING OF FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FOR
CLINICAL CONSULTING SERVICES TO
ASSIST IN INTERPRETING DATA AND
DETERMINE TRENDS RELATED TO
REDUCING HEALTH DISPARITIES
IMPROVE IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF CARE DELIVERED. STE HEALTH
CARE SERVICE REQUEST. EXERTIONS
AND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM
THE GENERAL FUND AND FEDERAL
FUND TO COORDINATE WITH THE DMA
C. ON THE ESTABLISHMENT AND
ENFORCEMENT OF HEALTH EQUITY
AND QUALITY STANDARDS AND TO
PERFORM RELATED DATA ANALYSIS.
THIS INCLUDES TRUE POSITIONS
AND TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX
THOUSAND AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWO
POSITIONS AND TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND- AFTER. SO I'LL PAUSE AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
OTHERWISE I CAN MOVE ON TO
QUESTION TO. W. WHAT A LOT OF
POSITIONS BUT WE DO BIG THINGS
WELL I WON LAST IN A LONG LIST
A LOT OF WORDS. ALL RIGHT. SO
LET JUST FIRST OF ALL. AND I.
ACTUALLY WORKING WHEN YOU
THROUGH THE OF THE REMAINING.
BUT JUST- FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU FOR DOING THIS. AND I AM
INTERESTED IN THINK ABOUT HOW
TO GO ABOUT DOING GOING ABOUT
DOING THIS BUT I KNOW THAT
THAT'S IN THE NEXT FOUR
QUESTIONS. I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU. YEAH NO PROBLEM WHICH IS%
ME TO MAKE JUST GET THROUGH
QUESTION AND THEN. YEAH I
THINK. OKAY I THINK. THE SECOND
QUESTION IS HOW WOULD YOU MAKES
THE APPROACH INSURANCE
AVAILABILITY OF RELEVANT AND
DIVERSE EXPERTISE HEALTHEQUITY
QUALITY. I'M SO SORRY MAN THAT
YOU KNOW WE AGREE TO INCLUDE
OUR OUR SISTER AGENCIES THE
OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS
PURCHASERS CONSUMER ADVOCATES.
AND HEALTH PLAN REPRESENTS READ
IT REPRESENTATIVES PROVIDERS-
AND OTHER ENTITIES WITH
RELEVANT EXPERIENCE- ARE
INCENTIVES TO ISSUE A SOURCE OF
BOTH THE PATIENT FOR MEMBERS
AND SELECT MEMBERS WITH
EXPERTISE IN QUALITY
MEASUREMENT BUT ALSO IN HEALTH
EQUITY- THAT REPRESENT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE
INCLUDING RACIAL ETHNIC
CULTURAL GENDER GEOGRAPHIC.
THANKS I ALSO MENTION PLAN TO
CONQUER CANCER IN CERTAIN
CONSOLE EXPERTISE IN THE
SUBJECT AREA WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN PLAN WORK AND
FACILITATING MEETING- WE'RE
EXPECTING THAT THE X. COMES MAY
I HAVE- EXPERTISE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR WHO TO
SOLICIT- PARTICIPATION ON THAT
COMMITTEE AND CAN. HELP US WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON TO QUESTION
THREE PLEASE DESCRIBE SOME
EXAMPLES OF THE TYPES OF
ACCORDION QUALITY MEASURES AND
BENCHMARK THAT COULD BECOME A
NEW PLAN RESPONSIBILITIES AS A
RESULT OF THOSE FOR PROPOSAL-
TO REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
ON BOTH THE HEALTH PLANS AND
PROVIDERS AND TO AVOID
DUPLICATION. THE INTENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO SELECT A
PRIORITY SET OF MEASURES AND
WE'RE TALKING PROBABLY
SOMEWHERE AROUND TEN TWELVE
FIFTEEN MAX. CERTAINLY AND
REPORTED OTHER ENTITIES SUCH AS
THC HAS COVERED CALIFORNIAN
CALPERS. WHAT'S THE COMMITTEE
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
THIS IS LIKELY- WILL INCLUDE A
SUBSET OF QUALITY MEASURES AS A
SAD COLLECTED BY HEALTH PLANS
INCLUDING HEALTH CARE
EFFECTIVENESS DATA AND
INFORMATION SET MEASURES ARE HE
JUST MEASURES AND CONSUMER
SATISFACTION SURVEY SURVEYS
SUCH AS THE CONSUMER ASSESSMENT
OF HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND
SYSTEMS SURVEY CAPS SURVEY. THE
MEASURES NAY ALSO INCLUDE THOSE
CONDITIONS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR OTHER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. AND
COULD INCLUDE A MIX OF CHILD AN
ADULT MEASURES. SOME EXAMPLES
OF POTENTIAL MEASURES
IMPROPRIETIES FOR OLD FOR
FRESHER CERVICAL CANCER
SCREENING COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENING ASAMOAH. PRENATAL AND
POSTPARTUM CARE OPIOID USE
IMMUNIZATIONS AND DEPRESSION
SCREENING. SOME EXAMPLES OF
CONSUMER SATISFACTION SURVEY
QUESTION INCLUDE THOSE RELATED
TO CONSUMER EXPERIENCES
OBTAINING NECESSARY AND TIMELY
CARE ACCESS TO CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE CARE
HEALTH PLAN CUSTOMER SERVICE
AND ABILITY TO RECEIVE SPECIAL
TREATMENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. A FULL SERVICE
IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH PLANS WILL
MAKE ALCOHOL MODIFICATIONS FOR
QUALITY ASSURANCEPROGRAM
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND
ANNUALLY COLLECT AND SUBMIT A
REPORT COMPETING TAKING DATA
AND INFORMATION ON THE PRIORITY
SET OF MEASURES AND BENCHMARKS
TO THE DEAL MAKES THE BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY OR PERMISSION
YOU'RE TWENTY TWENTY. THREE
SOME OF THE QUESTION FOR THIS
TO OF THE ACTIONS DEPARTMENT
WOULD EXPECT OF HEALTH PLANS AS
THEY SEEK TO COMPLY WITH THE
EQUITY QUALITY MEASURES AND
BENCHMARKS. I'M SO HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLANS DO NOT
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE MEASURES
AND BENCHMARKS. FOR THE
HEALTHCARE SERVICE PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT ACTION PLANS TO
ACHIEVE AND DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE HEALTH
HEALTH EQUITY IN QUALITY
STANDARD MEASURES AND
BENCHMARKS. ADDITIONAL ACT
EXPECTATIONS MAY INCLUDE THE
HEALTH PLAN IDENTIFYING ROOT
CAUSES OF FAILURE TO MEET THE
BENCHMARK STANDARDS. CONDUCTING
OUTREACH TO THEIR CONTRACTOR
PROVIDERS ASSESSING THE
EFFECTIVENESS EFFECTIVENESS OF
PAYMENT AND SENATE AND SAID
INCENTIVES FOR OTHER
INTERVENTIONS AND MAKING
CHANGES AS NECESSARY- WE ALSO
CAN REQUIRE PROVIDER PLANS TO
SUBMIT MORE FREQUENT REPORTING
AS PART OF OUR MONITORING. OF
RESPECT PROCESS. IN THE FINAL
QUESTION NUMBER HERE IS AFTER
THE REQUIRE PUBLICATION
REGULATIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN THE STATE MAKES THE
EXPECT TO HAVE TO PROMULGATE
NEW REGULATIONS WHEN EQUITY IN
QUALITY MEASURES AND BENCHMARKS
ARE UPDATED PERIODICALLY. SO
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE I WILL.
DEPARTMENT TO TAKE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION AND AVOID POTENTIAL
LEGAL CHALLENGES WE BELIEVE
THAT WE WILL NEED TO CODIFY THE
MEASURES AND BENCHMARKS AND
REGULATIONS- WE WILL NEED TO
AMEND THE REGULATIONS IF WE
MAKE CHANGES TO THOSE
BENCHMARKS. OR MEASURES- WE
INTEND TO RE EVALUATE AND MAKE
CHANGES TO THE EQUITY IN
QUALITY MEASURES AND BENCHMARKS
AS NECESSARY- A REALLY GOING TO
AND INTO THIS WITH AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THERE IS A
LOT THAT WILL CHANGE AS WE
START TO COLLECT THIS DATA BOTH
IN THE MEASURES AND THE DATA
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO ASSESS THE
QUALITY OF HEALTH EQUITY- IT'LL
BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO.
CONTINUALLY RE EVALUATE AND
WORK WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING
APPROPRIATE CHANGES- TO THE
MEASURES AND BENCHMARKS SAYS
BUT TECHNOLOGY IN THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM INVOLVES BUT WILL NEED
TO CODIFY THAT. IN A MINUTE BUT
REGULATIONS. I THINK THE
QUESTION THAT ARE FORMAL BUT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKING COURSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYTHING
FOR THE APARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU NO COMMENTS OKAY THE
L. A. O. MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS AB IN JOHNSON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY
NOTE THAT WE SUPPORT THE GOALS
THAT UNDERLIE THIS BCP AND
SPECIFICALLY FIND THAT
MEASURING AND REPORTING IN
HOLDING PLANS. RESPONSIBLE FOR
MEETING FOR THEIR PERFORMANCE
AGAINST QUALITY IN EQUITY
STANDARDS- CAN DRIVE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM WE RECOGNIZE THAT
CARRYING OUT THESE NEW
ACTIVITIES OUT ROOF WOULD
REFLECT A SIGNIFICANT
UNDERTAKING FOR DMH SEE AND
DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WITH THE RESOURCE REQUEST OR
THE ASSOCIATED- PROPOSED
STATUTORY CHANGES AND JUST
RECOMMEND CONTINUED LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS AS
THEY DEVELOP THAT PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS. AND AS THEY DEVELOP
THE PROCESSES FOR MONITORING
REPORTING AND ENFORCING THOSE
STANDARDS THANK YOU. IN YOU
VERY MUCH AND I GUESS MY FIRST
QUESTIONS WOULD BE AROUND- WELL
AGAIN THAT A TECHNOLOGY AND
THINKING YOU FOR YOU WORK WITH
US. BUT ALSO THEN- AGAIN JUST
THE IDEA OF EQUITY AROUND
REGIONALLY AROUND THE STATE
JUST IF WE CAN KEEP THAT IN THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR MINDS. AND
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR PLAN THEN FOR
MAINTAINING. I MEAN IT IT'S
GONNA BE COLLECTING A LOT OF
DATA SITTING ON A BENCH MARKS.
OR ARE WE SURE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO PUT. I GUESS HOW DO THANK
HEAVENS TO KEEP SAYING IS HOW
DO WE AVOID THE- ADD TO BUCKLE
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT I. T. AND
THEN DATA COLLECTION. AND START
THERE PLEASE. NO I AND I WILL
SAY THAT YOU KNOW COLLECTING HE
DOES STATE IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU KNOW THE PLANS ARE ALREADY
REPORTING AGAIN WITH THIS IDEA
THAT WE'RE NOT- YOU KNOW
CREATING A NEW SET OF MEASURES
THIS IS REALLY BUILT AROUND-
IDENTIFY MEASURES THAT ARE
ALREADY BEING COLLECTED AND
REPORTED TO PURCHASERS AND
OTHER STATE ENTITIES AND SO-
THIS IS NOT- IN TERMS OF LIKE
SUBMITTING THE DATA THIS IS NOT
HUGE HUGE DATABASES- THIS IS
DATA THAT CAN BE- JUST
SUBMITTED AN AGGREGATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT FAIRLY SIMPLY- SO
AGAIN ALREADY DATA THAT'S BEING
COLLECTED AND REPORTED BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT AND PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE SOMEONE HOW WE DEAL WITH
THE OTHER DATA THAT WE COLLECT.
AND CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT ONE OF THE AS ONE OF
MY OTHER HATCHES OF MOISTURE
THE LGBT CAUCUS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF THE COLLECTION I WAS THE
LACK OF COLLECTION OF UP SO G.
DATA AND THEN BUT THE LACK OF
REPORTING THAT OR DOCUMENTING
THAT SOMEWHERE I'M GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THOSE
EQUITY FACTORS MIXED IN AS WELL
OR INCLUDED AS WELL. NO NOT
THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT A
PRIORITY FOR US AS WELL I WILL
SAY ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE
HAVE OVERALL IN DATA COLLECTION
IS WEEK WE DON'T HAVE- YOU KNOW
COMPLETE ROBUST STATE ON BOTH
RACE ETHNICITY OBVIOUSLY SO G.
DATE AS WELL- AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT WE CAN LOOK
AT THAT WE CAN LOOK AT YOU KNOW
GEOGRAPHY ANOTHER PROXIES. IT'S
AN AREA THAT WE REALLY WILL BE
LOOKING TO BOTH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES ALL BUT ALSO THE
COMMITTEE TO ADVISE US ON HOW
DO WE CAPTURE THAT DATA HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
MISSING OUT ON CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES- THIS IS ANOTHER
AREA THAT I THINK WE ARE
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC THAT AS
TIME GOES BY ANDTHE
AVAILABILITY OF THAT DATA WILL
IMPROVE. AND THIS IS WHERE OUR
ABILITY TO BE NIMBLE MEN MOVE
AND MAKE CHANGES TO THOSE
MEASURES AND THE BENCHMARKS
WILL BE IMPORTANT OKAY AND WHAT
WE'RE GONNA BE USING THIS. DATA
TO AT. INCREASED EQUITY AND USE
IT FOR PER. HOW WHAT IS IT WHAT
IS THE I. ABOUT THE RELATION
BACK WITH THE LATEST AS FAR AS
REPORTING THIS DATA SO WE CAN
MAIN WE CAN BE AWARE OF WHERE
THE GAPS ARE OF- WHICH
PROVIDERS ARE ARE BEING ABLE TO
MEET THE OUTCOMES. AND WHAT
WHAT'S YOUR IDEA ABOUT COMING
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
UPDATES AND REPORTS. SURE
KNOWING WHERE WE'RE ALWAYS
HAPPY TO PROVIDE UPDATES- ON ON
THE WORK THAT WE DO- I THINK
THE KEY PIECE YEAR ROUND
TRANSPARENCY WILL BE THE ANNUAL
REPORT THAT WE WILL HAVE ON OUR
WEBSITE SO OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
AN ANNUAL REPORT STARTING AT
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE IT'LL
BE AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
THAT WILL WHO WILL SHOW HOW THE
PLANS ARE DOING IN TERMS OF
PERFORMANCE AND MEETING THOSE
BENCHMARKS. THANK YOU DOCTOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- IT. AND YES
CERTAINLY I UNDERSTAND- AND
ENSURE YOUR DESIRE NOT TO
INCREASE IN MISTER BURDENS ON
PLANTS WERE REPORTING A LOT OF
DATA TO THE DEPARTMENT AND TO
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT. HOWEVER I
THINK IF WE'RE DEALING WITH
EQUITY- WE HAD WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE SYSTEMS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE NOW- IT DID
COME FROM THIS YOU KNOW- THE
FIRST IS A SYSTEMIC RACISM IT'S
NICE BUILT INTO OUR SYSTEM SO I
THINK WE DO NEED TO LOOK
CAREFULLY AT OUR EXISTING DATA
SYSTEMS. DATA COLLECTION AND
LOOK AT WHERE THINGS WERE NOT
COLLECTING THAT WE PERHAPS
SHOULD BE SO I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING YOU KNOW YOU'RE
TRYING TO STICK THE THINGS
YOU'RE A YET BUT I JUST WANT TO
PUT THAT PEN ON THERE NOT TO
SAY THAT LET'S GO IN TO CREATE
A WHOLE BUNCH OF NEW MEASURES-
BUT I DO THINK THAT'S- SO BUT
THE ONE PLACE I THINK WE REALLY
DO NEED TO THINK VERY CAREFULLY
ABOUT WORK WITH THE PLANS BUT-
BUT BEFORE WE GET REALLY. GOOD
INACCURATE DATA IS AROUND THE
BENEFICIARIES THEMSELVES
BECAUSE WITHOUT THAT ALL THE
REST OF IT YOU CAN'T REALLY
INTERPRET SO FOR EXAMPLE ARE WE
DO WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE TO
CONFIDENTIALLY AND ACTUALLY AT
LEAST TRY TO COLLECT DATA ON-
YOU KNOW- SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY RIGHT.
BECAUSE IT BASICALLY IF THERE
ISN'T A MECHANISM DO THAT
THERE'S NO WAY YOU'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT THAT AND THEN I THINK
FOR THE API COMMUNITY HAVING A
DISAGGREGATED DATA SO YOU KNOW
THAT IT'S MENTION THAT. THE
EIGHTY I CAN BE REPRESENTS
PEOPLE COME FROM THE BIGGEST
COTTON IN THE WORLD THE BIGGEST
OCEAN IN THE WORLD THERE'S A
LOT OF DIVERSITY WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY AND SO IF YOU DON'T
GET THE- DISAGGREGATED DATA.
GOING TO MISS A LOT THINGS
THERE- SO. I IS SO. SOME NOT
SURE THE CURRENT SYSTEMS ARE
ADEQUATE ENOUGH AND THAT THERE
IS IF WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
ACHIEVE EQUITY. WE NEED TO.
DEMAND THAT THOSE SYSTEMS ARE
BETTER IN TERMS OF THAT THAT
BASELINE DATA BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU CAN HAVE ALL THE HEATERS
AND ALL THIS OTHER STUFF AND
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE- PARTS
OUT. IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE L.
G. B. T. Q. DATA. YOU DON'T
HAVE THE DISAGGREGATED AGI DAYS
SIMPLY SAY LIKE ASIANS ARE
DOING FINE AND THAT CETERA BUT
IT COULD BE THAT ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW THE PACIFIC ISLANDERS ARE
DOING SO WELL FACT WE SEE THIS
WITH OPEN RIGHT OPPOSITE GUY
ANDERS ACTUALLY HAVE THE
HIGHEST DEATH RATE OF ANY.
GROUP BUT IF WE JUST FOLDED THE
MEN AS A TI. FELLOW BEEN LOST
SO. SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT. IN AN ECHO
FRAMEWORK THAT. NOT SAY THAT
WELL WHAT WE HAVE IS GOOD
ENOUGH WE HAVE TO DO BETTER AND
COLLECTING AT LEAST. SOME OF
THE DATA. THE OTHER THING THAT
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION IS THE
EDITIONS OF COURSE TO THE DATA
YOU COLLECT IS ALSO- HOW YOU
ANALYZE EXISTING DATA SO LET ME
JUST POSE THIS QUESTION- WELL
THE LATEST BEFORE BECAUSE THIS
QUESTION- I ALSO WANNA GET BACK
TO CERTAINLY FOR THE API
COMMUNITY BUT- AS FOR OTHER.
MUSIC COLOR- IT. ACCESS TO
INTERPRETERS ALL RIGHT Y. SE
INTERPRETERS I MEAN YOU KNOW
NOT JUST TRANSLATION. ALL RIGHT
NOT JUST A PHONE PERSON SO ARE
WE GONNA BE COLLECTING DATA ON
ACCESS TO INTERPRETER TO LET
INTERPRETERS MEDICAL
INTERPRETERS AND- AND OF SAMPLE
PERCENTAGE OF TIMES THAT
HAPPENED AND SO FORTH SO IT'S
NOT JUST LIKE A CALL THE PHONE
THING WHERE YOU HAVE SOMEONE
WHO LITERALLY TRANSLATES AND
CAN'T AND SO YOU YOU DON'T GET
THE CULTURAL CONTACTED CETERA.
ARE WE GOING TO BE COLLECTING
THAT INFORMATION AS FAR AS
EQUITY EFFORT. NO I JUST ON THE
COLLECTING OF RACE ETHNICITY
AND SO G. DATA- YOU KNOW
HAVING. TO WORK ON THIS
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER THERE'S
ALWAYS THIS TRYING TO FIND THIS
BALANCE FROM TRYING TO CAPTURE
THE DATA TO DO THE APPROPRIATE
MEASUREMENT- WITHOUT CREATING A
BARRIER TO ENROLLMENT AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON- IN
PARTICULAR- WORKING WITH
PURCHASERS WHO WHO ARE INVOLVED
IN THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS AS
WELL- IN TERMS OF ACCESS TO
TRANSLATOR SERVICES THAT THIS
PROBLEM. HM THAT'S A
INTERPRETER SIR. THERE'S
ACTUALLY A DIFFERENCE.
CANCELLATION CANCELLATION IS
DIFFERENT THAN INTERPRETING
TRANSLATION IS CAN JUST BE A
LITERAL TRANSLATION I'LL TELL
YOU AS SOMEONE WHO'S A HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER A LITERAL
TRANSLATION WELL MORE HELPFUL
THAN NOTHING DOESN'T INCLUDE
THE CULTURAL CONTEXT OF THE
INTERACTION. AND SO IT'S NOT AS
USEFUL THAT'S WHY USE MEDICAL
INTERPRETERS. NOT JUST
TRANSLATORS. SURE NO I AND I
THINK THE OPPORTUNITY THERE IS
PROBABLY THROUGH SOME SORT OF
CONSUMER SATISFACTION SURVEY TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE MEMBER
EXPERIENCE FOR EXAMPLE- I
ASSUME THE CODE FOR THIS
BECAUSE USUALLY IT SHOULD BE
OFTEN AND EXPENSE SO IT'S OUR
WAY WE CAN COLLECTED ASIDE FROM
JUST ASKING THAT. PATIENTS THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DATA AROUND
DOUBLE PAYMENT HOW MAY I HELP
YOU CAN HELP ME OUT FOR A MID
STATE PAY FORWARD THE NAME I
MEAN THAT THAT'S A LEVEL OF
ACCESS. I WOULD CERTAINLY TAKE
THAT BACK AND SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH OUR
COMMITTEE ABOUT OKAY SO
CERTAINLY I APPRECIATE CATCHING
IT ON THE CONSUMER AND I AND I
ALWAYS RECOMMEND I THINK IN OUR
CONVERSATION THE PAST OF THE
SURVEY TO CONSUMERS AS WELL.
THIS CASE IS WILL REVERSE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE CONSUMER
INFORMATION PERHAPS SOME CAPS
AND AGAIN THAT'S IN THE SAMPLE.
GOING BACK THE OTHER WAY HI YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S USEFUL TO GET
COMPARISONS TO. THE WHAT TO
WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY PAYING
FOR AND HOW OFTEN YOU'RE PAYING
FOR SAID IT CENTER AND THEN OF
COURSE IS TIED TO KNOWING BASS
FISHERY BUT ALSO PERHAPS ALSO
SOME GEOGRAPHIC DATA RIGHT. SO
YOU KNOW THE LIVING IN AN AREA
THAT HAS A HIGH DENSITY AT
CETERA. AS TO IF ONE PLAN ISN'T
PAYING FOR VERY MUCH AND THE
OTHER ONE IS. THERE MIGHT BE
TELLING YOU SOMETHING. OKAY SO
AGAIN I THINK THAT CERTAINLY
FOR THE H. E. I. CAN ME THIS
CAN BE REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT-
BUT I IMAGINE THAT THERE ARE
SOME OTHER COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
AND THEN THE OTHER PIECE OF
DATA I THINK YOU NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT FROM ANALYTICAL
STANDPOINT SO YOU KNOW YOU DO
GET DATA ON. WHICH PROVIDERS
THE CONTRACT AND YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE AND SO FORTH SO YOU
GET THAT INFORMATION. BUT ARE
WE GONNA DO ANALYSES. AND ALSO
SENSE OF THE BENEFICIARIES AND
WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED SO
GEOGRAPHIC IT'S CETERA. BUT ARE
WE GONNA LOOK AT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE PROVIDERS
FOR EXAMPLE- AND- IT TO THE
GREED THAT THEY ACTUALLY ARE
LOCATED. IN AND LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE UP THAT'S
HOW YOU ONE WAY IF I DON'T WANT
TO HIRE EXPENSE AND I DON'T
CARE ABOUT EQUITY IS I JUST
BASE ALL MY- DOCTORS OFFICES
PHARMACIES YOU KNOW HOSPITALS
AND IN MIDDLE CLASS UPPER
MIDDLE CLASS IT'S CETERA
COMMUNITIES AND SAY FINE I'M
WILLING TO SELL YOU A HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN. BUT YOU HAVE TO
LIVE IN A POOR COMMUNITY YOU
JUST GONNA HAVE TO TAKE TWO
BUSES AND WHATEVER ELSE TO GET
THERE. AND SO I MAKE IT MUCH
LESS CONVENIENT SO- THAN OTHER
EQUITY MEASURE IS TO SEE
EXACTLY DO YOU HAVE PROVIDERS
IN WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING
DOCTORS ON TALKING PHARMACIES
AND TALK ABOUT OTHER TYPES OF
SERVICES. YOU KNOW A DEBTOR
LOCATED IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AFTER ALL WE HAVE
WE HAVE TO EASE DIVIDED BY
THESE I FORGOT WHAT THE NAMES
OF THE THESE QUARTILES FOR.
HELP SO WHEN WE DO WE HAVE
MEASURES- THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY
SO HE SHOULD SHOULD WE BE
LOOKING AT THAT YOU KNOW
SOMEONE'S A- SOLDIER FIGHTING
HEALTH INSURANCE YOU KNOW EVEN.
IF THERE'S ONLY HEALTH
INSURANCE RT RT BASICALLY
INTENTIONALLY JUST CONTRACTING
WITH PEOPLE IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES TO AVOID. HAVING
ENCOURAGING. BEEN OFFICIALLY
SIGNING UP FROM OTHER
COMMUNITIES. SO THE GOOD NEWS
IS AS YOU KNOW- WE DO HAVE
QUITE A ROBUST DATABASE ON.
WORKSITE. MEDICAL PLANS NETWORK
SO. IT IS LIKELY THAT I DO
THINK THERE'S AN OP. VERTICALLY
AS WE AT HER ACTION PLAN TO TRY
TO. REALLY TRY TO INTO THE
CAUSE- AND THERE AN OP. FOR US
TO KNOW KIND OF A LINE THE WITH
THE OTHER AREA OF WORK AT THE
DEAL MAKES THE- ARE. ACT OUT
OKAY. REFUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE
DATA FOR NETWORK. BUT ALSO.
PERHAPS OKAY DEVELOP THE
ANALYTICAL CAPACITY TO LOOK AT
ALSO FROM AN EQUITY LINES AND
PROVIDE REPUBLIC REPORTS ABOUT
THAT. AND THEN WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THEN TO. COUNTY
THROUGH YOUR AGENCY DIRECTLY
BUT ALSO THROUGH- OTHER MEANS
TO. ENCOURAGE PLANS TO HAVE
MORE EQUITABLE EFFORTS IN TERMS
OF- THEIR NETWORKS I MEAN NOT
JUST AND IT'S NOT THE NETWORK
ITSELF IT'S ACTUALLY WHO. YOU
KNOW WHO WHO. ACTUALLY HAS
ACCESS TO THE PLAN ITSELF.
RIGHT ANY BECAUSE OF DRUGS YOU
KNOW LOCATING A NEIGHBORHOOD
YOU DON'T HAVE A PHARMACY THERE
ETCETERA. YES SO YOU TRAVEL
YOU'LL FIND THE DOCTOR DOCTOR
WRITES A PRESCRIPTION NOW YOU
CAN'T FIND A PHARMACY THAT SEND
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD SO EVERY TIME
YOU DO RESELL YOU GOTTA GO TAKE
ANOTHER LONG TRIP IT'S ADDRESS
SO. THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO
SCOURGE FOR SOMEONE FROM
SIGNING UP FOR YOUR FOR THAT
PLAN RIGHT. THAT'S NOT
EQUITABLE. SO WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK IT'S ALL ABOUT ANALYSIS SO
THAT'S DATA YOU'RE COLLECTING
BUT LET'S DO IT LET'S DO THE
ANALYTICS FOR THAT OKAY LET'S
THAT JUST SOME IDEAS SO
THROUGHOUT THEIR EXPLAINS MORE
BUT I'LL- I'LL STOP THERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY I
THINK WE'LL MOVE ON THEN TO-
ONE OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
HELLO HELLO
PUBLIC HEALTH. HI THIS IS SUSAN
VALLEY ON THE CHIEF DEPUTY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMITTEE PROVIDING THE UPDATE
TODAY WE WELCOME YOU VERY MUCH
YOU CAN PROVIDE US AN UPDATE
BEFORE WE GO TO OUR PANELISTS.
OKAY SO ON THE COVERAGE FRONT
WE HAVE TODAY REPORTED ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE NEW CASES BRINGING OUR
TOTAL ARGUMENT OF TOTAL TO
THREE POINT SIX MILLION CASES
ARE ARE EFFECTIVE DATE RANGES
FROM ZERO POINT EIGHT EIGHT TWO
ZERO POINT EIGHT NINE AS YOU
KNOW OUR CASE NUMBERS ARE TEST
POSITIVE GET READY AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE STABLE AT
AND OR DECREASING ACROSS THE
STATE. OUR CASE NUMBER PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS AT FOUR
POINT ONE WITH A SEVEN DAY
AVERAGING SEVEN DAY LAG ON OUR
THAT COMPARES TO THE PREVIOUS
COUPLE OF MONDAYS IN TERMS OF
NEW CASES WHICH WERE- FOURTEEN
FORTY FIVE- TWO MONDAYS AGO ON
FOUR TWENTY SIX IN SIXTEEN OH
SIX- ON FOUR NINETEEN SO AGAIN
LOOKING BETTER IN TERMS OF LOST
NUMBER OF CASES ARE
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE ALSO MUCH
LOWER THAN. AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR AND HAVE STABILIZED
WITH- ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX NEW EMISSIONS EVERY
DAY BUT THE NUMBERS OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE WELL BELOW
WHERE WE WERE ON IN OCTOBER
BEFORE THE HEALTHCARE SEARCH
I'M SO MORTALITY WE HAD TWO NEW
DEATHS REPORTED TODAY BRINGING
OUR STATEWIDE TOTAL TO SIXTY
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE. OUR NUMBER OF TESTS
REPORTED OUR 480-008-0040 NINE
TODAY BURKINA THAT NUMBER OF
TESTS ACROSS A LOT OF THAT
PANDEMIC AT SIXTY MILLION EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY OUR
SEVEN DAY POSITIVITY OTHER. AT
ONE POINT 1% AND I PICKED UP ON
THE BACKS FRONT WE HAVE A
MINISTER A TOTAL OF MILLION.
FIVE HUNDRED AND ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED ELEVEN VACCINE
DOSES- THAT MEANS ABOUT ROUGHLY
60% OF ALL ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE DOSE. HOWEVER THAT'S
NOT THE SAME ACROSS THE- STATE
WITH ONLY 47% OF PEOPLE IN ON
THE QUARTILE ONE OR LOWEST
EQUITY QUARTILE COMPARED 270%
IN Q. TO Q. FOUR WHICH IS OUR
HIGHEST- HEALTHY PLACES IN NEXT
COURT TRIAL SO. AGAIN SEEING-
SOME DISPARITY ACROSS THE STATE
AND- I'M GREAT WE'VE ALSO BEGUN
TO SEE A- SLOWDOWN IN THE OPTIC
AND CANCELLING APPOINTMENTS AND
SO WE ARE LOOKING OUT THAT
ACROSS THE STATE AND LOOKING AT
WAYS OF INCREASING. ON THE
INTEREST IN GETTING VACCINATED
BY MAKING IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE
TO GET VACCINATED AND MOVING
AWAY FROM. I'M PLEASED
VACCINATION SITES NOT THAT WE
DON'T STILL NEED SOME OF THOSE
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO MOVE OUR
VACCINATIONS TO SITES WHERE
PEOPLE ARE FREQUENT- PLACES
THAT ARE MORE TRUSTED SUCH AS
SCHOOL CAMPUSES GROCERY STORES.
A WHOLE HOST OF PLACES WHERE
THAT MIGHT MAKE IT EASIER AND
MORE CONVENIENT FOR PEOPLE TO
GET VACCINATED IF I COULD
INTERRUPT YOU JUST ONE SECOND
TO DISHONOR- PREVIOUS MEETING.
WITH THE GOVERNOR- HE SAID LAST
FOR FIVE DAYS HAVE BEEN
STARTLING THE DROP OFF SO THAT
WHEN YOU'RE TRACKING THAT ARE
YOU ALSO TRACKING IN THAT FROM.
AN EQUITY STANDPOINT AS FAR AS-
WHAT WHO WHO'S NOT COMING BACK
ON WHO'S NOT WHO'S NOT GETTING
VACCINATED WHO IS THAT SIMILAR
TO THE EARLIER THE NUMBER SHE
GAVE. IT IS SIMILAR- I THINK
WE'VE SEEN AND READ DECLINE
ACROSS THE BOARD IN ALL FOUR
COUNTS OF THE STATE. I'M BUT I
THINK AND IN FACT AND I THINK
THAT GAP BETWEEN Q. FOUR AND Q.
ONE HAS REDUCED A LITTLE BIT
BUT NOT IN A GOOD WAY IT'S JUST
A REFLECTION OF REDUCTIONS
ACROSS THE BOARD. AND VACCINE.
HOWEVER YOU KNOW WE ARE WE ARE
STILL. MAKING GREAT PROGRESS
MOVING FORWARD IN VACCINATIONS
AND WE WERE HOPING THAT IT'S A
SLIGHT DOWNTURN GIVEN THAT POTS
ON THE J. AND J. RACKS THE SOME
OF THE OTHER- PROSAUROPOD IN SO
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
WERE WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
EAST YOU. SHARE BEST PRACTICES
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
BEING CREATIVE- BREALEY WORKING
OUT WAYS TO GET PEOPLE MORE
INTERESTED IN UNDERSTAND. THE
SAFETY OF THE VACCINES. THANK
YOU. I'M CAUGHT THIS IS THIRTY
FIFTH WEEK THE BLUEPRINTS- FOR
A SAFER ECONOMY WE HAVE FIVE
COUNTIES THAT MOVED TO A LESS
RESTRICTIVE HERE THIS WEEK FROM
RED TO ORANGE WE HAD INYO
COUNTY WHICH BRED BEING
SUBSTANTIAL DISEASE AN ORANGE
BEING MODERATE DISEASE WE HAD-
THREE COUNTIES MOVED FROM
ORANGE TO YELLOW WHICH IS FROM
MODERATE TO MINIMAL- LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO AND
TRINITY SO ALL THOSE FIVE
COUNTIES MOVED TO A LESS
RESTRICTIVE HERE AS YOU KNOW
OUR CURTAINS CURRENT STATS
OVERALL THE STATE THERE'S ZERO
IN WIDESPREAD PROPOSED HERE AND
THERE ARE TWELVE COUNTIES IN
SUBSTANTIAL THERE THIRTY NINE
COUNTIES IN MODERATE AND SEVEN
COUNTIES AND MINIMAL SO.
DEFINITELY MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE GONNA HIT THE GYM JUNE
FIFTEENTH DEADLINE- WE ARE SURE
GOING TO TRY AND SO I THINK WE
ARE- LOOKING AT OPEN YOU KNOW-
OPENING THE STATE ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH AS THE ADMINISTRATION
IS COMMITTED TO DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET AS
MANY PEOPLE VACCINATED- SO THAT
AS WE BEGIN TO OPEN UP THE
STATE THAT WE REALLY DO HAVE A
AND A LOT OF PROTECTION OUT
THERE TO KEEP THE TRANSMISSION
FROM MOVING FORWARD. I AM SO I
THINK THE NEXT STEP I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC UPDATE ABOUT
SORT OF A QUICK UPDATE. AND YOU
WERE TO MOVE ON TO THE QUESTION
THE WHOLE. OKAY SO THE NEXT ONE
WAS TO YOU PLEASE PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S
COORDINATED PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES WE SORT OF
BUCKET THESE ACTIVITIES AND- A
FEW CATEGORIES SOME ONE BEING
MONITORING THE SCOPE ON
PROGRESS OF THE PANDEMIC TO
INFORM OUR RESPONSE. AND THAT
INCLUDES ALL OF OUR SAY
SURVEILLANCE EFFORTS ARE
MODELING OUR ANALYSIS OF DATA
TO UNDERSTAND THOSE DISPARATE
IMPACTS AND OUR IT SYSTEMS ALL
VERY BIG EFFORTS- IN TERMS OF
THIS ONGOING PANDEMIC. WE TRY
TO DEVELOP THE POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT THIS MISSION TO PROVIDE
A SCIENCE BASED FRAMEWORK FOR
SAFE RE OPENING OF THE ECONOMY
TO MINIMIZE THOSE HEALTH
IMPACTS. WE DEVELOP AND PROMOTE
EQUITABLE POLICIES AND RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS AND WE ALIGN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE POLICIES
INACTION WITH CHANGING SCOPES
AND DEMAND. DEMANDS OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE ALSO WORK TO
MITIGATE AND SUPPRESSED COBIT
NINETEEN DISEASE BY DIRECTING
AND PREVENTING NON
PHARMACEUTICAL INTERVENTIONS
ARE AND P. EYES TO MINIMIZE
MINIMIZE ADVERSE HEALTH IMPACTS
WE PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS JUST SUPPRESSED.
AND CONTAINED COVER NINETEEN
WITH TESTING TRACING OR
CONTRACT RACING AND ISOLATION
AND QUARANTINE WE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR HELP
MAKE OUTBREAK CONTROL AND
CONGREGATE LIVING FACILITIES
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
WORKPLACES SCHOOLS. AND OTHER
COMMUNITY SETTINGS WE DEVELOP
AND PROVIDE INNOVATIVE AND
EQUITABLE SOLUTIONS FOR
CHANGING THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. OF THE NEXT BUCKET IS
COORDINATING AND SUPPLEMENTING
STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE RESOURCES
AND PHARMACEUTICAL
INTERVENTIONS- DEVELOPING AN
ACT. IN RESPECT DEVELOP AN APP
COVERT NINETY VACCINE JUST PLN.
STRONGLY AND INFLUENZA
VACCINATIONS TO REDUCE THE
BURDEN ON THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. ENHANCING INFECTION
CONTROL PROTOCOLS AND ALL OVER
HEALTH CARE FACILITY SETTINGS
AND MONITORING AND PROVIDING
AVAILABLE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT HEALTHCARE STAFF ICU
BEDS AND VENTILATORS TO MEET
THOSE THIRDS HEALTHCARE SERVICE
DEMANDS- NEXT IS COMMUNICATING
EFFECTIVELY TO THE PUBLIC AND
ENGAGING OUR STAKEHOLDERS-
INCLUDING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SAYS ARE KEY. OUR
PRIMARY PARTNERS COMMUNICATING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
PUBLIC TO BRIGHTEN UP TO DATE
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
SCIENCE BASED EASIER UNDERSTAND
INFORMATION. THAT'S ACCESSIBLE
IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. WE
PARTICIPATE IN A QUARTER
COORDINATED STATE GOVERNMENT
AND CJ JUST RESPONSE IN
ENGAGING IN AN ALL GOVERNMENT
APPROACH AS YOU KNOW THIS IS
MUCH BIGGER THAN THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WE ARE AN
ALL OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO
THIS- AS IT IMPACTS ALMOST
EVERY ASPECT OF GOVERNMENT AND
THE SECTORS WITHIN THE
POPULATION SO FOSTERING THAT
COORDINATED MULTI AGENCY
APPROACH TO- NEED THAT ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF THE VARIOUS
SUBGROUPS WITHIN THE POPULATION
AND GEOGRAPHIC AREA AS- WE
DEVELOP UNIFIED DATA SYSTEMS
AND ANALYTICAL DASHBOARDS- FOR.
FOR HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
CONTINUE ON THAT CROSSES
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS. AND THEN
WE'VE REALLY PARTNER WITH OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT ALL OF THE
STRATEGIES. I'M AND I THINK
THOSE ARE PROBABLY THE KEY
AREAS OF RESPONSE THAT WE ARE.
CONTINUING AND AS YOU KNOW AS
ONE SORT OF WHITES DOWN ANOTHER
ONE. PICKS UP AND SO AS WE ARE
YEAH WE ALL STILL OBVIOUSLY SEE
THE VALUE AND NOT ONLY
VACCINATION BUT IN TESTING AND
CONTACT TRACING TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOT ONLY- THAT. STRAINS
THAT WERE USED TO SEEING AND
CALIFORNIA BUT SOME OF THE.
VARIANT STRAINS MATT AND WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE THAT- SURROUND
THOSE CASE. AND ICE CORN VOTE
SO THAT WE DON'T SEE. THE
VARIANT STRAINS ON GETTING
BIGGER AND BIGGER. THE QUESTION
NUMBER THREE HAS A CURRENT-
COVE IN NINETEEN RESPONSE
HIGHLIGHTED ANY GAPS AND READY
IN US THAT MIGHT BE- MIGHT HELP
THE STATE AND DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HEALTH TO PREPARE
FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC. AND YES
I THINK THAT WHAT WE HAVE ALL
RECOGNIZED AND KNOWN FOR A LONG
TIME IS THAT THE CORE ASSET OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS STAFFING AND
WE KNOW THAT OVER THE YEARS OF-
CUTTING OF FUNDS AND- YEAH ONE
TIME FUNDING SOURCES TO
ADDRESS. MANY OF BALANCE THAT
WE HAVE AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
NEEDS- NEEDS HELP AND PRIMARILY
AND STAFFING ALSO THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED A LOT IN TERMS OF DATA
ANALYTICS AND THE WAY THAT WE
LOOK AT DATA SO I THINK WE
WOULD. PUT INTO THE BUCKET OF
STAFFING THAT WE NEED. BIGGER
PUBLIC HEALTH AND- THAT
INCLUDES MORE EPIDEMIOLOGISTS
GENOMICS ON GENOMIC TESTING AND
SEQUENCING MODELING- EVALUATION
OF OUR INTERVENTIONS AND
PARTNERING WITH ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS IN A BIGGER WAY.
YOU'VE ALL SEEN IT PLAY OUT
ABOUT OUR INVESTMENT NEEDS TO
BE BIGGER IN TERMS OF OUR IT
AND DATA SYSTEMS AND THAT WE
HAVE INVESTED A LOT THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC AND WE ARE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK IN TERMS OF
BUILDING. THOSE SYSTEMS THAT
CAN REALLY- WITH STANDARD THE
NUMBER AND THE TYPES OF
INFORMATION THAT WE- NEED TO
PUT I FROM TESTING TO
VACCINATIONS AND I'M CONNECTING
ALL OF THAT DATA. I THINK THAT
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SOME OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
HAVE BUILT FOR THE SCANNED THEM
EXCELLENT WE ARE INDEED READY
TO DEAL WITH. ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE BUT ALSO ANY OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY THAT MAY COME
OUR DIRECTION I THINK WE
HIGHLIGHTED THAT THE H. ONE AND
ONE REPORT BUT WE DIDN'T
REALLY. KEEP A LOT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO BUILD UP DURING H. ONE
AND ONE AND- LONG ENOUGH TO.
ADDRESS THE PANDEMIC. THE NEXT
QUESTION IS HOW SHOULD STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS APPROACH
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT TOOLS ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP DETERMINE
WHERE ADDITIONAL FUNDING. OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS AS REQUIRED
AND WHETHER THERE IS A NEED. TO
ADDRESS FUNDING GAPS OR TO
ASSESS WHAT THOSE GAPS ARE. I
THINK HISTORICALLY FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS INCREASED
MOSTLY IN RESPONSE TO
SIGNIFICANT EVENTS. AND THESE
FUNDING INCREASES AS I'M SAT
HAVE BEEN SHORT TERM. ONE TIME-
AND HAVEN'T ALLOWED US TO BUILD
SOME OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
AND WE NEED THAT STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE TO RESPOND TO
FUTURE EVENTS AS RIGHT AS WELL
AS PROMOTE. OUR REGULAR HEALTH
PROGRAMS. THIS FUNDING NEEDS TO
ACCOUNT FOR BOTH THE INCREASING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH HUMAN
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AS YOU KNOW EVEN IF
YOU'VE GOT LEVEL FUNDING. OVER
TIME THE COST FOR SALARIES AND
BENEFITS AND THOSE KIND OF
THINGS CONTINUE TO INCREASE SO
YOU'RE REALLY. GETTING A
REDUCTION IF YOU'RE NOT KEEPING
UP WITH THOSE BENEFIT COSTS.
AND THERE ARE TOOLS THAT
ESTIMATE NECESSARY STAFFING
LEVELS FOR AND NEED IT FOR MANY
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS- YOU
KNOW WE JUST CAN USE THE
EXAMPLE OF CONTACT TRACING.
FIFTEEN CONTACT TRACERS FOR
EVERY HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
MANY PROGRAMS THAT SET UP. ON
HOW MANY STAFF YOU SHOULD HAVE
ON A PER CAPITA ASIS. THERE
ARE ALSO OTHER MODELS THAT LOOK
AT. PER CAPITA SPENDING ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND YOU KNOW
MANY- COME MAKE COMPARISONS ARE
FROM ACROSS THE NATION ACROSS
THE WORLD ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS.
IN PUBLIC HEALTH PER CAPITA. I
THINK YOU KNOW WE'RE UNLESS. IN
ORDER ACCURATE ACCURATELY GAUGE
WHETHER ADDITIONAL FUNDING OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS AS REQUIRED I
THINK IT COULD BE HELPFUL TO DO
SOME SORT OF AN ASSESSMENT
PARTICULARLY. IF WE COULD
DESIGN THAT IS THAT I'M- THE
ASSESSMENT SUCH A WAY THAT
ALLOWED FOR LOCAL FLEXIBILITY
AND STILL MEASURED SOME CORE
CAPABILITIES OF EACH PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. WE WOULD
NEED TO SORT OF DO THAT THROUGH
A CONTRACT I THINK- AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK AS WE
ASSESS ONGOING WORKFORCE NEEDS
LABOR CAPACITY CRITICAL
SUPPLIES- AND WE WOULD NEED TO
ENGAGE THEIR STAKEHOLDERS FROM
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH. HEALTH
OFFICERS LAB DIRECTORS PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME AREAS THAT THERE
ARE. VERY DIFFICULT TO RECRUIT
WE NEED TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE
STATUTORY RULES AND SOME OF
THAT EVEN DUTY STATEMENTS THAT
WE WRITE AND THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR SOME OF THESE POSITIONS TO
SEE IF THEY REALLY ARE-
WARRANTED AND WHETHER THERE ARE
SOME WAYS TO YOU- GIVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY- TO MEET COMMUNITY
NEEDS AND THE ROLES OF. THINGS
LIKE COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
AND WHERE WE CAN USE OTHER
CLASSIFICATIONS OR MAY WANT TO-
EXPAND. THE ROLE OF SOME OF
THOSE OTHER FOLKS AND OF MEAT
COMMUNITY NEEDS. I'M IN TERMS
PUBLIC. THE NOT NOT QUESTION
VERSION WHAT SEVEN. IN OUR
HEALTH FIRST WOULD BE OF.
THERE'S NATIONAL FREE MORE THAT
I. SHE ATKINS. AS WELL AS THAT
OF. ARE IN FOR OF REALLY
LOOKING AT THE WAY THAT WE-
KIND OF. UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WHAT ARE THE
CAPABILITIES THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS TO HAVE- IT'S A NATIONAL
MODEL IT LOOKS AT THAT KIND OF.
THE SEVEN CORE CAPABILITIES OF
A PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT- THE
OTHER ABILITY TO ASSESS AND
SURVEY ALL OF EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE
POLICY DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT.
COMMUNICATIONS COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPETENCIES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT THAT WAS NOT CORPS
FRAMEWORK ALLOWS YOU TO DO
OTHER PRESS ANY OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS. AND IF YOU
HAVE A AND- GOOD RESOURCES IN
EACH OF THOSE BUCKETS YOU CAN
ALSO READ DIRECT STAFF TO YOU
WHATEVER IT MEANT. NEW WEST
ADVANTAGE MIGHT BE WHEN YOU
HAVE SOMETHING LIKE A PANDEMIC
AND WE BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW
ALL OF THAT ALSO SHOULD IT
INVOLVES SOME CROSS TRAINING
AND SAM. AND IT'S REALLY HARD
WHEN YOU HAVE CATEGORICAL
FUNDING IT MAKES IT THAT MUCH
HARDER TO DO AND THAT CROSS
TRAINING BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THERE'S A LOT OF VALUE IN THAT
AND PARTNERING- ON THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN. ADDRESS THE NEXT AND THE
NEXT BIG THING- AN EQUITY
APPROACH WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT-
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC OF THOSE
THAT ARE. I'M MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED WE KNOW
THAT ALL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REALLY IT HAS ABOUT. THE
ADDRESSING THE DISPARITIES AND
INEQUITIES IN THE IN THE STATE
IF YOU WANT TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH YOU HAVE TO GET TO. SOME
OF THE ROOT CAUSES BUT- MAKE
FOR PEOPLE AND MAKE THE- RESULT
IN- LAST HEALTH FOR PEOPLE- THE
RECALLS ARE HISTORICAL AND
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES INCLUDING
RACISM. DISCRIMINATION SEXUAL
AND GENDER MINORITIES THE
IMPACT EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION ACT
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES HOUSING
HAVE THEIR SONS AND ACCESS TO
HEALTHY FOODS AND ENVIRONMENTS.
THESE CHRONIC STRESSES AND
TRAUMA AND EXPOSURES ADVERSELY.
IMPACT THAN OR DEVELOPMENT OF
CHILDREN IN AN IMPACT BRAINS
AND- THROUGHOUT THER LIFE. AND
THAT RESULT IN HIGHER RATES OF
CHRONIC DISEASE MENTAL ILLNESS
AND SUBSTANCE USE AND SO WE
WANT TO LOOK AT THE SOCIAL
ECONOMIC AND PHYSICAL MENTAL
IMPACTS. OF NOT ONLY. THE
SYSTEM BUT ALSO OF THIS
PANDEMIC AND THAT'S BEEN HAD IN
AN ENORMOUS AND LONG LASTING
IMPACT THAT WE DON'T YET
UNDERSTAND. AND WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE THAT CHALLENGE OVER
PROMOTING AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY
IS A LONG TERM ENDEAVOR AND WE
NEED TO BE READY TO TAKE THAT
ON. I AM AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THE STRATEGIES ARE TO ASSESS
AND MONITOR CHANGES IN THE
RANGE OF CONDITIONS AND FACTORS
THAT MAY HAVE IMPACTED THE
PANDEMIC ESTABLISH AND EXECUTE
A LONG TERM SURVEILLANCE AND
HAPPY ANALYSIS PLAN. APPLY
RESULTS BASED ACCOUNTABILITY
MODEL TO ESTABLISH ESTABLISH
THOSE POPULATION RESULT IN
INDICATORS SO WE REALLY CAN
MEASURE THEM OVER TIME. AND
INCORPORATE A TARGETED SET OF
KEY TOPICS AND STATE HEALTH
ASSESSMENT AND IMPROVEMENT
OFFER ONGOING MONITORING. ON
AND YOU KNOW I THINK BACK
PROBABLY AS WE'RE ALL STOCKTON.
REPAIR TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY THE GROUP MOVE ON TO THE
PANELISTS NOW BUT BEFORE WE DO
HOW CLOSE ARE WE TO THE
NATIONAL MODEL. I'M THAT IS A
GOOD QUESTION AND I DON'T BUT I
THINK WE ARE PUTTING THAT
TOGETHER THE NATIONAL MODEL IS
A SET OF CAPABILITIES IT IS NOT
SO IT DOESN'T GO SO FAR AS TO
SAY HOW MANY PEOPLE IT JUST
SAYS YOU NEED TO HAVE THESE
CAPABILITIES AND SO WE ARE- YOU
KNOW WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON SOME OF THIS
AND WILL BE- LOOKING AT WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND I THINK YOU ALSO
HAVE RECEIVED A PROPOSAL FROM
G. ACTIN THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ON KIND OF HOW THEY
SEE. DO YOU AGAIN THESE WITH
THE SAME MODEL MIND IN THE SAME
CAPABLE FOR MORE TO COME I
DON'T HAVE THAT TO SHARE TODAY
OKAY BUT AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
FIRST PERSON IF THAT MONEY WERE
NO OBJECT JUST HAVING THAT
FULLY INCORPORATED INTO
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE YOUR WISH.
OKAY OKAY LET'S MOVE. IT SHOULD
QUICK COMMENT THANK YOU THREE I
WOULD MAKE NOTE. AT THIS
ACTUALLY INTERESTING IN FOR
LAST OF THIS OF YEAR PER THE
PEN- THE BECAUSE US TO.
ESSENTIALLY HAPPY PERSON
HEARINGS AND SO FORTH WAS THAT
AT PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE HAD-
THEN DIRECTOR OF GIVE A
PRESENTATION ON THE STATE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT THIS SUB COMMITTEE OF BOTH
AT THAT IN A PRIOR HERE UNDER
PRESS- DRY KAREN DAY. I YES
CHAIR HAD EACH OF THEM TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE OUR WITH A
PUBLIC HEALTH. ASSESSMENT SO
THAT WE COULD TRY TO MORE
ADEQUATELY FUND- PUBLIC HEALTH
SO THIS IS PRETTY COVERED- AND
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT SOME OF
THE ITEMS WHICH I KNOW WAS-
PRESENTED HERE TODAY BUT AS WE
GET INTO OUR A PANEL HERE-
THOSE ARE ACTUALLY MORE
MAKE NOTE THAT AND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THE PANELS ADDRESS
THIS- THE ROLE NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT PLAYS AND ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY LIMITING THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT GOES TO PUBLIC
HEALTH OF THE LOCAL LEVEL. SO
WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW THE
DISEASE'S DON'T STOP AT THE
BORDERS POLITICAL BORDERS SO
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE A
STATE THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND WE HAVE THE VARIOUS
COUNTIES AND WE HAVE SOME CITY
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH BUT
WHAT IS THE INTERFACE BETWEEN
THEM. RIGHT AND EVEN BETWEEN
THE VARIOUS COUNTY DEPARTMENTS
AND ALSO THE OTHER LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW
THAT WE'VE CLOSE MANY PUBLIC
HEALTH LABS SO IT'S KIND OF BY
THE FULL REGIONAL LIES BUT IT'S
NOT PLANNED REGIONALI STRAIGHT
SO COUNTY DECIDED THEY DON'T
WANT A PUBLIC EVER TRY MY SON
THAT KIND HAVE. AND NOW THE
ACCOUNT RELY ON ANOTHER
COUNTIES HEALTH RIGHT SO BE
INTERESTED ONE PANEL IS TO TALK
ABOUT SORT OF THIS HEALTH.
WHICH WOULD YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THAT'S IF ON THE FED RATE BUT
THE STATE. AN THE STATE HAS ITS
OWN. AND THE CAL. AND SOME OF
THE COUNT HAVE A LOT. IN IN. IS
REQUIRED. FOR EACH COUNTY
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN. OF FOR OWN
K. AS- AND THEN THE WHAT DEGREE.
DO WE- AND- OF. IN WHETHER IT'S
AT THE COUNTY LOW TO STAY LEVEL
I WAS A PANDEMIC OF ME. SERVE
Y. HUNDRED YEAR. BUT I WOULD
POINT OUT WE ALWAYS HAVE AN
OUTPUT. EVERY YEAR JUST ALWAYS
AT LEAST ONE NOT BOTH. THING I
CAN PLAY TO EVER SINGLE. WHAT
WE NEED TO DO. COMPARE SO LIKE
TO ALSO THE- OF. HOW WE BUILD
AND SEARCH CAPACITY. THAT OFTEN
IS NOT ONE. A TIME IT'S EITHER
RE. OR WHOLE STAY- AND SO I
HOPE LOOKING. TO THAT DISK. FOR
OUR FIRST. AND ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THE STATE PERHAPS
COMMENT ON THAT AT THE WHEN
WE'VE COMPLETED THE INDIVIDUAL.
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY TO BE HEARD.
IN AND AGAIN AS WE'RE TALKING
THIS WANT TO HEAR ABOUT EX BUT
ALSO ANY ANY THOUGHTS IDEAS YOU
HAVE ABOUT. WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN GOING FORWARD OKAY I
THINK WE'LL START WITH ME GIVEN
EXECUTIVE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. EIGHT THANK YOU
TURN NUMBER- MY NAME MICHELLE
GIVE SAME THE COUNTY EXACT IS
TO. OF CALIFORNIA REP LOCAL
DEPARTMENT ACROSS THE STATE AND
WE'RE A MEMBER OF THE- CAN'T
WEEK. WHICH IS LED BY
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS COUNTIES
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS COMMUNITY
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES AND
CONSIST OF NEARLY A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATION. AND I SENATOR PAN
I DID HEAR YOUR QUESTIONS AND
IF THE CHAIR WILL ALLOW ME A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME I WILL TRY
TO ADDRESS THEM WITHIN MY
REMARKS. AND BUT IS ESSENTIALLY
OUR COALITIONS MESSAGES THEY
CAL CAN'T WAIT THE NEXT PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO INVEST IN LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THESE
INVESTMENTS NEED TO HAPPEN NOW
AND I'D UNDERSCORE MUCH OF WHAT
MR ELLIE SHARED REGARDING THE
NEEDS- AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE PANDEMIC
HIGHLIGHTED WENT HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS OF KNOWN FOR SOME
TIME THE DISAPPEAR UNDER OF
HEALTH OR STAY I'M PREPARED TO
ADDRESS A PANDEMIC SUCH AS
THEIR- AND TWENTY. SENATOR P.
YOU CHAIRED AT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE INFORMATION HEARING
ON HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
COULD ADD CAPACITY. DURING THAT
HEARING A PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
DIRECTOR AND THIS I THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH LAB PLAY IN OUR- AND- TO
EMERGING. AND PROVIDING TIE
INCOME. TESTING AND DURING THAT
HEARING SHE GOT THAT NOT LABS
PUBLIC HEALTH LAB TO CLOSE IN
THE PRIOR TEN YEARS DUE TO A OF
FUNDING. AND I BELIEVE ME I'LL
JUST THE- WE NEEDED OR ANDY
SYSTEM AND HIGHLY THE NEED
ADDITIONAL. IN TECH SYSTEMS AND
STAFF. A PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECT
IDENTIFY THE LACK OF
SUSTAINABLE FLEXIBLE. AND I
DON'T THAT IS A KEEP TO DRAW
THE BIRD OF CHRONIC DISEASE-
AND THE DISK. IMPACT ON
COMMUNITY OF COLOR. ANOTHER
HEALTH DIRECTOR NOTED THAT
HEALTH INCLUDING DOT. NURSES AT
THE D. LEVERAGE IN- AND DISEASE
INVEST. ARE OTHERS ARE THE MOST
CA. OF A HER. I THAT TIME SHE
THAT LOW HEALTH TO DID HAVE THE-
NEEDED TO RESPOND TO A LARGE.
ALONG TERM IN THE- AND URSULA.
CONSIDER FONG INVEST AND HOW
HEALTH AND- JUST DRINKING THE
LOCAL COULD. WILL DID WE KNOW
THEN KOBE NINETEEN WHICH AROUND
THE- WELL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ARE IS. BETTER FUNDING I'M
GOING COHEN. S. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT THE FINDINGS THE
THIS FUNDING SO SPECIFIC AND
CAN BE USED TO ADDRESS.
CRITICAL THAT AS STDS ARE
DISEASE AND IS SUPPORT THE DATA
WORK OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO. BE
THE NINETEEN. AND THIS IS WHY
ON. SO FLEXIBLE ISN'T. THE
CAN'T WE KHALILI IS USED. ARE
TO. NINETY ONGOING GENERAL FOR
COLOR HEALTH WORK AND I
INTEREST NEEDS. AND JUST UNDER
THREE FIVE AND FOR IN A- OF
PUBLIC HEALTH RIGHT INTO. AS
RECALL BY EIGHTY FORTY. IN SAN
JUAN. THIS MEANS FUND TO STAFF
MOBILE IN THE- CLINICS FOR.
HAVE C. AND HER TEXAS ALLOW
PUBLIC HEALTH TO REACH THEM
WATER NEIGHBORHOOD SUCH AS- AND
HOMELESS. IN SACRAMENTO THIS
FUNDING INCREASED CAPACITY TO
INVEST. SCREENING CAN COMING
DISEASE SUCH AS- AND RIVERSIDE
THIS FUNDING TO EXPAND OF
COMING. DISEASE INVESTING. AND
I SHOULD NOTE THAT IN TWENTY
ONE RIVERSIDE COUNTY HAD THE
SAME NUMBER OF CA. DID INVEST.
THAT HAD IN THE- EIGHTIES
DESPITE THE GROWING PART. FOR
OTHER JURISTIC ACROSS THE STATE
IN NEED TO BAN. WE WORK.
CHRONIC DISEASE AND
INTERVENTION SIX PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE COME. PROGRAMS AMONGST
OTHER BY. TO COMMUNITY. AND WE
CAN'T WORK THE SITE OF HEALTH.
WHICH NEW YORK UP AT CHARACTER
I AS NICKEL. PANICKING OR P.
AND SENATOR CAN'T ADDRESS SOME
YOUR- ABOUT THE ROLE OF REAL.
AND ACCOUNT IN THE STATE AND
FOR UP WITH. FOR TO FIND PUBLIC
HEALTH. AT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
DO RECEIVE. NINETY ONE RELY.
AID ONE OF THAT FUNDS FUNDING
SOURCES LOCAL DRESSED. HAVE AND
JURISTIC. AT COUNTIES IN AND AS-
THAT THIS. THREE CITIES ME ALL
PUT UP AND WILL I AM. ATTY
OTHER AND ALL I MEAN IT'S A FOR
X. ME. IN THE- CON AROUND
REALIGN WAS THAT. WE WOULD BUT
THERE WAS OF FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
WOULD BE REAL LIKE REAL. TO
THIS IS REALLY NOT MEETING THAT
OBLIGATION AND I SHOULD ALSO
SAY THAT. I'M IN TERMS OF STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDING AS ISN'T WE
ALL PROBABLY KNOW HAT WE'VE
SEEN IS. THAT FUNDING COMING
DOWN BASED ON THE DISEASE. SO
EACH ONE ADELINE ABLE AS HE GOT
WEST NILE LIKE THEIR BUCKETS OF
FUNDING BUT THE REAL CHALLENGES
THAT IT PROHIBITS US TO LOOK
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT AND
REALLY ADDRESSED THINGS
HOLISTICALLY. AND KEEPS OUR
DEPARTMENTS IN THESE INDIVIDUAL
FUNDING CYCLES. AND THEN IN
TERMS OF SURGE CAPACITY WE'VE
BEEN HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS-
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. AND
REALLY THAT THE- KEY CHALLENGES
HAVING THE STAFF ON HAND AND
MANY OF OUR DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC TURNED
INTO. CULVER DEPARTMENTS FOR
LACK OF BETTER TERMS WHERE.
MANY OF THE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT HAD TO BE
SATISFIED AND PUT ON HOLD WHICH
CREATES- EVEN MORE CHALLENGES
RATE STD RATES HAVE GROWN. YOU
KNOW WAS IT TREMENDOUSLY DURING
THIS TIME. JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
AND SO HAVING MORE STAFF THAT
COULD BE FLEXIBLE THAT WE CAN
USE TO ADDRESS ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT OUTBREAKS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT'S THAT WE WILL SEE.
AND CONTINUE TO FACE WOULD BE
HELPFUL I'M AND IT WOULD HELP
THE SEARCH CAPACITY BUT RIGHT
NOW OUR OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT STAFFING. HAS HAS
SHRUNK BY 2224% IN TERMS OF
WORK FORCE AND SO BECAUSE OF
THAT HAVING. SEARCH CAPACITY ON
HAND HAS BEEN A HUGE CHALLENGE
FOR US. AND SO THIS IS WHY WE
ARE YOU KNOW WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS INCLUDED
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THEIR PRIORITIES AND WE'RE
ASKING- THAT YOU SUPPORT OUR
REQUEST FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ON GOING PUBLIC. I HAD GENERAL
FUND FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE WE NEED PEOPLE. AND
THE MOST BENEFICIAL THING THAT
WE COULD HAVE HAD THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC IS PEOPLE THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN MOVED IN
TRANSITION. AND AS YOU KNOW AND
AS YOU STATED CENTER PAN WEEK
WE PROBABLY WILL NOT HAVE THIS
PANDEMIC OF THIS MAGNITUDE IN
THE NEXT. YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY
MANY MANY YEARS BUT WE WILL
HAVE OTHER LESSER. CHALLENGES
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
WILL NEED TO FACE AND SO WE
SHOULD ALSO EVALUATE. WHAT IS
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. DO WE HAVE
ADEQUATE STAFFING RATIOS
INCAPAZ. I MEAN WE HAVE
INTEREST. WHERE THEY- YOU KNOW
FIVE PUBLIC HEALTH. WE OTHERS
HAVE QUITE FIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES AND THAT DOES NOT.
ASSURE THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE STATE. WE ALSO
HAVE. I BELIEVE NOW THAT. OVER
ELEVEN A ROUGH ELEVEN HEALTH
LABS THAT IT CLOSED. AT THE
LAST YOU KNOW DO. OR MORE. AND
WHEN WE REALLY THINK OF THAT
HEALTH LABORATORIES WORD FIRST.
THAT DO ANY OF THE TEST RELATED
KOBE TO NOW THERE ARE. MOVING
ON IT YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
SEQUENCING AND SO FOR SO THEY
PAY A CRITICAL ROLE. AND WE
WERE NEED A- WHAT THE RIGHT
SIZE OF PUBLIC YOU KNOW PUBLIC
LABS IN OUR SPEECH BE AND I
THINK THERE'S MANY OTHER IT.
THAT I WOULD JUST YEAR WHERE.
YOU KNOW REALLY NEED TO. AND
THEN. WORK TOWARD- ABLE TO
STAFF UP AT HAVE THE RIGHT
RESOURCES THAT WE CAN BE
PREPARED WE LOOK AT PUBLIC
HEALTH. JUST AS A OTHER. SAFETY
FUNCTION RIGHT AND- YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT OUR STATE AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ALLOWING ME TO GO
A LITTLE LONGER TO ADDRESS OUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GIVENS DR V. FIVE HEALTH OFFICE
FROM STAND. COUNTY YEAH THANK
YOU ANYTHING YOU MISGIVINGS
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M TRULY TO
BE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS JULIE
HUESO KLEINER THE STATUS COUNTY
PUBLIC OFFICE AND DISEASES
PHYSICIAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE HEALTH OFFICERS JUST. OF
CAL REP LOOK HEALTH OFFICERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. INSURE
YOUR WORK NINE QUICKLY
OVERWHELMED PUBLIC HEALTH WITH
CRITICAL NEED TRYING. THE OF
PEOPLE IN FACT TO. MY MEASURES
IN TO STOP. SOME NUMBER ON THIS
WERE THAT WE SAW INTO THE NINE
STAFF. HOW RECENT JUST UNDER IS
THOUSAND. OF DISEASE. THAT
NUMBER AND TWO WEST HUNDRED
SEVENTY POWER. OUR SYSTEMS WERE
NOT SET UP FOR MANAGING THIS
MASS INFLOW OF REPORTS.
HUNDREDS OF LAW WHERE ELECTED.
REPORTING TAKAO AND. LOCAL PART
RECEIVE THOUSANDS OF CALLS AND
NEEDED TO DO WITH THE DAY- NOT
A. DURING THE COLD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THAT WASN'T. NEED FOR
CAN. TO THE- THAT CARE. SCHOOLS
BUSINESS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANISED. AND ELECTED A- TO
NAME A FEW. DEDICATED HEALTH
STAFF TRAIN IN COUPLE MESSAGE
ARE SO MESSED. BUT THERE ARE
NOT. OUR LIMIT ON PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING AND GAP HAS BEEN
ROUGHLY APPARENT. THE A DV. AND
I STAFF WITH SKILL IN DATA.
GEOCODING CREATING DASH THEY
WERE SHORTS IN THE AND THAT AT
A- NEED TO BE TO. IN BEGIN
MONTHS OF PANDEMIC. EVEN IN THE
BEST QUE SCENARIO THE CO
RELATED WORKFLOW FOR HEALTH
CONTINUE TO BE SICK. THROUGH
TWENTY TWO ONE AND INTO TO SEE
WHAT TWENTY TWO TWO FOR SURE.
THERE WILL BE AN IN WORK FROM
TO PUBLIC HEALTH AS HAD TO REDO
STAFF TO PENN CHRIS. OVER THE
RED PROGRAM AT. WE'LL START TO
SEE THE IMPACT READER OF OUR
STAFF SO CONCERT SAID IS ONE
EXAMPLE I'LL USE- THERE'S BEEN
A INCREASE IN THIS PART OF
SURPLUS THE PAST TEN YEAR- IN
CAL- ALONG THIS IN. WE SEEING-
AN INCREASE BABY FOR MOST OF
ESPECIALLY THIS JOAQUIN- WE
WORK HARD INSTEAD HOW AND WITH
SEEN AT THE- IN OUR- FOR WITH
STEP- BUT IN. TWO AND FORTY WE
CAN NINETY BAY FINAL SEVERAL.
WHICH WAS IN. FROM TWELVE IN.
TWO NINE. PUBLIC HEALTH PRO
WERE FRONT PRIOR TO PEN DOWN-
AS WE THIS INCREASING SUPPLY IN
THE TWO. AND LATE TO. ALL S. T.
PROGRAMS. GRADUALLY DIVERT TO.
CASES IN ENSURING. FOR SYPHILIS
FLATTEN THE CURVE AND PREVENT-
SPREAD OF. AND CONFOUND-
COMMITTEE GONORRHEA NO LONGER.
A CONTEXT RESTORED IS- IN FACT
DO A LOT OF STAFF AND THE NAY
TO PRIOR. OUR SEASONS ABOUT
SEVENTY FIVE PER OF ALL CAN
USES RECORD STANISLAUS COUNTY
OR NO INVEST- OF THOSE BEING
COMMITTEE GONORRHEA AND CRY
HAVE TO. C. IN REALLY THE
PEOPLE OF LEVEL OF FUNDING WAS
NOT. TO SUPPORT ADVOCATE NUMBER
OF A STAFF. I WANTED TO STAY IN
CLOSE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF
FOR NOW OR- TODAY FOR STAFF
COUNTY AS THEY HUNDRED FIFTY OF
OUR PANDEMIC EMERGENCE UP.
BENEFIT RISK WHAT BY REQUIRE
SEVEN A WEEK OFF. FOR ABOUT
MONTHS AND- WORK ON. SIX DAYS A-
RUNNING WHAT VACCINES SIX DAYS
A WEEK OVER FOUR MONTHS DARK
STRETCHED OUR STAFF NEARLY TO
THE BREAK POINT. KNOWING THAT
OUR EFFORTS ARE VALUE AND- IS
CRUCIAL AND I THINK YOU FOR AND
ME HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
HEALTH GAPS IN THE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ROLE COLEMAN. ADD ME
TO. OF POLICY FOR. CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC NETWORK. RUN COLEMAN
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
THE CALIFORNIA AND CAL NETWORK
WHICH IS WHY MULTI CULTURAL
HEALTH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO THE WI FI. UNITING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR GREEN
CONSUMER VOICE TO THE- WE CAN
ADVANCE EQUITY ABANDONING
CERTAINLY. HEALTH NEEDS FOR
SOME TO DELAY CARE FOR CRIME
INCREASE THE THINKING. AND CALL
PEOPLE STRESS NAMES ARE IN THE
IF THEY AFFORD CARE GIVING OUR
WERE LIEU HEALTHCARE ALL THE
WITH JOE LOSS PEOPLE OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY LATINO NATIVE AND
PACIFIC I PEOPLE OR AT LEAST TO
HAVE THE USUAL. HEALTHCARE MOST
LIKELY THE WITH CRIME HEALTH
CONDITIONS SUCH AS HEART
DISEASE BY AND ASTHMA AND
REPORT. TREE WITHIN THE HEALTH
SECTOR FURTHERMORE PEOPLE LOOK
FROM LIKELY LIVING REDLINING
WHICH TODAY PLAY BY ADVERSE
SOCIAL TO. INCLUDE ENVIRONMENT
TOXINS THROUGH DESERT I THINK
CONCERNS BUT STILL FROM POVERTY
THE PANDEMIC ON THE PRIME OF
OUR HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
THIS BUSINESS TO MAKE RACISM
THAT BASED BATES GAINES WHO
HOURS THIS. AND THEN NAY
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT FROM
PUBLIC. COMMUNITIES OF COLOR L.
G. B. T. PLUS AND PEOPLE WITH
THIS SPACE CULTURE AND LANGUAGE
VERY TO CARE WELL OF TRAUMA
SERVICES AND BROADBAND. THAT
HAVE MEETINGS BY THE END WE'RE
ALSO SEEING HEALTH IN WORLD
NEED ARE AS PEOPLE ARE. ANXIETY
STRESS OVER NINETY AND ALSO
DELAY OR HEALTH. IN ON GOING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT IS
RACISM. IT IS AGAINST THIS
BACKDROP THAT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR INDOOR THROUGH THE MOST
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF COPING
NINETY. THE HIGHEST RATES OF
COMMUNITY INFECTION. MORE
NUMBER OF DEBT. AND THE
GREATEST OF JOBS INCOME. SO WE
OFTEN ASK OUR WHAT THE STATE
WELL TO ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES
IN WHERE IS IT ALL IN SHORT. WE
CERTAINLY HAVE A THE THAT
STATUS DE THE FOCUS RESOURCES
ON NEIGHBORHOODS COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED BY. SOCIAL WE
MORE THAT WE ALSO THE COURSE
ECONOMY. HEALTH MATCH WASN'T
NEXT FUNDED IS ABOUT OUR-
INSTITUTES. THE PRICE OF THAT
WE ARE ALL. WE ALL HEALTHY WHEN
LEAVE NO BEHIND. WE HOPE AS WE
DO OPEN WE ARE A TO INCLUDE
EQUITY MATCH. AS THIS REOPENS
MINIMUM THE IN OF THE OF
ALREADY BEEN PARTICIPATING BY
PANDEMIC. THE STATE HAS ALSO.
COUNTIES TO INVEST. PORTION OF
COPING RELIEF ON IN THE
COMMUNITIES HARDEST BY THE
PANDA. EVEN WITH ALL THIS GOOD
WORK IT IS JUST A STEP FORWARD
MAKE THE- CHANGES OUR HEALTH
SYSTEM. AFTER OVER A CENTURY A
BILL. IN MANY CAL COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. OUR PUBLIC SO HELPS.
IS A- UNDER AND RECOGNIZE TO
ACT IN PUBLIC HEALTH WILL BE.
BUT A LOT BE ABLE TO DIRECT
EQUITY DOLLARS AND MAYBE ABLE
TO BE USED OKAY THE K. HEALTH
AND HUMAN. AGENCY TO DRAW SO
CAN. WE RECOMMEND ALLEGE. TAKEN
OF STEPS OUT WITH EVEN EVER
WILL GIVE ME. AND ALSO WITH CAN
BE AND- THIS THE DAMAGE THE
PENDING INTO IN CASE A BILL A
MORE ECO CAL. NUMBER ONE WE
NEED TO DECLARE THAT RACISM IS
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THE
KNOWLEDGE HOW LONG STANDING.
INEQUITIES REYES. AB HE DONE.
IN TO THE OF CAL COMMUNITIES
ARE. IN DEVELOP STRONG ACT PLAN
ACROSS HELPING YOU MISTER EACH.
TO ENSURE THE ALL COMMUNITIES
CAN THRIVE. NUMBER TWO WE ARE
NEED TO RE. OUR HEALTH. OUR
MORTGAGES. NUMBER TWO WE NEED
TO REMAIN OUR HELL IN PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE. AS A TOOL FOR
AGAIN HEALTH AND EQUITY NOW
ONLY IS REACHED TO IN THE SICK
THIS. AND. FINAL ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
THAT ADDRESS HEALTHCARE
DISPARITIES. PART OF THE
OVERSIGHT OF FUNDING COULD BE
CREATED WE COULD CREATE A TASK
FORCE BACKING INCLUDES VARIOUS
DIRECTORS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY G. MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE ADVOCATES AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO ASSESS
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND TO DEVELOP
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO REDUCE
HEALTH DISPARITIES GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE WE ARE
CURRENTLY. ASKING AT THAT WE
INVEST NO LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
RACIAL JUSTICE INNOVATION
FUNDING CAN BE USED BY A
VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY BY
REDUCING DISPARITIES. AND
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES OUR
STATE CAN MEET THIS CHALLENGE
WE'VE SEEN THAT WE WHEN WE SAT
ON THE SIDE IN THE PAST TO
REDUCE DISPARITIES SPECIFICALLY
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECTS. WE CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE COMMUNITY BENEFIT
FROM THE CHANGES WE MAKE WE'VE
SEEN THE BENEFITS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REACH OTHER STUDENTS
WHEN WE CREATED PROGRAMS TO
SERVE THE CRITICAL NEEDS OF
DEMOCRATS THAT HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY IGNORED IN THE PAST.
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND OUR BROADER
COALITION TO FIND WAYS TO
CREATE A RACIAL JUSTICE
INNOVATION FUNDS THAT IS BLACK
CIVIL ENOUGH TO DEVELOP
PROPOSALS AND ALSO FUND
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE DELIVERY
APPROACHES TO REDUCE HEALTH.
DISPARITIES ACROSS OUR STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HOME- NEXT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM DEL CRUZ CHIEF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH SPECIALIST
L. A. COUNTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CENTERS AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY PASSION FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH WITH YOU. MY NAME IS
HECTOR BELLERIN IS AN ARMY
CHIEF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALIST FOR LA COUNTY PUBLIC
HEATH AS WELL AS A MEMBER OF
SEIU SEVEN TWENTY ONE. INVERNAL
HEALTH CAN SOMETIMES BE
OVERLOOKED WHEN YOU THINK OF
PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE WE'RE
VERY GOOD AT WORKING BEHIND THE
SCENES TO HELP PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. THE MOMENT
YOU TAKE OUT THE TRASH IN THE
MORNING WE'VE ALREADY JOINED
YOU. BECAUSE WE HAVE INSPECTORS
ON LANDFILLS. SURE IN AT THE
WAIST IS EXPOSED UP PROPERLY.
WE'RE THERE WITH YOU AT LUNCH
THANK YOU RESTAURANTS REDUCE
YOUR RISK OF. FOOD BORNE
ILLNESS. WHEN YOU GET BACK HOME
THE APARTMENT WE'VE GOT YOU
COVERED BECAUSE WE INSPECT
APARTMENT BUILDING. TO MAKE
SURE THE MOST BASIC
HABITABILITY STANDARDS ARE MET.
THOSE WHO WISH NO BERMAN THE
MOLE HUNT FOR HEAT IS PROVIDED.
AND REQUIRED REPAIRS ARE MADE.
AND WE'RE WITH YOU ON THE
WEEKEND FOR AN AFTERNOON OUT AT
THE BEACH WE MONITOR THE OCEAN
WATER. SURE THIS STATE THIS
WOMAN MIGHT. NOW THIS ALREADY
HAVING A FULL PLATE OF
RESPONSIBILITIES. PROBABLY HAS
MADE IT NECESSARY FOR US TO
TAKE ON EVEN MORE. WE'VE TAKEN
ON THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
ENFORCING HEALTH OFFICER ORDERS
IN BUSINESSES THAT AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH. THE ALSO LONG
HAIR SALON- THE STORES CELL
PHONE STORES CAR DEALERSHIPS
PRIVATE OFFICES MUSEUMS CARD
ROOMS THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
THE IMPACT THE COLD IT IS HAD
OUR WORKFORCES INTERNATIONAL
AND IT'S COME WITH CHALLENGES
AND PERSONAL SACRIFICE. AT THE
BEGINNING WE WEREN'T EQUIPPED
WITH PP INSPECTORS RASTER SPEC
BUSINESS AS WELL HE IS FINE
WANTED REJECT THEMSELVES AND
LOVED ONES AT HOME. IT'S A
SITUATION AND NOBODY SHOULD
EVER FIND THEMSELVES. AS QUOTED
MARSHON INSPECTORS WERE
CONFRONTED BY HOSPITAL WORKERS
AND PATIENTS FOR EXAMPLE
LEGIONS INSPECTORS INTO A
VERBAL ABUSE WELL THE
INTERACTIONS WERE FILMED AND
POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA. SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE COULD
HAVE BEEN MINIMIZED IF
RESOURCES WERE AVAILABLE
LOCALLY OR POSSIBLY PROVIDED ON
THE STATE FEDERAL LOCAL.
EXAMPLE THE NEED FOR PP WAS
SOMETHING THAT SEEMED TO CATCH
EVERYONE OFF GUARD IT SPEAKS TO
THE NEED FOR ENHANCED
PREPARATION. OR FOR ALL THE-
LOCALLY WE COULD HAVE
BENEFITTED IF THE GROUNDWORK
WAS ALREADY LATE. ON LICENSE
FOOD VENDING. LOCALLY THIS WAS
IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE NO FUNDING
WAS AVAILABLE TO DO THIS WORK
ALTHOUGH WE DID WELL THEIR
DRESS CODE ISSUES AND PERMITTED
FOOD FACILITIES. YOU ARE
PREPARED TO PROPERLY ADDRESS
LARGE GROUPS OF PEOPLE TOGETHER
BROUGHT ON LICENSE FOOD VENDORS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE
GATHERINGS TYPICALLY HEARD TO
COMMUNITIES. FORTUNATELY BY. HE
BETTER PREPARE FOR FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES WE'RE
GOING TO NEED CRITICAL AND BEST-
THE MOST PRESSING INVESTMENTS
IN MY EYES OUR PERSONNEL AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES TECHNOLOGICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH WE'RE HAVING TO SAY
GOODBYE TO MANY OF OUR EXPERTS.
UNDER TIENEN OTHERS TOOK EARLY
RETIREMENT THAT WAS EXPEDITED
BY THE OVERWHELMING DEMANDS OF
POPE. STILL OTHERS LEAVING FOR
WHAT THEY SEE AS BETTER
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. WE NEED TO HIRE MORE
STAFF ACROSS ALL POSITIONS BY
LITTLE HEALTH. COMMUNITY
EDUCATORS PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
HELP IS NEEDED ACROSS THE
BOARD. REGARDING RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT WE NEED TO CREATE A
PUBLIC HEALTH FOCUS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM PROVIDE
INCENTIVES IS YOUR POST
GRADUATE DEGREES. OFFERED
PRAYERS SHIPS OFFER FELLOWSHIPS
THESE ARE ALL THINGS WE NEED TO
RECRUIT AND CULTIVATE. A NEW
GENERATION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL. YOU IN OUR INBOX
SPUR AS WELL FOR EXAMPLE. IN
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH WE FIND
OURSELVES REDUCING OFFICE SPACE
TO SAVE MONEY. IF YOUR DOCTOR
IS BEING COMBINED INTO MAKE
OFFICES WHICH IS INCREASING
NUMBER OF STAFF UNCOMFORTABLE
IF NOT ON STATE LEVELS AND A
LOT OF POLLUTED. NOW THE
OUTCOMES OF THE IMPORTANT WORK
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
REFORM IS SOMETIMES OVERLOOKED.
AND UNDERAPPRECIATED BECAUSE
WHAT WE DO IS PROACTIVE IN
INTENDED TO PREVENT NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES. BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THE WORK IS INDEED
NECESSARY AND ESSENTIAL.
SENATORS PLEASE SUPPORT PUBLIC
HELP BY INVESTING IN INCLUDING
AN ONGOING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
A YEAR STATE GENERAL FUND
EIGHT. IN YOUR BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER LUCAS. MISTER
EUGENE KANSEN PLEASE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH NETWORK. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS EUGENE KANSEN POLICY
ANALYST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BLACKHAWK NETWORK AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR HEALTH EQUITY
FUND COALITION THE COALITION IS
REQUESTING A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION OF ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION OVER TWO YEARS
SIXTY MILLION PER YEAR I WANT
TO CALIFORNIA HELD AT THE PARK.
WE ALSO SUPPORTING A COMPANION
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY
EIGHT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIKE GIPSON
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH SUPPORT.
I NEED FOR THIS ONE IS BIGGER
THE APPARENT. I'M SURE MOST OF
YOU HAVE RECKONED RIGHT NOW
IT'S ONE OF OURS. BECAUSE
EXACERBATED AND AMPLIFIED THE
INEQUITIES. THAT HAVE LONG
EXISTED IN OUR COMMUNITIES. IF
YOU WANT TO TRULY ADDRESS A
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE MUST ADDRESS THE
INEQUITIES. BECAUSE SUCH
DISPARITIES TO EXIST TO DO THAT
WE MUST ADDRESS THE ROOT ****
YOU MUST LOOK UP STREAM AND
ACTIVELY INVESTING PUBLIC
HEALTH PREVENTION AND THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
CHRONIC UNDERINVESTMENT
DISINVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PREVENTION AND RESULTED IN
A DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
LARGELY PREVENTABLE PRE
EXISTING HEALTH CONDITIONS SUCH
AS HYPERTENSION. HEART DISEASE
AND DIABETES AS WELL AS CROWDED
OR IN OUR INSTITUTION HOUSING.
UNSTABLE EMPLOYMENT. AND LACK
OF ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD. DUE
TO A LEGACY IS REYES. THIS
BURDEN HAS JUST. ON OPPORTUNITY
A COLOR I WOULD BE TEACHING
PLUS AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
WILL CONTINUE TO BEAR THE BRUNT
HEALTH AND SOCIAL IMPACTS OF
CODE NINETEEN. HEALTH REFORM
WHICH WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH'S OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY WOULD ALLOW THE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS TO BE
DIRECTED TOWARDS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. CLINICS
PRIME ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. ELIGIBLE
ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE ALLOWED
TO USE THE FUNDS TO ADDRESS
HOUSING SECURITY. AND SECURITY
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY SCHOOLS IN
CHILD CARE COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
AND HATE CRIMES AS WELL AS THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT. ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. IN THIS
IS VALUE OF LOCAL COULD.
RECIPIENTS OF FUNDING EACH AREA
WERE USED LOCAL NEEDS. AND
INDICES ARE HEALTH PROJECT.
IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES TAILORED
FOR LOCAL NEEDS. ELDERLY FUND
IS ALSO TRUE TO ITS NAME AS WE
ALL KNOW IT IS IMPORTANT
COMMUNITIES. NEED TO SUPPORT
ACCESS TO RESPOND. THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE HIT
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARD CONNECT
ONE OF OUR STANDING NEXT HAVE
SUFFERED FROM CHRONIC
UNDERINVESTMENT. ASK. IT WILL
BE AN OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE COME
THAT WILL ENSURE. THAT THE FULL
OPERATES AND MANNER. AND ENSURE
THAT THEY CAN ORGANISER
CRITICAL NEED I'M NOT BEHIND.
IMPORTANTLY ALWAYS COMMITTEE
WILL THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
WILL BACK TO THE LEDGE. WITH A
PLAN ON HOW CREATE A- SOURCE OF.
FUNDING TO REDUCE HEALTH. AND
TRASH SOCIAL TO. OF HEALTH. AS
I CLOSE I WANT TO THANK BUDGET
SO. FOR HOLDING IMPORTANT
HEARING. I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT WILL INVEST IN
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WORK TO
ADDRESS HEALTH INEQUITIES IN
OUR STATE INCLUDING SEAPLANES
RACIAL JUSTICE IMMIGRATION
FINDERS WELL AS OTHERS. WE
TRULY NEED ALL HANDS ON DECK TO
ADDRESS. HEALTH INEQUITIES AND
SHIFT THE PARADIGM. LARA TO
TAKE OUT OF. TO BE HAVING FUN
US. NUMBER TWO TO DO BY OUR-
BETTER BONTA PARTS OF THE-
THANK YOU FOR MUCH MR CAN.
THANKS WILL GO TO- A HOST OF
FINO AL RATO MINYA. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I AM HONORED TO
APPEAR BEFORE BE APPEAR BEFORE
YOU THIS EVENING MY NAME IS
JOSEPHINE ON WHAT OTHER MEN I
IN MY PRONOUNS ARE SHE HER AND
HERS I PROBABLY SERVICES CEO OF
SAFE PASSAGES AND REPRESENTS A
RACIAL ETHNIC. MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION AND THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT WE ARE YOUR PARTNERS IN
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITIES. SEXY RT P.
CURRENTLY FUNDS THIRTY FIVE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SERVING FIVE
POPULATION GROUPS AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATIN NEXT ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND NATIVE
AMERICANS AND LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITIES SEVEN OF THE
PROJECT'S THIRD THE DISTRICTS
REPRESENTED BY THE MEMBERS OF
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. THE CRT P.
HAS BEEN FUNDED AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO THE MENTAL SERVICES
ACT BUT AND LESS ACTION IS
TAKEN WILL CEASE NEXT APRIL
THIS CRT P. NETWORK AS TRUSTED
AND STRATEGICALLY POSITIONED
COLLECTIVELY WE HAVE RESPONDED
TO KOBE NINETEEN THE RACIAL
RECKONING RESULTING FROM THE
POLICE KILLING OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR HE CRIMES AGAINST THE API
COMMUNITY ANTI IMMIGRANT
POLICIES. HOMOPHOBIA AND
TRANSPHOBIA INCLUDING RECENT
TRANSPHOBIC LEGISLATION
CONSIDERING THE CRT P. SERVES
THE VERY POPULATIONS THAT
SUFFER DISPROPORTIONATELY DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC THE VALUE AND
URGENCY OF SUSTAINING THIS
PROJECT IS OBVIOUS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE C. R. D. P.
B. C. BY. THE KERR PRO THINK
TECH S. AND YOU. AND CREATING A
MECHANISM FOR SCALE THE PRO AT
THE LOCAL LET. DEVELOP PLANS
FOR A PHASE THREE THAT EXPAND
SERVICES TO SERVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL POPULATIONS AND SYSTEMS
CHANGE AT ALL LEVELS WE
PROPOSED SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM THE SURPLUS OF THE
GENERAL FUND THIS YEAR. THIS
ONE TIME FUNDING WOULD SUSTAIN
THE CRT P. FOUR FOUR ADDITIONAL.
YEARS THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
SPONSORED BY BOTH RAMCO. AND
THE NOW SO OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER END OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS SUPPORTED BY
THE SIXTEEN MAJOR STATEWIDE
MENTAL HEALTH POLICY AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS. THE C.
R. D. P. FUNDED SOLUTIONS ARE
CREATING A NEW RESEARCH BASED
THAT ELEVATES THE ROLE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND DEFINING WHAT
WORKS BEST FOR THEM. OUR
COMMUNITIES WANT INVESTMENTS IN
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
IS COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
THESE INVESTMENTS. THE C. R. D.
P. STATEWIDE AND THIRTY FIVE
LOCAL EVALUATIONS WILL IMPACT
THE STATE AND NATIONAL
DISCOURSE ON HOW TO REDUCE
MENTAL DISPARITIES. IN BILL THE
EVIDENCE BASE FOR CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE PRACTICES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY IMPROVE LIVES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT CHILDREN
FAMILIES SENIORS FRONTLINE
WORKERS THAT WE ALL SERVE AT
SHARE THE DEVASTATING IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC PARTICULARLY ON
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH WE SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEAN IN AND
MEET THEM IN THIS MOMENT TO
ENSURE THAT ASK OUR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS LEAD US FORWARD. IN THE
RECOVERY WE RECIPROCATE WITH
THE CULTURALLY AFFIRMATIVE
SERVICES THAT MEET THEIR NEEDS
JOIN US IN MOVING OUR
COMMUNITIES PASSED THE PILOTING
PHASE AND LEVERAGE THE CRT P.
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO AMPLIFY THE
LESSONS LEARNED SCALE THE
SOLUTIONS AND ACCELERATE THE
RECOVERY WE HAVE SOLUTIONS BUT
WE DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE THE
SOLUTIONS TO SCALE. AND THAT IS
WHERE WE TRUST THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE SO URGENTLY
NEEDED. PLEASE INVEST IN THE
STRATEGIES THAT WORK FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BUT ANY ANY
INPUT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. A NOTHING AND THIS
TIME VENTURE AT. EJECUTIVAS
FINANCE THANKS JACK. OF THE L.
A. L. I MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- AND SEND YOU A PIC
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND- I JUST HAVE ONE
SORT OF INFORMATIONAL POINTS TO
RAISE ONLY BECAUSE IT WAS NOT
AND IT WAS NOT YET DISCUSSED IT
AT- DURING THIS ISSUE TODAY
AND- THAT IS RELATED TO THE
VARIOUS- ACTIVITIES AND EFFORTS
OVER THE COMING YEAR I WANTED
TO MENTION THE FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WILL BECOME AVAILABLE. TO
THE STATE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTIVITIES FROM THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT THAT WAS
RECENTLY PASSED- AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT IN ADDITION OUR
OFFICE WILL BE PUBLISHING A
POST IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS-
HIGHLIGHTING THE HEALTH RELATED
PROVISIONS OF THE ACT SO- I
WON'T GET INTO IT TOO ALL OF
THE SPECIFIC AMOUNTS BUT I JUST
MENTION THAT IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE A. R. P. ACT
INCLUDES NEARLY SIXTY SEVEN
BILLION FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTIVITIES AT THE FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL LEVELS WITH SEPARATE
POTS OF FUNDING FOR TESTING
CONTACT TRACING BLACK CAPACITY
AND RELATED ACTIVITIES ABOUT
GOOD FOR GENOMICS SEQUENCING
ABOUT GOOD FOR VACCINE RELATED
ACTIVITIES AND THEN A SEPARATE
BUCKET FOR SUPPORTING AND
SUSTAINING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MUCH FUNDING WILL
COME TO CALIFORNIA- WE DO KNOW
THAT THUS FAR THE STATE IS SET
TO RECEIVE- AT LEAST ONE POINT
TWO SIX BILLION AND L. A.
COUNTY WILL RECEIVE- ITS OWN
DIRECTOR LOCATIONS OF AT LEAST
A THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
MILLION- SOME OF THIS FUNDING
IS FOR ACTIVITIES TO SUPPORT
SCHOOL PUBLIC HEALTH ACTIVITIES
SPECIFICALLY. TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
RE OPENING- THE STATE WILL ALSO
SOME THE FUNDS FOR TO SUPPORT
GENOMIC SEQUENCE SEQUENCING-
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION FOR VACCINE RELATED
ACTIVITIES. AND THEN I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THE STATE
WILL ALSO RECEIVE ARE
PRESUMABLY WILL RECEIVE SOME
AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO SUPPORT
AND SUSTAIN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE WHICH HAS- ARE A BEEN
AN ISSUE THAT'S- BEEN BROUGHT
UP IN A NUMBER OF. BY A NUMBER
OF THE SPEAKERS TODAY- WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT- ONE CHALLENGE
WITH THIS FUNDING IS THAT IT'S
ONE TIME IN NATURE. AND SO EVEN
THOUGH THE ALLOWABLE EXPENSES
INCLUDE SPENDING ON WAGES AND
BENEFITS- THE FUNDING CAN ALSO
BE USED ON GP DATA MNAGEMENT
AND I. T. SO THERE WILL JUST.
YOU KNOW. JUST TAKE CONSIDER
WHEN DECIDING HOW TO SPEND THIS
FUNDING- THAT IT IS ONE TIME IN
NATURE AND- THE LEGISLATURE
MAYBE WE SHOULD CONSIDER HOW TO
LEVERAGE THAT FUNDING- MOVING
FORWARD AND GIVEN THAT. IT
WILL. EXPIRE SO THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BE LOOKING LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING MORE ABOUT THAT- IF
I COULD SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE PRESENTATIONS AND THANK
YOU TO THE PANELISTS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE FOR. YOUR
TIRELESS WORK. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND ALL THE TIME I
PUBLIC. EVERYBODY KNOWS NOW HOW
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH IS-
DURING THE PANDEMIC I WAS
MOSTLY DEALING WITH I JUST HAD
A SINGLE COUNTY AT THAT TIME
BUT I BUT I KNOW ISSUES AROUND
CAL READY AND DATA ENTRY AND
COMMUNICATION. ALL OF THOSE
THINGS OF COURSE. WERE WERE
VERY DIFFICULT TO GET THROUGH
THEM BUT I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT. OUR OUR VACCINE
RATES GOING DOWN. AND ALSO IT'S
JUST SOME OF THE- THE STRESS
AND TENSION I THINK THAT WAS
CREATED. BY NOT HAVING FULLY
FUNDED PUBLIC HEALTH AND JUST
THE DIVISION THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING THEN. BUT THIS
IDEA AROUND MESSAGING I IS AND
IMPORTANT AND I'M ONE. I DON'T
KNOW FROM THE LOW BUT ALL FROM
THE STATE LEVEL HOW ARE WE-
HOWEVER WE USE EVERYTHING THAT
WE'VE- AND WE'RE THINKING.
MESSAGE AND FOR. TO LIKE THAT I
MEAN I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
THE- AT T. IT WAS A HOT MESS.
WE DID THE BEST WE COULD SOME
OF THE BEING FAXED AND HAND
WRITTEN AND- EVERYTHING WE CAN
WE'LL DO BETTER ON THAT BUT
THIS IDEA OF MESSAGING I THINK
IS SO IMPORTANT- COMING OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC RIGHT NOW CAN CAN
SIMPLY SPEAK TO MIL ROUTE
MESSAGING ON WHAT THE PLAN IS
FOR THAT GOING FORWARD JUST IN
IN GETTING VACCINATED BUT EVEN
THEN FURTHER THAT JUST IT
WOULDN'T GET BACK TO TALKING
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH IN A WAY
THAT- MOST AMERICANS CAN HEAR.
AND WHAT'S THAT GOING TO COST.
DURING THE FINALE MIGHT HAVE TO
COME BACK TO YOU. WHO ARE SO I
CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SOME OF THE EFFORTS UNDERWAY WE
HAVE OUR VACINE ALL FIFTY
EIGHT CAMPAIGN. I'M I THINK
THERE WAS A AND AN INITIAL TIME
INVESTMENT OF ABOUT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS I'M AND WE ARE
AND THIS MONTH. REALLY FOCUSING
ON YOUTH AFRICAN AMERICAN LATIN
POPULATIONS TO REALLY GET A LOT
OF MESSAGING OUT AND HOSTING A
NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES THIS MONTH
TO TRY TO- REALLY ADDRESS THE
VACCINE HESITANCY TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT THE
VACCINE IS SAFE. I'M AND YOU
REALLY WORK WITH NOT ONLY-
BESTEHT AND CAMPAIGNS BUT TO
WORK WITH A TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AND TO ENGAGE CPOS IN THIS WORK
THEY'VE BEEN I'M- THERE WAS
FUNDING FOR BRINGING ON CBO'S
AS WE ARE DOING TESTING AND
OTHER THINGS WE RE DIRECTED
SOME OF THOSE SAME. I'M PEOPLE
ARE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
ADDRESS VACCINE HESITANCY TO
ADDRESS OUTRAGE AND SO A NUMBER
OF EFFORTS UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW
WE ARE ON THE GROUND IN SEVERAL
COUNTIES. REALLY LOOKING OUT
VACCINE HESITANCY FROM OUT SORT
OF COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF WHERE
WE ARE LOOKING AT WHERE WE CAN
STAGE THE- I SPENT OF AND
VACCINE. AND LOCATIONS WITH
SURROUNDING THAT WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OUTREACH TO
DRUM UP DEMAND IN THOSE AREAS
AND THEN FOLLOW THAT. WITH
ONGOING MESSAGING AROUND SAFETY
AND VACCINE- CONCERNS SO THAT
WE GET TO PEOPLE WITH EASY TO
EASY TO GET VACCINATED. ALSO
THE EDUCATION A MESSAGING AND
TRUSTED MESSENGERS AND SO I
THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS UNDER WAY I KNOW THERE
ARE ALSO SOME OF OUR LOCALS WHO
MAY WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THEIR INNOVATIVE IDEAS FOR
MESSAGING- FOR. PARTNERSHIPS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL- ONE THAT WE
HEARD ABOUT TODAY CAME FROM SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY WHICH THEY'RE
PUTTING IN PLACE TOMORROW
CALLED FIRE AND ICE. THEY'RE
USING FIREMEN AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ALONG WITH ICE CREAM
TRUCKS YOU TRY TO GET SOME
INTEREST IN GETTING VACCINATED
AND REALLY LOOKING AT WAYS THAT
THAT CAN COME ON BOARD WE HAVE
SOME EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT THE
NATION IN NEW JERSEY OF ALL
PLACES WHICH IS WHERE I WAS
BORN. THEY'LL BRING UP THEIR
EXAMPLE THEY HAVE- SHOTS AND
BEERS AND ALL OF THEIR
BREWERIES ARE OFFERING- IN A
VACCINE WITH. A FREE BEER IF
YOU GET VACCINATED DID TO TRY
AND ATTRACT SOME OF THE YOUNGER
POPULATION AND SO WE'RE SEEING
SOME VERY INNOVATIVE IDEAS
PARTNERSHIPS WITH HEALTH CARE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CBO'S RIGHT
SOME PEOPLE CALLING IT THE TRIO
WHERE YOU'VE GOT. A CBO-
PROVIDER AND MAYBE I HAVE MY
CAL BACKS IMPROVED PROVIDER AND
SOME CLINICAL STAFF TOGETHER TO
REALLY LOOK AT DIFFERENT WAYS
OF BRINGING VACCINATIONS IN TWO
COMMUNITIES AND WE KNOW IF
WE'RE GOING TO HIT THE KEY ONE
POPULATION. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO BE TARGETED AND FOCUSED AND
DO IT IN WAYS THAT REALLY
INVITE PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED.
WHO MIGHT HAVE DISTRUST IN THIS.
MICHELLE GIVE FROM ENJOY OKAY
HANDS UP TO TALK ABOUT LOCAL
EFFORTS OKAY. THE AREA OKAY
TALK TO BE. YEAH SURE I WAS
TALKING ABOUT- RPI OR PUBLIC
INFORMATION PERSON AND WE
REALLY NEED- A DEDICATED PERSON
THIS IS A THERE'S A SCIENCE TO
COMMUNICATION IS A SKILL TO
HAVE AND IT'S ONE OF THOSE
FOUNDATIONAL CAPABILITIES THAT
THAT WAS FINALLY HAVE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER THAT ALL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN YEAH THERE ISN'T A
DEDICATED FUNDING STREAM FOR IT
DOESN'T FIT INTO REALLY THOSE
SILENT FINDINGS AND SO. IT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MANY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS DIDN'T POP
IN PLACE- WE HAD ABOUT FIVE
PEOPLE TRYING TO FILL THAT
FUNCTION BUT YOU DON'T REALLY
DEVELOP GOOD SKILLS THAT THAT I
HAVE TO SAY IF IT'S A FUNCTION
DON'T BY FIVE PEOPLE SO. I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
FOUNDATIONAL- STAFF. THAT WE
WOULD WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
FUNDING TO KEEP ON GOING- SO
THERE'S THAT. OF THE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS DEVELOPING THAT
PARTNERING WITH A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OUR SCHOOLS
AND OTHERS TO DO THAT- AND THEN
THINKING ABOUT HOW- JUST
TALKING ABOUT. GETTING VACCINES
OUT AND- IT MESSAGING ABOUT IT
AND ANOTHER THING THAT I THINK
WE STOLEN FROM MADERA COUNTY IS
GOING INTO SCHOOLS AND WE HAVE
HEALTH PLANS- FUNDING- MONEY SO
YOU. YOU YOU COME AND GET YOUR
VACCINE AS A STUDENT AND YOU
COULDN'T. TELL- DESIGNATE A
APPROVED COLLECTIVITY TO
RECEIVE A DOLLAR THAT'S COMING
FOR THE HEALTH PLAN SO IT'S A
WAY TO FUNDRAISE FOR YOUR YOUR
SPORTS TEAM FOR EUROPE. LATIN
CLUB WHATEVER YOU HAVE. AND GET
VACCINE AND BRING IN YOUR
FAMILY AND YOU KNOW YOU CAN
JUST KEEP MULTIPLYING THE
FUNDING SO. TRYING TO FIND
UNIQUE WAYS TO GO INTO OUR MOST
H. BACK PORCH ON ONE SCHOOLS
AND- AND HELP THEM RAISE MONEY
FOR THEIR ACTIVITIES AS WELL
SO. LOOKING AT SOME INTERESTING
WAYS I LIKE THE ASKING TO-
ANYWAY LET TO TRY TO PROMOTE.
AND COMMUNICATE. AND ENSURE
ACCESSION. THANK YOU AS WAS
GIVEN TO THE GOD AND UP AS WELL.
YES THEY YOU- I WOULD JUST ADD.
ECHO MUCH OF WHAT ADD DOCTOR VS.
ONLY A COUPLE THINGS THAT I
WOULD OUT AS YOU KNOW THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE OFTEN
HAS TRUSTED RELATIONSHIPS OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND AS FOR
TURNING THE CORNER INTO THE
HARDER TO REACH POPULATIONS AS
WELL THOSE THAT. HAVE A BIT
MORE HESITANCY AND GOING OUT
INTO THOSE COMMUNITIES IT'S
BEEN THE TOP OF OUR DISCUSSIONS
IN GOING IN AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE GOING INTO WHERE
THEY ARE VERSUS TRYING TO DRAW
THEM INTO THE MASS BACKSIDES
AND SO. JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE WHETHER THAT'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS ARE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES AND OTHERS
THAT HAVE THOSE TRUSTED
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WILL BE
THOSE TRUSTED MESSENGERS IN THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL- AND THEN TWO
OTHER AREAS OUTSIDE OF VACCINE
MESSAGING THAT I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AS- I THINK
THERE'S GOING TO NEED TO BE-
SOME. SOME BROAD MESSAGING
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE AGING
WORKFORCE AND AS YOU HEARD
FROM- THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
AND PARTICIPANTS THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE KIND OF LEFT
PUBLIC HEALTH DURING THIS TIME
REALLY WERE EARLY RETIREMENTS
AND SO FORTH AND SO WE WILL
NEED TO HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE CAMPAIGN TO DRIVE
INTEREST INTO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. AND THEN LASTLY I
THINK AND- DURING THE PANDEMIC
FOLKS KNOW WHO PUBLIC HEALTH IS
THAT OFTEN BECAUSE OF RULES AND
REQUIREMENTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT WERE DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC- I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CHANGE THAT
NARRATIVE AND SHOW ALL OF THE
OTHER AREAS IN WHICH PUBLIC
HEALTH HELPS TO BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES AND NOT JUST THAT.
THE RULES IN THE ENFORCEMENT
SIDE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND SO I
THINK THERE COULD BE BETTER
MESSAGING THERE SO THAT FOLKS
REALLY UNDERSTAND AND VALUE
PUBLIC HEALTH IN THE FUTURE. I
THOUGHT MR DELA. CRUZ DID A
LOVELY JOB OF TALKING ABOUT
THAT- ICE- MS. HOSTED FOR. AUTO
MANUFACTURER AND- THANK YOU
MUCH- YES I JUST WANTED TO
REALLY LEAN INTO THE POINT
AROUND THE TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
RELATIONSHIPS IF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FAMILIES AND
YOUNG PEOPLE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE WHAT PEOPLE
LEAN INTO AND SO TO BE
STRATEGICALLY POSITIONED IN
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE THOSE INTER
GENERATIONAL AND HISTORIC
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE REALLY MADE
THE DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF
REACHING IS HARD- HARD TO REACH
POPULATIONS. OUR ORGANIZATION-
AS PART OF OUR- CRT P. WORK-
HAS MADE OVER THREE THOUSAND
PHONE CALLS TO FAMILIES AROUND
THE VACCINATIONS AND HELP TO
SCHEDULE OVER NINE HUNDRED
APPOINTMENTS AND THAT'S WHAT WE
FOUND IT REALLY TAKES IN ORDER
TO MAKE THAT CONNECTION BECAUSE
OF FAMILIES ARE NOT ABLE TO
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE EVEN
WITH THEIR CELL PHONES TO MAKE
THE VACCINATION APPOINTMENTS
THEY NEED THAT WARM HAND OFF
AND THEY'LL ONLY ACCEPT THE
WARM HAND OFF IF THEY ARE HAVE
TRUST. IN THE MESSENGER SO JUST
WANTED TO STRESS THAT AND ALSO
THAT IN TERMS OF LANGUAGE WE
ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
THE INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS-
THAT ARE HERE AND IT FOR
EXAMPLE IN MY IN POPULATIONS
WHO DO NOT HAVE A WRITTEN
LANGUAGE AND SO YOU NEED TO
HAVE AGAIN THE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT MESSENGERS THAT
REPRESENT THOSE COMMUNITIES IN
ORDER TO BE EFFECTIVE. IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH HEALTH BROWN AND
SPECIFICALLY AROUND
VACCINATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THEM BACK TO MS GIVENS
POINT TO ABOUT TO- MESSAGING
ABOUT WORKFORCE WE'RE GONNA
NEED A LOT OF OUR- FOLKS COMING
FROM ARE MORE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES WITH FOR TRUSTED
MESSENGERS I KNOW JUST. EVERY
TIME I READ THE PAPER I SEE ONE
MORE OF OUR BLACK SENIORS WHO
WHO HAVES SUCCUMB TO THIS WAR-
UNIT IN MY IN MY WORK IN THE
LATINO COMMUNITY I KNOW THAT
THE A LOT OF THE OUTRAGE WE DO
IS- IS SO INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
BUT IT'S SO VALUED ONE WHEN
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY REACHED AND
THEN JUST TODAY WITH THE BITS
BIG MACS. VAST MAX BACKS AND
ASIAN SITE AND ARE ARENA. WE
HAD TROUBLE WITH OUR API
COMMUNITY WITH- MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. ON THAT PEOPLE
NEEDED AND IN TRANSPORTATION
WAS ALSO ANOTHER ISSUE BECAUSE
IT'S CLEAR ACROSS TOWN. SO I
GUESS MY FINAL QUESTION I KNOW
DOCTOR PAN IS EAGER TO GET IN
HERE IS JUST AROUND. AND AS YOU
KNOW THE SENATE HAS REALLY
PRIORITIZE PUBLIC HEALTH IN OUR
BUILD BACK BOLDLY AND WILL BE
MAKING VERY BIG INVESTMENTS-
FOR THE SHORT TERM AND THE LONG
TERM. BUT I GUESS WHEN WE'RE
JUST TALKING ABOUT OUR WORK
FORCE- IT IS IT. AND I KNOW
WE'VE LOST ENOUGH AND I KNOW
IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLY STRESSFUL
HAVE WE LOST LIKE TO I WE DO WE
NEED TO DOUBLE IT DO WE NEED TO
TRIPLE IT WHAT ARE WE- WHAT ARE
SOME KIND OF PROJECTIONS- ONLY
TALK ABOUT. INCREASING STAFF
BOTH AT THE STATE AND THE- AND
THE COUNTY LEVELS. I DON'T KNOW
THE STARTER FINALE- REFUSE
FINALE OR- ON THE OTHER
PANELIST. HEY THIS IS MICHELLE
GIBBONS AGAIN I WOULD JUST
MAYBE START OFF THE
CONVERSATION BY GIVING YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND THEY HAD SAID THAT
THEY HVE HAD DOUBLE NEARLY
TRIPLE THE SIZE OF THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT DURING THE
PANDEMIC SO THAT JUST GOES TO
SHOW KIND OF WHERE THE DEFICITS
WERE- ALSO AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WORK FORCES DECLINE BY
ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. I'M OVER THE PAST
DECADES AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT TO THINK
THROUGH THAT. PART OF THE
REASON WHY WE REALLY NEED THE
ASSESSMENT. IS TO REALLY. AND
WHAT THE ADEQUATE LEVELS OF
WORKFORCE THE TO BE FOR OUR
STATE BUT ONE THING THAT I CAN
SAY IS WE WILL BE. IN AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THERE WILL
BE THAT THE TWO COMPETING
ISSUES ONE IS THAT WE NEED
ONGOING FUNDING IN ORDER TO
BOLSTER AND GROW THAT WORK
FORCE THE OTHER IS THAT WE WILL
BE BACK FILLING POSITIONS THAT
WE- WE HAVE CURRENTLY- BECAUSE
OF THOSE EARLY RETIREMENTS ARE
MOVING ON AND SO. I'M I THINK I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THOSE
TWO CHALLENGES FOR YOU AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE
RE DIRECTED SO MANY STAFF THAT
PART OF HOW WE'RE USING THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS IS TO ALLOW
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE TO BE
DIRECTED BACK TO THEIR NORMAL
WORK. ON SAID WE'VE INCREASED
OUR STAFFING POSSIBLY RE DIRECT.
IT NEARLY HALF OF OUR STAFF OF
THE DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY THIRTY PM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
OF FIRST OF ALL IT'S ONCE
AGAIN- I KNOW THAT- I THINK- MR
DELA CRUZ FROM S. YEAH YOU-
BRIEFLY MENTIONED IN HIS
REMARKS BUT- I WANT TO FIRST OF
ALL THANK ALL THE PEOPLE WERE
ON THE FRONT LINES AND PUBLIC
HEALTH I KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE IN DOING
YOUR WORK AND DOING YOUR JOB
AND PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO HATE AND
PERSONAL ATTACKS. WE SEEN THIS
WITH- HEALTH OFFICERS IN FACT
JUST COUPLE DAYS AGO AND OF
HAVING TO RELEASE A STATEMENT
WHERE A PUBLIC LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER UP IN YUBA
SUTTER ACTUALLY THAT I COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICER WAS USING DEATH
THREATS FOR MONTHS- AND IS NOW
HAVE TO HAS HAS ARMED GUARDS-
BECAUSE OF THAT- BUT THAT GOAL
DIFFERENT LOOK OUT LEVELS- THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS HAVE
BEEN. UNFORTUNATELY SUBJECT TO-
PERSONAL AND THREATS AND I KNOW
THERE WAS ENVIRONMENTAL OFFICER
WHO WAS STABBED AND DIE I THINK.
AS WELL THE PAST YEAR- IT I
JUST THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE FRONT LINES AND
FRANKLY THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
THAT THE THAT PEOPLE CALLING
FOR THESE. TYPES THE BROTHER
TERRASSE MEANT OR ACTUAL
ATTACKS ON ON PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES. SO
I JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT-
BECAUSE OF. QUESTION I GUESS IS
FOR- L. A- YOU YOU MENTIONED SO
THEY- RESCUE PLAN JUST TO BE
CLEAR IN TERMS OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING SO WE'RE ALL SAYING
LOOK AT ALL THIS FEDERAL MONEY
IT'S- IT THIS IS. TEMPORARY
MONEY RIGHT IT'S ALL IS IT ONLY
FOR A YEAR HOW LONG IS HOW HOW
LONG DO WE GET THE MONEY FOR-
THE STATIC. THANK YOU SENATOR
SOME OF THE FUNDING SOME OF THE
PARAMETERS AROUND THE FUNDING-
JUST. YEAH HAVE BEEN RELEASED
YEAH SO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MIGHT POSSIBLY HAVE MORE
DETAILS BUT- YEAH WE'RE STILL
WAITING WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
YOU KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S ONE
TIME IN NATURE OKAY YOU CAN
FINANCE SPEAK TO THIS I MEAN
HOW I KNOW IT'S ONE TIME HOW
LONG THE ONLY TALK ABOUT ONE
TIME A YEAR AT IT AND REALIZE
THAT MAYBE DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
BUT PARTICULARLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH PORTIONS OF THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN. I CERVANTES GENTLE
FINANCE- THE VARIOUS RANGES-
THE VARIOUS POCKETS OF FINDING
AN AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ARE
TYPICALLY AVAILABLE FOR
ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO FOUR
YEARS- IT WOULD HAVE TO HAVE TO.
HOW TO DRILL INTO THE
INDIVIDUAL PIECES OF THE ACT TO
GIVE YOU A CLEAR ANSWER ON EACH
ONE BUT- MOST OF THEM ARE
AVAILABLE OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS OKAY SO WELL YOU'RE
TALKING TWO TO FOUR YEARS- AND
ESPECIALLY AGAIN THE FOCUS HERE
I THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT
BUILDING A PUBLIC HEALTH
CAPACITY- I MEAN IT'S HARD TO
HIRE SOMEONE UNTIL SOMEONE BY
THE WAY I HAVE. TWO YEARS OF
FUNDING AND WERE HOPING YEARS
JOB WILL STILL BE THERE SO- SO
I THINK PART OF OUR JOB HERE IS
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO BUILD OUT YOU KNOW NOT BOTH
NOW IN THE OUT YEARS AS WELL-
FOR SUSTAINING THESE POSITIONS-
NEXT. QUESTION I HAVE ACTUALLY
IS- ACTUALLY FOR- CD P. H. I
KNOW THAT WE TALKED ABOUT YOU
KNOW HE DOES BASICALLY THE
VACCINATION EFFORTS AND- THE
COVERT EFFORTS AND SO FORTH.
AND BASICALLY AND I HEARD THAT
US A LOT OF HEALTH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SENT TO BECOME
COVERT DEPARTMENTS BUT I WANT
TO MAKE NOTE THAT FOR EXAMPLE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN BEFORE
CODED- WE HAD. THE MEASLES
OUTBREAK THAT HAPPENED HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
ACTUALLY THANKS TO PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION IT WASN'T AS BAD
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WAS IN
OTHER STATES. HE MAY BE TO THE
WHAT DEGREE BOTH IN AND PERHAPS
MAYBE MS GIVENS ME. MITCHELL
GIVENS MAY SPEAK TO THIS TO
WHAT DEGREE DO WE ACTUALLY TO
SHIFT PEOPLE SO THAT OF COURSE
COVERED WOULD TALK ABOUT OKAY
YOU KNOW LAST A HUNDRED. YEARS
AGO YOU KNOW THAT THE BIGGEST
WANTED CENTER AND OBVIOUSLY
REALLY BIG. BUT EVEN WITH THAT
THAT MEASLES OUTBREAK WE HAD IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. TO WHAT DEGREE
DID THAT IMPACT PUBLIC HEALTH.
DEPARTMENTS BOTH STATE AND
LOCAL IN TERMS OF HAVING SHIFT
PERSONNEL. I THINK EVERY LARGE
OUTBREAK REQUIRES THAT WE SHIFT
PERSONNEL BOTH AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL FROM OTHER
INFECTIOUS DISEASES TO DEAL
WITH THE OUTBREAK. I THINK IT
VARIES BY THE IMPACT- ON. IN
EACH COUNTY. BUT I KNOW THAT IN
THE STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT WE
RE DIRECT MANY PEOPLE FOR EACH
OF THOSE OUTBREAKS FOR THE
MEASLES FOR THE HEPATITIS.
pSEEN RATHER MULTI COUNTY IN THE
STATE NEEDS TO STEP IN. OKAY SO
AND SO I THINK CERTAINLY AND-
AND PERHAPS AND IT- THAT WE GOT
THINK ABOUT THIS ONGOING SURGE
CAPACITY RIGHT- IN TERMS OF- BE
SURE WE HAVE THE SURGE
CAPACITY- IT. IN TERMS OF RIGHT
IT IN SPITE T. CAPACITY WE
HEARD ABOUT WITH CODED FOR
EXAMPLE- I KNOW THAT- THE GOOD
HEALTH OFF FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY TALK ABOUT HOW JUST.
JUST TOTALLY OVERWHELMED I MEAN
AND I'VE HEARD STORIES ABOUT
ESSENTIALLY PEOPLE TRYING TO
SEND DATA BY FAX MACHINE HE-
AND THEN HAVING TO BUY A SHE
WASN'T SIXTY MINUTES HE TALKED
ABOUT HOW THE BIO HAVE
ACTUALLY. BOUGHT TWO FAX
MACHINES IT TO COMMUNICATE WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- SO-
CAN WE SPEAK TO THE STATE. OF
OUR IT INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ACTUALLY SERVED UP EVEN IF. AND
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WE RAN
INTO THIS WITH SOME OF THESE
OTHER OUTBREAKS BUT- IS THERE A
STATE I MEAN THIS IS WHAT. IS
YOUR STATEWIDE I. T. ASSESSMENT
SO AND I KNOW WE NEED STAFF TO
AND THAT'S ALSO YOU COULD
EASILY IGNITE MORE IMPORTANT
BUT- IN TERMS OF OUR IT
CAPACITY IN PUBLIC HEALTH AS A
WHOLE NETWORKS OF MILLER TO
HAVE CD PH YOU HAVE. COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND THEN IT
NEEDS INTERFACE OF HOSPITALS
LABS AND OTHERS HEALTHCARE
ENTITIES AS WELL- HAS SOMEONE
DONE A IN I. T. ASSESSMENT FOR.
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH I MEAN OF
COURSE I'M SURE WE JUST NOW
BUILT UP SOME SYSTEMS RECOVERED
AND SO FORTH- IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY- YOU KNOW WE HAD
REPLACED CAL READY BUT REALLY
THINKING SYSTEMATICALLY. ABOUT
THE IT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CERTAINLY I'VE BEEN TAUGHT- IF
YOU LOOK AT THIS IS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA AS THE FOUNDATION
FOR ALL PUBLIC HEALTH SO WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD ARTISTE
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN'T REALLY DO
OUR JOBS. SO CAN WE SEE THIS
ONCE THE LAST TIME THE
DEPARTMENT- YOUNG STATE
GOVERNMENT'S DONE AND I. T. THE
TOTAL I. T. EVALUATION FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH SO IT'S NOT JUST
STATE. YOU KNOW C. P. H. I. T.
SYSTEM IT'S REALLY UP AND DOWN
YOU KNOW ENTER HOW INTERFACES
THE COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
HOW COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT'S
HOW INTERFACES THE STATE HOW
THE INTERFACE OF LAUGHTER
UNIFIED WITH. HOSPITALS OTHER
PROVIDERS OR HAVING TO REPORT
DATA AND OF COURSE IT'S NOT
JUST CONTAGIOUS DISEASES. OVER
TALK ABOUT EQUITY AND OTHERS
OTHER THINGS. BUT WHAT WHAT HAS
IT EVER BEEN DONE OUR WINS LAST
TIME THAT'S BEEN EVALUATED. M.
I CAN TELL YOU THE LAST TIME
BUT I CAN TELL YOU WERE OVERDUE
I THINK WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
INDIVIDUAL SYSTEMS AS WE LOOKED
AT THE COW READY SYSTEM AS WE
LOOK AT CARE AS WE LOOKED AT
GROWING HOW CAN ACT I THINK THE
WAY THAT WE ARE DEVELOPING
SYSTEMS. LEND THEMSELVES TO
USING SIMILAR PAP PLATFORMS AND
BRINGING THEM TOGETHER WE HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO TO CONNECT ALL
OF THE LECTERN OF HEALTH
RECORDS- I THINK WE'RE MOVING
DOWN THAT PATH BUT I THINK THAT
ONE THAT YOU KNOW AS WE'RE
INVESTING SOME OF THESE FEDERAL
DOLLARS WERE CERTAINLY LOOKING
AT THAT OVER ARCHING ISSUE.
THAT WE HAVE EVERY STATE I
PLEASE ALLOW LOOKING LOOKING IS
THERE IS SO JUST THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION THEN- WHEN CAN WE
EXPECT IN I. T. PLANNED FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND I KNOW THAT
FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S EVEN
LEGISLATION GOING THROUGH NOW
ABOUT REGIONAL HEALTH EXCHANGES
AND SO FORTH. THAT AND KNOWING
THAT YOU HAVE TO INTERFACE NOT
ONLY WITHIN BUT ALSO SO- IS
WITH HIM ON SOCIAL SERVICES
THERE'S A LARGE IT PROJECT
GOING THROUGH WITH THE STATE
THE SSS AND COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE DEPARTMENT AT CETERA
PRAYER WILL BE DONE UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. WHEN CAN WE
EXPECT A PLAN FROM CDPH AND
VARIOUS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS FOR
AN IT INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I AM I WILL GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT I CAN'T
COMMIT TO A DAY OR TIME TODAY
BUT I KNOW THAT IT IS A
PRIORITY FOR OUR DEPARTMENT AND
WE'LL GET OUR I. T. INTERNET
AGENTS WORKS TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE KNOW HOW I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE A PROPOSAL
AND IT CAN BE TOTALLY FUNDED
FROM THE FEDS. MORE POWER TO
YOU- BUT IF YOU NEED STATE
MONEY THEN WE SHOULD BE HAVING
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT OKAY.
AND THEN- ALL RIGHT AND THEN IT
AND I SAID THIS IS NOT JUST FOR
CD PH THIS IS THIS IS TOP YOU
KNOW TOP THROUGH BUT YOU DON'T
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE A LOT
ABOUT CONNECTING HEALTH CARE
AND HEALTH CARE SURGEON AND A
LOT OF THE OTHER PIECES THAT WE
NEED TO CONTACT. RESPOND TO
SOMETHING OF THIS MAGNITUDE BUT
ALSO THE RIPPLE RESPONDED FIRES
AND OTHER EVENTS THAT HAPPEN
EVERY YEAR RIGHT AND THEN WE
HAVE CHRONIC CONDITIONS AND
ELSEWHERE YES VALLEY FEVER WE
HAVE. LOTS OF THINGS GOING ON
AND WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY RIGHT
SO WE NEED TO HAVE OKAY- AND
THEN THE OTHER PART IS I JUST
ON THE STAFFING LEVEL- AND I
KNOW THERE'S VARIOUS PROPOSAL
OUT THERE- BUT- SHOULDN'T HAVE
SO YOU KNOW AND- YES WE HAD
ESSENTIALLY. WE HAVE A CERTAIN
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE A SYSTEM
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM RIGHT. SO WE
HAVE FIRE DEPARTMENTS- YES
PROVIDES THEM WITH FIRE TRUCKS
AND OTHER TYPES OF EQUIPMENT
AND THEN WHEN THERE'S OF
WILDFIRE AND YES THERE'S BEEN
TIMES THEY'VE BEEN OVERRUN
BLENDER SO MANY WILDFIRES BUT-
HAVE WE THOUGHT ABOUT
ESSENTIALLY A KIND OF MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM FUNDED BY THE STATE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH WHERE WE
ACTUALLY PAY FOR IT WOULD NOT
FIRE TRUCKS BUT MAYBE STE.
PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF WILL BE
STATIONED AT LOCAL YOU KNOW AND
ACTUALLY IMPRESSED PAID FOR BY
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS OR
CITY HEALTH DEPARTMENT THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS BUT-
COULD BE MOBILIZED ONE HAVE
BASIC SKILL SETS THAT COULD BE
MOBILIZED TO HANDLE OUTBREAKS-
SAYS- SO THAT- WE WOULD BE SO
WE HAVE. THAT IN PLACE A MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM HAS BEEN DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THAT FOR IS A WAY TO IS
THIS ONE AT LEAST. ONE ELEMENT
OF THE WORK FORCE APPROACH. WE
ARE USING SOME OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS LOOK AT OF LIKE A- HOW.
CORPS AND LOOKING AT WAYS TO
BUILD UP SOME OF THOSE STAFF
AND PLACING THEM AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO WE ARE. DOING
SOME OF THAT WE HAVE- YOU CDC
STAFF IN THAT SAME WAY-
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC. I
WILL SAY THAT YOU KNOW OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS. DO YOU HAVE A
PRETTY ROBUST MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
WHEN EMERGENCIES HIT. WHERE
THEY DO RESPOND TO ONE ANOTHER
AND PUT SOME OF THEIR- HAPPY
STAFF SOME OF THEIR RESPONSE
STAFF IN- ONE. AND YOU KNOW
FROM ONE JURISDICTION INTO AN
IMPACTED JURISDICTION BUT I
THINK. THAT IS MORE BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
RESPONSE IT DOES IMPACT BOTH OF
THOSE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
TERMS OF- LETTING SOME OF THEIR
STAFF AND- SO. WE DEFINITELY
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR THAT SO
I HOPE I HOPE THERE CAN BE SOME
WORK. DONE ON THAT AND I
REALIZE THAT FIRST OF ALL- I
KNOW THAT. PUBLIC HEALTH
COOPERATIVES THE OTHER PART IS
BECAUSE WE ARE EVERYONE SO
SHORT STAFFED. I DON'T THINK
IT. THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
PEOPLE HAVE TO DO THAT AS WELL
BUT LET'S THINK ABOUT DOING IN
A WAY THAT ACTUALLY IS IT JUST
BECAUSE WE'RE SHORT STAFFED
BECAUSE WERE ADEQUATELY
STAFFED. SO SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT AND THEN FINALLY.
I IN TERMS OF LAB RESOURCES AND
I KNOW WE TALKED- TOUCHED ON.
IT A IT WAS MENTIONED THAT
MANY. REGIONAL LABS ARE CLOSED.
IS THERE IS THAT THERE IS THERE
BEEN DISCUSSIONS AT C. PH AND
REGIONALLY AND THEN MAYBE WE
CAN ALSO HAVE. THIS GIVENS
ADDRESSED THIS. AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT EIGHT YOU KNOW I KIND
OF DROPPED HER OFF BUT YOU KNOW
SOME OF THESE ITEMS AS WELL
AFTER ACKERMAN C. PH. IN TERMS
OF MAYBE A REGIONAL APPROACH TO
LAB. TWO TWO TWO LABS. BECAUSE
IT SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE. COUNTIES
AT CLOSE LABS BUT THERE'S NOT
LIKE A SYSTEMATIC PLAN. SO THEN
THE COUNTY GOES OKAY WE'LL
CLOSE OUR LAB AND THEN WE'LL
FIND SOME OTHER COUNTY LAB TO
COVER FOR US IT'S UNDER- BUT-
THAT IS THERE SOME SORT OF
PLANNING APPROACH TO LAB
CAPACITY. BEYOND YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY A STATE LAB BUT THEN
WE ALSO. YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE
SOME REMAINING COUNTY LABS. IS.
THERE REGIONAL APPROACH TO A
LAB RESOURCES. SOME NOW I THINK
WE RE EXAMINING THAT WITH OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS WERE SETTING UP
SOME PUBLIC HEALTH WORK FORCE
AND WORK GROUPS TO REALLY LOOK
AT. I'M AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE PANDEMIC AS WELL AS AND
WHAT COMES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF THE
NEED FOR. LOOKING AT WHAT.
CAPABILITY SHOULD BE REGIONAL
WHAT. CAPABILITIES SHOULD BE
STATEWIDE WHAT SHOULD BE LOCAL.
I'M AND REALLY LOOKING AT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WE'VE LEARNED A LOT.
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO MEET AND
THAT. NEED FOR NAY ABILITY TO
BRING ON NEW TASKS AND BRING
THEM ON QUICKLY AND TO YOU.
KNOW WITH HE VALENCIA LAB SORT
OF WHAT THE FUTURE OF THAT LAB
LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS OF- BOW
QUARTER PUBLIC HEALTH. CAPACITY
BUT I THINK AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S ROOM TO GROW- AND I
THINK THAT WE WOULD ALL AGREE
THAT EACH HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
HAVING THEIR OWN PUBLIC HEALTH
LAB PROBABLY. MAKES SENSE IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. BUT WHERE-
MAYBE IT JUST DOESN'T IF THE
COUNTY IS SO SMALL WHERE WE A
REGIONAL APPROACH MIGHT MAKE.
SENSE I THINK OR WHAT I'M
THINKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
REGIONAL APPROACH IS MAYBE.
SPECIALIZING SOME OF OUR LABS
TO PLAY SOME OF THE ROLES. THAT
MAYBE EVERY LAB HERE- PLAY.
THAT'S REGIONALIZATION. WELL AT
THE AT THE END LIKE IT'S A
THINK ABOUT MORE SYSTEMATICALLY
THAN JUST THE EACH COUNTY BOARD
SUPERVISORS GOING WITHIN CLOSE
OUR LAB. SO AND- HOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO ABOUT SUPPORTING
THE LABS ARE THERE SO. MAYBE
PERHAPS WE CAN NOT FOLLOW UP ON
AGAIN I TALKED ABOUT THE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE. STAFFAN LABS
PERHAPS MAYBE MICHELLE GIBBONS
AND PERHAPS ALSO CITED THAT IF
WE CAN HAVE THE HEALTH OFFICERS
DOWN THE COUNTY DR- SORRY
VISION PAN. MAYBE COMMENT ON
THOSE ITEMS AS WELL. FROM THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND THE COUNTY. I
THINK IT'S AN PAN QUESTIONS IS
USED. AND I WOULD JUST SAY
TERMS THE TWENTY NINETEEN
MEASLES OUTBREAK YOU ARE
CORRECTED THAT THERE ALWAYS HAS
TO BE A SHIFT OF. FOCUS IN A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT WHEN
THERE IS AN OUTBREAK. AND SO
MANY OF THE STAFF GET COLD FROM
OTHER ISSUES OTHER AT PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAM SO YOU CAN.
IMAGINE SOMEONE AND THAT S. TV
PROGRAMS. AND GETTING PULLED
OVER TO YOU KNOW FOCUS ON THE
MEASLES OUTBREAK IN NEW DISEASE
INVESTIGATION. THE ONE THING I
JUST WANTED TO REALLY CALL OUT
IS WHEN THEY'RE BECAUSE WE ALL
KNOW THAT FEDERAL FUNDING
USUALLY COMES DOWN FOR THE BIG
THINGS AND- AND- WIN THAT%
DISEASE OUTBREAK HAPPENS IN THE
FEDERAL FUNDS COME DOWN THEY'RE
STILL. AT A TIME LAG. IN
ADDITION WE'RE TAKING A
INDIVIDUAL FRIEND ANOTHER
PROGRAM THAT'S FEDERALLY FUNDED
POTENTIALLY OR STATE FUNDED
WITH REQUIREMENTS. THEN THAT
THEN HAVE TO BE SHIFTED OVER TO
THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT ARE
COMING DOWN THE WAY. AND SO
THAT MEANS THAT THERE MIGHT BE
A GAP IN TIME IN WHICH THAT
PERSON CANNOT ACTUALLY. MEET
THE DELIVERABLES OF THEIR
ORIGINAL PROGRAM AND THEN PUT A
FURTHER STRAIN ON THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AS WELL SO I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT
TO JUST CALL OUT. IN TERMS OF
THE DEED I FULLY AGREE WITH YOU
AND I THINK MANY OF OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS LEAD THAT WE
REALLY DO NEED TO REVISIT THE
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE AND FIGURE
OUT. A WAY TO EXPAND AND MAKE
IT MORE ROBUST. THERE WAS
NOTHING MORE CHALLENGING THAN
TRYING TO- WALK THROUGH DATA
CHALLENGES DURING THE PANDEMIC
IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
DATA WAS MATCHING AND WHERE
THERE WERE DISCREPANCIES THAT
WE WERE IDENTIFYING AND
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE ISSUES
WERE. AND INDEED IT TOOK UP A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME AND
SO WE WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
THERE- AND THE ONE THING THAT I
WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT IN THE
ASSESSMENT THAT WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD ARE PROPOSING THREE
EIGHTY TWO FORTY. YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT JUST WORKFORCE I THINK
WORKFORCE IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THAT BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO ACCESS DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED TO
ASSESS AND EVALUATE OUR-
LABORATORY CAPACITY SO I THINK
ALL OF THOSE ARE THINGS THAT.
WHILE WE SHOULD NOT WAIT TO
INVEST IN THEM NOW WE SHOULD
MAKESURE THAT WE HAVE A ROAD
MAP FOR WHAT. WE WANT
CALIFORNIA TO BE CALM AND MAKE
SURE THEY WE ARE CONTINUE. TO
MAKE. TO GET THEIR- AND THEN IN
TERMS OF THE STAFF BEING- YOU
YOU KNOW I THINK AS- MISS
FINALE ADDRESS THIS. AND YES WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE WE CAN. ACT WHERE
WE HAVE MUTUAL AID AND SO WE DO
THE MEDICAL MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
INCLUDES PUBLIC HEALTH WORK
FORCE AND I THINK THAT.
CRITICAL CHALLENGE THERE IS IF
EVERYBODY'S UNDER RESOURCE THAT
NOBODY CAN SHARE AND NOT IS
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT HAPPENS
AND SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
COULD MAKE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE LOCALLY MORE ROBUST
IN PLACE MORE PEOPLE THEY WILL
HAVE LOCAL EXPERTISE THAT THEN
COULD GO INTO ANOTHER
JURISDICTION AND SUPPORT THEM.
AND THEY ALREADY HAVE TRAINING
AND PRACTICES THERE SO INSTEAD
OF KEEPING THEM IN SOME. KIND
OF RESERVE AREA WHICH- YOU KNOW
I THINK GETTING MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE IN. THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT HELPING TO
ADDRESS THE DAY TO DAY ISSUES
AND THEN AT THE AVAILABLE FOR
MUTUAL AID IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND THEN- JUST ONE ECHO THE
LABORATORY RESOURCES I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
REVISIT WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. INVESTMENT IS UNTIL LABS
AND WHAT IT SHOULD LOOK LIKE
ACROSS THE STATE AND MANY YOU
KNOW LOOK SMALLER JURISDICTIONS
WHEN A LABORATORY CLOSED. AT
THE POOL TOGETHER A CONTRACT
WITH ONE LAB IN AND AS WE SEE
IN KOBE THEN THE LAB THAT IS
OVERSEEING. THE JURISDICTION
OVERSEAS A LOT THEY HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR SPECIMENS- IN
IN THE EVENT OF SOMETHING BIG
LIKE THIS AND THEN OTHERS ARE-
THEIR PRIORITY BUT- THERE ARE
SOME LADS THE END UP HAPPENING
AND SO WHEN THE STATE STEPPED
IN WITH THE VALENCIA BRANCH LAB
THAT WAS. REALLY HELPFUL AND I
THINK. WE SHOULD IT REALLY
REVISIT AND TRY TO BE
INNOVATIVE AND FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE LABORATORY CAPACITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND I
WOULD JUST. SORRY TO BE LONG
WINDED THE LAST THING I WOULD
JUST SAY IS. ALL OF THESE AREAS
TAKE REALLY CRITICAL AND HIGHLY
SKILLED PEOPLE SO AT AND THEN
IT CONTEXT OF LABORATORIES FOR
EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW LAB DIRECTORS
ARE NOT EASY TO COME BY AND- WE
REALLY NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A PIPELINE SO THAT WE
HAVE. THE STAFF BEING IN THE
CAPABILITIES AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE- QUALITY. SERVICES
COMING OUT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
WELL. OKAY AND THEN- APPRECIATE
THAT AND PERHAPS. WECHT PAN AND
JUST PARTICULAR FOCUS ON. THE
YOU'RE WILLINGNESS. TO AND YOUR
DEPARTMENT WHEN DOES YOUR
FELLOW HEALTH OFFICERS TO
PARTNER AND TRYING TO. DEVELOP
THESE PARTICULAR PLANS SO THAT
QUICKLY. I THINK WE KEEP ASKING
FOR PLANS AND I'VE I'VE I'VE
SERVE INDICATED HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR EVERY YEAR BUT- WE
BETTER HAVE ONE SOON SO WE CAN
START. YOU KNOW MOVING ON THEM.
THANK YOU YES THANK YOU AND I
VERY MUCH AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN SAID SO FAR SO- WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY AREN'T STAND
READY TO. HELP AND COORDINATE
AND I THINK A GOOD ASSESSMENT
IS NEEDED WE REALLY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
WHAT THE GAPS ARE IN. AND WHERE
WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE OUR OUR-
OUR INTERVENTIONS AND CHANGE
THINGS SO. JUST TO SPEAK- OF
THE LABORATORY ISSUE ENOUGH
LABORATORIES YOU THAT SECOND-
THE I. T. ISSUE REPORTS YOU
KNOW ELECTRONIC LAB REPORTS SO
NOT ALL WERE AND HOW MANY WERE
THEY BY LAW PROVIDERS ALSO HAVE
TO REPORT AND THEY DON'T REALLY
HAVE AN EASY WAY TO COURT AND
THAT WAS MOST OF THE PHONE
CALLS AND FAXES WAS PROVIDERS
REPORTING UNCOVERED NINETEEN
TESTS ESPECIALLY THE ANTIGEN
TEST THEMSELVES. I KNOW WE WERE
WORKING ON WHAT WE CALL THE
EACH CASE REPORTING SO DIRECT
MESSAGING FROM- PH OURS INTO
POWER READY AND THAT WAS MOVING
FORWARD THAT PILOT COUNTIES IT
WAS MOVING BUT THE PANDEMIC
KIND OF STOP THE MOVEMENT BUT
THAT SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
SOLUTIONS THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO IMPLEMENT TO- MORE
OPERATIONALIZE OUR DATA. AND
STREAMLINE WHAT WE'RE DOING-
FOR THE LABORATORIES AGAINST
YOU KNOW FUNDING IS ALWAYS AN
ISSUE BUT MISGIVINGS JUST
BROUGHT UP RIGHT THERE AT THE
END- WE ARE ONE OF THE COUNTIES
THE COSTAR LAB I BELIEVE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND- IT WAS
BECAUSE WE REALLY HADN'T BEEN
ABLE TO EVER RECORD A LOT
DIRECTOR I THINK WE HAVE A PART
TIME RETIRED PERSON FOR ABOUT
TEN YEARS IT WAS REALLY ALMOST
MARCH I'M SPECIALIZED STAFFING
THEN. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT SAVING
MONEY THIS WAS NOT ABOUT SAVING
MONEY IT WAS ABOUT- TRYING TO
CONSOLIDATE RESOURCES IN TRYING
TO BUILD A BETTER LIFE BETWEEN
TWO COUNTIES THAN AND THAT A
SINGLE LAP AND IT SINGLE LABS
IN BOTH COUNTIES HIMSELF REALLY
I'M LOOKING AT A REGIONAL
APPROACH IN A REGIONAL PLAN AND
FIGURING OUT WHAT THAT WHAT
WHAT IS REALLY NECESSARY IN
ENSURING THAT THE STAFF IS
AVAILABLE TO- IMPLEMENT THE
PLAN AND WE STAND READY TO HELP
ABSOLUTELY. OKAY THANK YOU AND
THEN JUST ONE LAST QUESTION-
FOR THE CD PH- WE TALK ABOUT
VACCINE OUT REACH AND I KNOW
YOU TALKED AND CERTAINLY WE
NEED TO REACH OUT TO VARIOUS
COMMITTEES COLOR WE
PARTICULARLY NEED TO PRIORITIZE
GETTING VACCINES I THINK
VACCINES ACCESS IS ALSO
CERTAINLY A HUGE ISSUE FOR. A
GAME TO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
BUT LET'S ALSO BE BLOOD. THE A
DATA RIGHT NOW SHE HAS THE
BIGGEST AREA OF THE RESERVE-
THE- HESITANCY OR ACT- WHAT
RIPPLE. MEN AND WE'RE
COMMUNITIES. SO CAN YOU SPEAK
TO WHAT'S GOING TO BE DONE TO
TRY TO ADDRESS. THOSE
PARTICULAR POPULATIONS IN TERMS
OF VACCINE HESITANCY- AND IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO GET
ORGANIZATION RATES UP. I THINK
WE ARE TRYING TO FIND THE RIGHT
TRUSTED MESSENGERS AND DOING
SOME WORK ON WITHOUT REPUBLICAN
PARTY WITH OTHERS THAT- TO OUR
ADMINISTRATION AND THROUGH OUR
VACCINATE ALL FIFTY EIGHT
CAMPAIGN. I AM I THINK IT IS A
HARD GROUP TO REALLY- GET TO
YOU AND TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
REALLY CAN GET THE WORD TO
THOSE PEOPLE IN WAYS THAT GOT
THEM TO ACT I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY OUR MOST CHALLENGING
POPULATION. AND I THINK THAT
SOME OF OUR SMALL COUNTIES ARE
LOOKING FOR FAITH BASED AND FOR
OTHER AIR OTHER TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AND HAVE DONE SOME
WORK THERE BUT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND WE'RE WORKING WITH.
THE RURAL COUNTIES TO COME UP
WITH IDEAS FOR THAT WE ARE ON
THE GROUND WITH THE CBO IS THAT
AND- IN. TRYING TO GET TO THE
FAITH BASED AND- ROTARY CLUBS
AND OTHER PLACES WHERE WE THINK
WE CAN MAYBE MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE AND GOT SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE VACCINE
AND WHY IT REALLY IS SO
IMPORTANT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL
OF YOU I THINK WE WILL READY TO
MOVE ON NOW TO- ISSUE NUMBER
TWO BOOKS FOR LOW INCOME
CHILDREN MY WEREN'T REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE PANEL AND THANK
EVERYBODY FOR ALL THEIR WORK.
IN AND AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WILL CERTAINLY BE HEARING AND
SEEING A LOT MORE OF EACH OTHER
GOING FORWARD. KEEP CLIMBING. I
AM KATHRYN LOPEZ I AM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THE POOREST WAKE OFFICE
ARE WE ARE PRESENTING ON BOOKS
FOR KIDS IT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATION
FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PROMOTING CHILD LITERACY IS
IMPORTANT ENDEAVOR AND
LEVERAGING EXISTING QUICK
PLATFORM TO APPROACH THESE
CHILDREN WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN WHO
WE CAN APPROACH BY PROVIDING
BOOKS TO HELP WITH OUR
EMERGING. LEADERS WE HAVE THE
WEIGHT CLASS LINE THAT IS
FAMILIAR TO ALL OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS AND IT'S EASY TO
NOW PROVIDE THEM WITH BOOKS
THROUGH THAT PLATFORM IN THE
AREA THAT THEY'RE FAMILIAR
WESTWICK IS ALSO COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND
LOCAL AND COUNTY FIRST FIVE
COMMISSIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING ANY OF
OUR EFFORTS AND WE'RE GETTING
THE EXPERTISE. THAT THEY HAVE
AND WE WILL PROVIDE THE BOOKS
ARE POPULATION AND SO WITH THIS
AFTER WE'RE JUST I'M SHIFTING-
ARE FUNDS TO LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
TO BETTER SERVE OUR
PARTICIPANTS. THERE ANY
QUESTION. I DON'T HAVE ANY
AFFECT ON THE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BYE THANK YOU BILL YOUR
DEPARTMENT FINANCED YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING ON THIS ONE. RIGHT
NOW AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SEND YOU PARTICULARLY- WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY COMMENTS THANK YOU
JEFF JACKS WILL FINANCE NOTHING
FROM US AS WELL. AND I LOVE
THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU OKAY YOU
CAN- NEXT ISSUE NUMBER THREE
COSMETIC FRAGRANCE FRAGRANCE
FLAVOR INGREDIENT RIGHT TO NOW.
EVERYONE MY NAME IS MONICA
MORALES AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. I WILL BE DISCUSSING
TODAY ARE SAFE COSMETICS
PROPOSAL THIS PROPOSAL I
REQUEST AN APPROPRIATION OF
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOR FY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWO. AND FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR FY TWENTY TWO NON
KOREAN- THIS PROPOSAL AND IT'S
READY FOR US TO MAINTAIN. AND
OPERATE OUR- DATABASE RECORDING
ARE SAFE COSMETICS. YOU KNOW
PER A. B. E. TWELFTH WE JUST
HAD A NEW- MANDATE THAT WOULD
TAKE LACE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. WHICH BASICALLY
REQUIRES MANUFACTURERS TO
PROVIDE- ARE SAFE COSMETICS
PROGRAM A LIST OF EACH
REPORTABLE FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENT. IN SAFE COSMETIC
AND SKIN IN COSMETIC PROGRAM-
PRODUCTS. SO AS A RESULT YOU
KNOW THIS- APPROPRIATION REALLY
WILL HELP US. MAKE THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
DATABASE MAINLY ADDING MORE
VARIABLES THAT INDIVIDUALS WILL
BE ABLE TO REPORT ON- AND ALSO
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO. A POST
THIS ON OUR- SURGICAL DATABASE
ARE SAFE AND EXPEDIENT BASIS-
THE PROPOSAL ALSO HELP. THE ON
I SIX THAT WE NEED A WE KNOW
THAT WITH ANY I PRIDE- IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT YOU NEED TO
HAVE POINT SINCE YOU ANTICIPATE
THAT MORE ADDITIONAL
INGREDIENTS WILL PROBABLY BE
ADDED. AS LEARN MORE AND MORE
ABOUT THESE FRAGRANCES AND ADDS
MORE FRAGRANCES ARE ACTUALLY.
WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE AND-
MY- PRESENTATION ON THIS ONE HE
THINK EVERYBODY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HELLO MICHIGAN THERE
HAD HOPE CREEK DR FROM JAPAN
JUST A THREE QUESTION- I DID SO
FACING DESCRIPTION THIS IS TO
SET INCREASE MORE FIELDS IN THE
DATABASE AND OTHER I. T.
CHANGES. IT WAS THE DEPARTMENT
NINE TO SPENDING THE LOS BEST A
FEISS WHAT TYPES OF DATA YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO COLLECT THE
DEPARTMENT NOT A- IT'S- IT'S
JUST A PHASE THE- FIELDS THAT
NEED TO BE INCLUDED ARE
DESCRIBED IN THE LAW OR BARS
THIS BECAUSE YOU'RE- COLLECTING
THINGS ARE BEYOND THE STATUTE I
CAN YOU JUST CLARIFY WHY THE
FIELDS ADDITIONAL FIELDS ARE
NEEDED. WHAT KIND OF FIELD ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT. SO RIGHT NOW
WE DO HAVE ANY FIELD
SPECIFICALLY AROUND FRAGRANCE
SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE- THE
DATABASE DOES COLLECT RIGHT
NOW- OTHER PRODUCTS. YOU KNOW
NECMETTIN AROUND FRAGRANCE AND
SO WE DON'T YOU HAVE YOUR NOW
BECAUSE- THIS SPECIFIC SB THREE
FIVE TWELVE REQUIREMENTS IS
AROUND FRAGRANCE. WE DO HAVE TO
GO BACK TO OUR DATA SYSTEM. AND
PLAN OKAY. IS THERE A SO YOU
SAID THESE ARE VARIABLES
REQUIRES THAT YOU'RE REQUIRED
TO COLLECT BY LAW THAT YOU
DIDN'T PLAN ON THE PREVIOUS
EXPANSION AND NOW YOU'RE ADDING
THEM TO THE DATASET CORRECT.
CORRECT IN V- I'M SORRY SB
THREE TWELVE REQUIREMENTS
REALLY JUST WENT INTO EFFECT
SEPT SOMETHING WE DID NOT
ANTICIPATE OKAY THAT'S THAT'S
IT THAT'S WHY IT'S ON CLARIFY
THAT THIS IS FOR- THINGS
SPECIFICALLY MANDATED BY THE
LAW THAT WERE NOT ANTICIPATED
AT THE TIME WE INITIALLY FUNDED
THE DATABASE OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
MOVING ON ISSUE NUMBER FOR
ESTABLISHING THE OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION. IN THE
MORNING GONZALEZ WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THIS IS A REQUEST FOR AN
APPROPRIATION OF SEVEN HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
FOR FY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND I'M GOING TO ESTABLISH THE
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION AS
AUTHORIZED BY A. B. TWENTY ONE
TWELVE AND THE SPECIFIC TECH
FRIENDLY IT WOULD SUPPORT. FIVE
FTP SPENT REALLY IT WILL BE
WORKING ON A LOT OF THE KEY-
WALLS OF THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
INCLUDING PROVIDING INFORMATION
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE YOU
KNOW CHORE STATEWIDE PARTNERS
AND EVEN REGIONAL PARTNERS
AROUND PROMISING PRACTICES FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
POLICIES. ALSO CONDUCTING
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS- AROUND
JUST SUICIDE PREVENTION
POLICIES AND PRACTICES LOOKING
A LITTLE BIT DEEPER IN TERMS OF
DISSEMINATING THIS INFORMATION
AND REALLY PUSHING FOR- YOU
KNOW SOME INFORMATION AROUND
PREVENTION EFFORTS AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL AND REALLY
SERVING AS A CONVENER WITH
CHEESE STAKEHOLDERS WORKING.
WITH SOME OF OUR POPULATIONS
WITH THE HIGHEST RATES OF
SUICIDE BECAUSE YOU ARE NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION OLDER DOGS
VETERANS AND THE LGBT
COMMUNITY- WE WILL OBVIOUSLY BE
WORKING AND CONSULTING WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THE QUESTION EXCUSE ME. ON
THESE EFFORTS I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A QUESTION THERE ABOUT
HOW WE PLAN TO IMPLEMENT IN THE
FORTY EIGHT- WITH. THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND SO WE HAVE AN
EXISTING PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMMISSION WE HAVE BEEN MEETING
WITH THEM FOR YEARS YOU'RE
REALLY LOOKING ENSURING SOME OF
OUR HOMICIDE AND SUICIDE DATA
WE HAVE BEEN MEETING ALSO MORE
RECENTLY TALKING ABOUT THE CDC
SUICIDE PREVENTION STRATEGIES.
AND ALSO THINKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW WAYS THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO PARTNER I ALSO KNOW THAT A
LOT OF FOLKS- IN OUR DEPARTMENT
SUCH AS YOU DO THAT THE.
DIRECTOR IN THE OFFICE TO HELP
MAKE WE WILL HAVE ITS MEDIAN
PROTECT YOUR- AND ART DIRECTOR
WOULD YOU WHAT THE CONDITIONS
DIRECTOR AND REALLY OF CRAZY
ENTERED. ARE INTENDED DEEP INTO.
PARTNERSHIP BE A MORE SPECIFIC.
IDEALLY THE YOUR ENSURE THAT WE
INSTITUTE STRUCK ARMENIANS WERE
YOU BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THIS. OF
YOU KNOW THAT HI STRAIGHT
TWENTY TWELVE THINK ABOUT THE
PRIORITIES THAT- THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLAN HARMS IN REALLY
NEAR THOSE PARTNERSHIPS BY
IDENTIFYING MORE CONCRETELY YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO WHAT WE
CAN GET TOGETHER. AND REALLY
ADVANCE YOU KNOW THE NATION
THAT ARE BOTH THE OFFICE OF
SUICIDE HAS. ALSO THIS MYTH
RATE PLAN THAT'S ALREADY OUT
THERE YOU WITH THE ADDRESS OF
THE SITE PREVENTION. ANSWERED
THAT'S THE THINKING RIGHT NOW
ON THE ROAD SHOULD I WELCOME
ANY IDEAS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE-
OR JUST APPROACH IS THAT YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE ALSO
THINK YOU THANK YOU. PART OF
FINANCIAL. I JACKSON ANSWERS
FOR UP WE'VE BEEN AT THE WILL
LET'S SEE TO CREATE A OFFICER
AFTER AS- MARKET SHARE SO. THIS
PROJECT FOR AND WENT OUT AFTER
QUESTIONS YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS. THANK YOU CHAIR AND I
WOULD JUST NOT THE WE REVIEWED
THIS. IT TO BE A REASON. WAGE
TO BEGIN AND- AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE AND- REFLECTS ONE OF THE
OBJECTIVES THAT'S DETAILED IN
THE MENTAL SIR BUT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSIONS-
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION- GIVEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE OF
COURSE WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR- PROGRESS TO MAKE SURE
THINGS ARE IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY. THANK YOU- IN THIS
WORLD SO. SO AND I KNOW YOU'RE
WE'RE STILL IN KIND OF THAT THE
THINKING ABOUT THIS A BUT. IS
YOUR IS IT IS THE PLAN THEN TO
WORK WITH WITH COUNTIES OR WITH
CBO'S. AND HOW IT. AND WHAT'S
THE DM THE STATUS OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT EXISTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS AS
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT BEING A
RESOURCE AS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION YOU
KNOW IT WE ARE PARTNERED WITH
T. H. C. S. FOR EXAMPLE AS WELL
WE KNOW THAT DEPARTMENT AND
EDUCATION HAS EFFORTS ARE RUN
USE. SUICIDE PREVENTION WE KNOW
ALSO THAT THE COMMISSION HAS A
ROBUST- YOU KNOW INFRASTRUCTURE
OR AT LEAST GIVES ME YOU KNOW
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEIR
SHEPHERDING G. ACTIVITIES AND
WE WERE PART OF ALL THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. I WILL SAY THAT IN
INTERNALLY TO CDPH- WE'VE BEEN
MOBILIZING OR AT LEAST TRYING
TO REALLY ORGANIZE A LOT OF OUR
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM TO RUN THIS
REALLY TRACKING SUICIDE
TRACKING HOMICIDE. WE NEED
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE PREVENTION
STRATEGIES THAT- WE CAN MOVE
AND ORGANIZE AROUND I'M
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAS HAPPENED
IS THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD
HISTORICAL FUNDING FOR THIS
RIGHT AND SO WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF. FUN FROM BONO WORK AS I
LIKE TO CALL IT IN THE
DEPARTMENT WHERE WE LEVERAGE
ACROSS OUR DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW RELEASING
DATA THINK ABOUT A SUICIDE- AND
THEN MOST RECENTLY AS OF
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR WE DID
RECEIVE A GRANT FROM CDC. ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND PER FIVE
ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS YOU
START REALLY HAVING A PUBLIC
HEALTH- YOU KNOW A FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
CALIFORNIA WERE VERY PLEASED
WITH THAT. BUT IT DEFINITELY
DOES NOT COVER THE SPECTRUM
THAT WE SEE AND- THE INTENT OF
THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE IN THE
FORESEEABLE COMPLIMENTED VERY
MUCH WILL ALSO COMPLEMENT THE
PLAN ON- THE SUICIDE PREVENTION
FIND THAT THE CONDITION IS
MOVING FORWARD. I'M SO WE
BELIEVE ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
EFFORTS WERE REALLY JUST
STANDARDIZE IT WILL HOPEFULLY
BE OUR ROLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE BRING THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER OR THAT WE ACTUALLY
AND BETTER SELVES IF WE HAVEN'T
ALREADY AND SOME OF THE
EXISTING PLANNING SESSIONS
THERE ARE TAKING PLACE
WORKGROUPS. YOU KNOW COMMITTEES
AND SO FORTH SO HOPEFULLY THAT
HELPS A LITTLE BIT BIT-
DEFINITELY AT SNAPSHOT AT LEAST
THAT'S STARTING TO DEVELOPED
INTO THE- OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
I WOULD SAY JUST LIKE WE EARLY
ON A PUBLIC AND FAX HAS IT. THE
THIS IS SOME THAT WE ALSO HAVE
TO THINK A LOT ABOUT MY- ABOUT
HOW HOW WE TALK ABOUT THIS HOW
DO WE GET THE WORD OUT AND THEN
HAVE RESOURCES FOR HELP. I
RECENTLY HAD TO. RENEW MY LCSW
LICENSE AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I HAD TO DO IN TAKING MORE
SEE YEARS WAS A- SUICIDE
PREVENTION. AND I REMEMBER WHEN
THE BILL PASSED- MY COLLEAGUE.
MR LEVINE AYE SO WHY WHY
WALKING. IS THE MOST IS THE
BEST PLACE TO MAKE PEOPLE GET
MORE TRAINING FOR THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF
TRAINING IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO
ME TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
POLICE OFFICERS- PEOPLE
EMERGENCY ROOMS PEOPLE WHO MAY
NOT ALREADY HAVE ADVANCED
TRAINING. IN SUICIDE PREVENTION
AND INTERVENTION AND
IDENTIFICATION BUT REALLY BE
ABLE TO MOVE TRAINING SANTA
CLASSROOMS AND ALL KINDS OF
OTHER PLACES SO ANYWAY THIS
INSIDE DR BRANDED YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ON THIS ONE. OKAY I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING A LOT
MORE ABOUT THIS AND- TRACKING
THIS AS IT GOES FORWARD- SO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS. OKAY MOVING ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS. THE
GREAT HERE ABOUT THAT BIG PUMP
AGAIN- THE RELOCATION TO THE
CLIFFORD AVENUE BUILDING PHASE
THREE MOVING IN THERE. IF YOU
CAME OUT CHAIR AND I LOVED IT
HELLO DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITALS I SHOULD WALK IN THE
FIRST WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BRIGHT HOUSE
OR GETTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS I'LL
BE SPEAKING ON ON ISSUES ONE
THROUGH SIX ACTUALLY IN
STARTING WITH ISSUE ONE AND TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSAL IT DOES. REPRESENT A
MULTI DEPARTMENT REQUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS UNTIL PRIMARILY
BE FOCUSING ON THE DISK YES H.
COMPONENTS OF THE REQUEST
HOWEVER CAN ALSO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE TOTAL REQUEST
ON. BEHALF OF ALL THREE
ENTITIES AS WELL. SPECIFICALLY
TO DEPARTMENT STAY HOSPITALS
THIS IS A REQUEST TO SUPPORT
INCREASED RENTAL COST OF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION. IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AN ONGOING
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MOVE. THE
NEW CLIFFORD L. ALLEN B.
BUILDING. IN ADDITION TO THE
RATE INCREASED YES THEY JUST
SEEKING TO POINT- POSITION
AUTHORITY NO FUNDING. TO
PROVIDE TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT TO
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. FOR BACKGROUND
PURPOSES- BUDGET REQUEST FOR
THE THREE DEPARTMENTS INCREASED
COSTS RELATED TO THE RELOCATION
OF THE- BEEN DIVIDED INTO THREE
SEPARATE SPACES. A PHASE ONE
WAS REPOSE AND ENACTED AS PART
OF THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT INCLUDED FUNDING FOR
PLANNING EFFORTS REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE THE MOVE. PHASE TWO
WAS PROPOSED AND ENACTED AS
PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET I CAN INCLUDE THE
FUNDING FOR THE PHYSICAL MOVED.
AND NOW I FACE THREE INCLUDES
THE PHYSICAL OCCUPATION OF THE
BUILDING AND THIS PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES THE INCREASED RATE
COSTS. INCREASE RENT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RESIDENTS
IN THE BUILDING. UPDATED RENTAL
RATES WERE UNAVAILABLE DURING
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TEN
BUDGET- DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND
HAVE BECOME AVAILABLE SINCE
THEN WHICH ARE BASED ON DHS'S.
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PRICE BOOK FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- ALL
DEPARTMENTS ALL THREE
DEPARTMENTS ANTICIPATE STARTING
TO OCCUPY THE ALLENBY BUILDING
BEGINNING IN LATE. JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AT THIS TIME
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE RELATED TO
PHASE THREE UP THREE LOCATIONS
THE CLIFFORD L. ALLENBY
BUILDING. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THAT DOCTOR PAN.
QUESTIONS ON THE RELOCATION TO
JUST CLARIFY WE SEE RENT
INCREASES THAT RENTS WERE PAINT
TO OURSELVES AS A STATE OR IS
THAT RENT TO I THINK THAT
THAT'S A STATE BUILDING RIGHT-
YES RENT SHOES DGS. FOR IT'S
BASED ON SQUARE FOOTAGE WELL AS
A SURCHARGE AS DHS IS THE
PROPERTY MANAGER AS WELL AS
PAYING DOWNTHE BOND OBLIGATION
FOR. FUNDING FOR THE BUILDING.
OH OKAY ALL RIGHT I THOUGHT WE
PAID CASH GIVEN THE UNDERGROUND
BUT ANYWAY OKAY SITES ON
CLARIFY THIS IS A RENT INCREASE
THAT THE STATE HAS CHARGED IT'S
AN AGENCY. THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
OFFSETTING YEAH I GET IT OKAY
RIGHT NOW THAT'S JUST THIS ONE
MAKES THAT CLEAR WHEN EVERYONE
HEARS RATE INCREASE AND THAT
WATCH THIS HEARING THAT IT'S
NOT. IT'S ACTUALLY RENT WE'RE
PAYING TO OURSELVES OKAY THANK
YOU. OKAY THE- AND I DID AYE
RESCUE AYE YO DEPARTMENT
FINANCED YOU HAVE ANYTHING ON
THIS. THIS PHASE THREE MOVE.
YES DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
COMMENTS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU BRENT.
MURATSUCHI DELEO NO COMMENTS
FROM THE AUDIO AND THAT'S WHAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY MR
HOUSER CHILI MOVE ONTO
INCREASED INVESTIGATION
WORKLOAD. SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSAL THIS IS A REQUEST
FOR A THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING TO
SUPPORT THE NEED FOR
INVESTIGATIVE STAFF AND ALL
FIVE OF D. SHS HOSPITALS. I
GUESS AGES REQUESTING AGREE
CLASSIFIED TWENTY EXISTING
HOSPITAL POLICE OFFICER
POSITION TO THE INVESTIGATOR
CLASSIFICATION- OVER THE YEARS
WITH N INCREASING PATIENT
POPULATION DEMOGRAPHICS AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF GSA JIM
PLEASE- THIS HAS RELATED TO-
INCREASE INVESTIGATIVE WORK
LOAD. A WORKLOAD DRIVERS FOR
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE CRIMINAL
WENT OR ADMINISTRATIVE
INCIDENTS THAT WAR AND
INVESTIGATION THE SEVERITY OF
THE OFFENSES AND THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE INCIDENT TYPE. A WHILE DSHS
BEEN MANAGING THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ITS INVESTIGATIONS- WE DO
REQUEST THE REAPER
CLASSIFICATION TO INVESTIGATORS
FOR THE HOSPITAL POLICE
OFFICERS BECAUSE THE WORKLOAD
BEING COMPLETED IT'S AT A LEVEL
MORE CONSISTENT WITH THE DUTIES
OF AN INVESTIGATOR
CLASSIFICATION. AS A RESULT OF
THE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
IS REQUESTING THE APPROPRIATE
POSITION OF FORTY AND THE
INCREMENTAL DIFFERENCE IN
FUNDING FROM THE HOSPITAL
POLICE OFFICER PUT
CLASSIFICATION TO THE
INVESTIGATOR CLASSIFICATION.
APPROVAL OF THIS REQUEST WILL
ENABLE DSHS THE APPROPRIATE
INVESTIGATIVE STAFFING NEEDED
TO PROVIDE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR PATIENTS STAFF AND THE
COMMUNITY. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING. NO COMMENTS THANK YOU
HELLO. OKAY YEAH WHEN I WAS
GETTING BRIEFED ON THIS I
THOUGHT WHAT WHAT WHEN WE HAVE
THESE LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
AS WELL AS MORE OF AN
INVESTIGATION AS WE KNOW THOSE
ISSUES DON'T JUST OCCUR AT
STATE HOSPITALS BUT ACROSS OUR
SPECTRUM OF VULNERABLE PEOPLE
HELD A DEPEND QUESTIONS ON
THIS. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OKAY MOVING ON TO A
STATEWIDE WITH IT SURE RISK.
SPECIAL REPAIR FUNDING. THANK
YOU- TO PRIVATE PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THIS REQUEST IT'S
FOR BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TRICKS
STAND THE ENCUMBRANCE
EXPENDITURE PERIOD FOR LIKE OR
LITERATURE ESPECIAL REPAIR
FUNDING THAT WAS AUTHORIZED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT. A
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IS NEEDED
TO ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES AND
COMPLETING THE PURCHASE OR
FABRICATION OF LITERATURE
RETROFIT MATERIALS AND LABOR
ISSUES THAT HAVE NECESSITATED
AN EXTENDED TIME FRAME TO.
COMPLETE THAT REQUIRE RETROFITS
OF THE PROPOSED PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE EXTEND THE FUNDING
PERIOD BY THREE YEARS
COMMENCING WITH THE TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY TWO FUNDING NO
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS ARE FUNDING
IS BEING PREPPED REQUESTED ONLY
A LONGER AVAILABILITY OF FUNDS
PERIOD. I BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED FUNDING TO ADDRESS
LIGATURE RISK WITHIN THE S. H.
IS JOINT COMMISSION ACCREDITED
HOSPITALS. NATIONALLY STATE
HOSPITAL'S ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS AND HOSPITALS WITH
ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC UNITS HAVE
BEEN REQUIRED TO EITHER
MITIGATE THESE LIGATURE RISK OR
RISK LOSING. THEIR
ACCREDITATION- THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY CHALLENGE AND MITIGATING
THESE RISKS BASED ON THE
PURCHASING AND PRODUCTION
PROCESS THESE ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE TYPES OF CHANGES. A
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES WE'VE
EXPERIENCED AMONG OTHERS
NATIONALLY ARE THE PRODUCTS
USED TO MITIGATE THESE RISKS
ARE USUALLY NOT STOCKTON MASS
QUANTITIES BY VENDORS IN MANY
INSTANCES ARE MADE TO CUSTOM
ORDER- GIVEN THE HIGH NATIONAL
DEMAND COMBINED WITH. THE
LIMITED AVAILABILITY IN STOCK
HAS MADE IT DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN
THESE MATERIALS IN A TIMELY
FASHION ON THE SUFFOCATING THE
LONGER PERIOD OF AVAILABILITY
OF FUNDS. ADDITIONALLY COVERED
NINETEEN HAS IMPACTED DSHS
ABILITY TO ADDRESS LIKE
INTERESTING THE WAY WE HAD
ORIGINALLY PLANNED. ON THIS
IMPACT WAS NOT ONLY FILL OUT
OUR HOSPITALS WHERE WE HAD TO
MAKE OPERATIONAL CHANGES TO
PROTECT PATIENTS AND STAFF.
INCLUDING LIMITING CONSTRUCTION
AND RETROFITS A PATIENT UNITS
BUT ALSO IMPACTED THE VENDORS
THAT PRODUCE AND SUPPLY THESE
MATERIALS. ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES ARE ONCE THE
PRODUCTS ARE OBTAINED
INSTALLATION OF THE SPECIALIZED
MATERIALS DOES REQUIRE PLANNING
AND MAY REQUIRE COORDINATION OF
MULTIPLE SKILLED TRADE LABOR
SUCH AS DEMOLITION CARPENTERS.
PLUMBERS FOR INSTALLATION
CARPENTERS FOR CABINETS AND
OTHER FINISHING- LABOR SUCH AS
PAINTERS FOR TOUCH UP WORK- SO
IN SUMMARY THIS REQUEST IS JUST
TO EXTEND THE ENCUMBRANCE
DURING THE BILL ABILITY OF
FUNDS- THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
APPROPRIATED THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACTS SO THAT WE MAY
COMPLETE. THE OPERATE RETRO.
THANK YOU HAPPY TAKEN ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NO
QUESTIONS I BELIEVE THAT COVERS
IT THANK YOU MISTER SHE TO
ANYTHING ON THIS ONE THANK YOU
AND I'M I'M HOPING YOU'RE ALSO
WORKING ON THE ON THE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT- OF WAS
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND THEY YET
TO DECREASE THE UP. THE
LIKELIHOOD OR ASSESS IF
SOMEBODY IS LIKELY TO BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE IN STRANGULATION
BEHAVIOR AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
INTERACTION OR WILL YOU HAVE
ANY INTERACTION WITH THE PART
IN A PUBLIC HEALTH AND A
SUICIDE PREVENTION OR- ASSUMING
YOU HAVE YOUR OWN UNIT WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT THE DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
FESTEJOS WAS LOOKING AT THAT.
WE DO HAVE A STATE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT- DIVISION THAT DOES
WORK ON THIS AND WORK WITH THE
HOSPITALS TO IDENTIFY THE RISKS
AND APPROPRIATE MITIGATION
EFFORTS I THINK THERE. WELL I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT EXPERTISE
ON. THE NON KIND OF. THE GOAL
IMPROVEMENT ASPECT OF IT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WE DO HAVE A
UNIT THAT LOOKS LIKE THIS AS
WELL AS- THE SURVEY THERE'S
THAT COME IN AND REVIEW OUR
HOSPITAL PRACTICES AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ACCORDINGLY
AND- WE HAD RECENT SURVEYS AND
HAVE- A PAST THOSE SURVEYS IN
OUR IN OUR MEETING THE
APPROPRIATE STANDARDS TO. AT
THE JOINT COMMISSION. IN A
COMBAT I HAVE MY COLLEAGUE
NICOLE HICKS ON THE LINE OR
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER THAT
MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL INSIGHT
THAT I COULD NOT. PROVIDE
INSIGHT TO. MYSTICS ANYTHING TO
ADD TO THAT ARE WE ARE WE-
BEING ABLE TO ASSESS AND
MITIGATE. TO SILENCE REGULATION
ATTEMPTS WITHOUT JUST TAKING
OFF A COAT- PICKING UP DOOR
HOOKS. YES THAT'S CORRECT I
MEAN IT'S BEEN A IT'S BEEN A
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR STATE. STATEWIDE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT TEAMS AS WELL AS
OUR REGULATORY PARTNERS TO TRY
AND MITIGATE THE RISKS POSED IN
THE PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL AS IN OUR- CLINICAL
PROTOCOLS. THANK YOU THIRD
PENDING ON THIS FOR QUITE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN WE
WILL MOVE ON. IF YOU NUMBER FOR
MR HOUSER. THANK YOU ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR IS MAINLY TECHNICAL
IN NATURE- INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WERE TO
PROPOSALS THAT PROVIDED LIMIT
TERM FUNDING FOR RESOURCES OVER
TWO YEARS I THESE PROPOSAL DID
NOT INCLUDE POSITION AUTHORITY
SO THIS REQUEST IS TO ADJUST
THOSE PROPOSALS APPOSITION
AUTHORITY TO ENABLE RETAINING
THE INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY IN
THESE POSITIONS AS I THESE
PROPOSALS ARE AN EXTENSION OF
LIMITED TERM RESOURCES APPROVED
A PRIOR BUDGET ACTS ARE SET TO
EXPIRE. AT THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR- SO THE REQUEST
SLASH UPDATE IS NOT FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BUT TO ADD
FIVE POINT FIVE PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUEST RELATED TO
INCREASE COURT APPEARANCES AND
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT- PROPOSAL
AND EIGHT POSITIONS TO THE
PROTECTED HEALTH INFORMATION
PROPOSAL- FOR BACKGROUND
PURPOSES IS THE ISSUE WAS HEARD
THESE ISSUES WERE HEARD AND-
FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX UP THREE
HEARING OUT INCREASE CORE.
APPEARANCES THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT PROPOSAL SUPPORTS WORKLOAD
WITH THE CONTINUED DEMAND FOR
ATTORNEYS TO APPEAR IN COURT
AND RESPONDING TO THE INCREASED
VOLUME AND COMPLEXITY OF.
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST. AND
DEEPER TO HEALTH AND PROPOSALS
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
SUSTAINED WORKLOAD WITH
PROCESSING OUTSIDE MEDICAL
INVOICES AND PROTECTING PROTECT
PROTECTED HEALTH INFORMATION.
ALSO IN SOME RATE THIS- AT THIS
ISSUES RELATED TO A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO ADDING POSITION
AUTHORITY CHU CHU OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU A
DIFFERENT FINANCE ANYTHING. THE
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
THANK YOU OKAY THIS ISSUE THE
THING. OKAY DR GRANT. OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
HYDRONIC LOOP REPLACEMENT. FIVE
WE'RE ALMOST THERE TO THE
POSSIBLE WATER BOOST PALM SO
WHAT WE'LL GET THERE SHORTLY IN
ISSUE NUMBER SIX ON THE
HYDRONIC WITH REPLACEMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
REQUEST THE DECREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND- BASED ON. UPDATED
DGS DEPARTMENT GENERAL'S
SERVICES UPDATED COST ESTIMATES
AS THAT BACKGROUND PURPOSES
THIS PROJECT REPLACES THE
SEVERELY CORRODED AND
DETERIORATED I JOIN A GROUP
PIPING SYSTEM WITH ANY
COMPLETELY NEW PIPING SYSTEM
WHICH WILL. OFFICIALLYPROVIDE
HOT WATER HEATING TO THE
FACILITIES INCLUDING PATIENT
OCCUPIED BUILDINGS. ARE SINCE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YES AGING
ICHI DGS EVALUATED ALTERNATIVE
SYSTEM OPTIONS FOR THE PROJECT
AND SELECTED AS FAST
SPECIALIZED A PLASTIC PIPING
SYSTEM WHICH REDUCE THE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS IN BOTH
LABOR AND MATERIAL- THE SYSTEM
WILL DELIVER THE REQUIRED
PROTECTION FROM THE CORROSIVE
SOIL THEREBY- STILL PROVIDING
THE SAME LEVEL OF QUALITY AND
LONGEVITY OF THE PIPING SYSTEM-
BUT AT A MORE COST EFFECTIVE-
AS IS. MORE COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION. ADDITIONALLY
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IS ALSO
REQUESTED REGARDING THE
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDS PERIOD
ALLOWING FOR THE COMPLETION OF
THE WORKING DRAWINGS AND
CONSTRUCTION- I'M- HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
SUGGESTED FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS UP FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCE OR THAT THE
L. A. O. AND I GUESS I'LL I
WILL JUST ASK ARE WE SURE THIS
ONE. IF WE'RE GONNA GET A LESS
EXPENSIVE ONE THAT IS ACTUALLY
GONNA LAST. SINCE THE LAST ONE
DID LAST. THAT IS MY- I THINK
IN OUR DISCUSSION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WERE ASSURED THAT WE WOULD
STILL BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE
LEVEL OF QUALITY WITH THIS NEW
SPECIALIZED UP. PLASTIC PIPING
SYSTEM- JUST AT A LESSER PRICE
HOWEVER OF MY COLLEAGUE GOT
NICOLE HICKS MAY HAVE MORE
DETAIL AS TO. HOW THAT WILL BE
ACHIEVED WITH THE PARTICULAR
PRODUCT THAT WAS EVALUATED
MAYBE THE LIFE OF THIS.
HYDRAULIC LOOP. EXACTLY AND I
MEAN AS FAR AS THE OVERALL
LENGTH OF THE NEW SYSTEM ARE
EXPECTED ABOUT A FIFTY YEAR
WHITE EXPECTANCY BUT THIS NEW
PIPE AND WHAT MAKES IT
DIFFERENT THAN. PREVIOUS
TECHNOLOGIES AND SYSTEMS THAT
WERE CONSIDERED IS THE
APPLICATION OF THE MATERIAL ON
THE POINT BEING THAT INHIBITS
ANY DETERIORATION FROM ACROSS
THE SOIL WHICH WASN'T AVAILABLE
INITIALLY WHEN WE FIRST LOOKED
AT THIS AS THE PRODUCTS ARE NOT
ONLY AS A PROJECT SO NOT ONLY
IS IT. MORE COST EFFECTIVE IT'S
EASIER TO IMPLEMENT INSTALL AND
YOU GET A COMPARABLE LIFE
EXPECTANCY. OKAY THANK YOU DIRT
PATH. OKAY THANK YOU ISSUE
NUMBER SIX ATASCADERO THE
POTABLE. WATER BOOSTER PUMP
SYSTEM REAPPROPRIATION. YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
REQUEST A REAPPROPRIATION OF A
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR THE
WORKING DRAWINGS AT THE
ATASCADERO POSSIBLE WATER
BOOSTER SYSTEM OF THE
REAPPROPRIATION AS NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS PROJECT DELAYS SUCH AS
COMPLETING THE REAL ESTATE DUE
DILIGENCE PROCESS- THAT WAS
EXPERIENCED DURING THE
PRELIMINARY PLANNING PHASE HAT
WAS DRIVEN BY. COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC OF THIS
REAPPROPRIATION WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS TO
COMPLETE THE WORKING JOHN SPACE
THE PROJECT CAN PROCEED TO
CONSTRUCTION JUST CLEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE- BACKGROUND
PURPOSES THIS PROJECT INCLUDES
INSTALLING A PART OF OUR WATER
BOOSTER PUMP SYSTEM TO SERBIA
CENTER TASK DEREK TO ADDRESS
WATER LINE PRESSURE ISSUES THAT
SUPPORT THE MAIN FIRE SPRINKLER
SYSTEM AND DOMESTIC WATER
OPERATIONS INCLUDING A PATIENTS
OUT SHOWERS. AND SINKS AND
TOILETS XTERRA. HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY ON ISSUE NUMBER SIX. BERMAN
FINANCER EARLIER CAN SHAKE YOUR
HEAD. OKAY THE PLAN. OKAY MR
HOUSER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PHYSICS WE APPRECIATE YOUR OF
YOUR YOUR SERVICE I THINK MY
NUMBERS NINE. TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE COVERED
CALIFORNIA. GOOD EVENING
PRODUCT HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN THANK YOU. THANKS SO
MUCH ANYWAYS K<c.cyan> RAVEL AND</c>
THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
ELIGIBILITY IN RESEARCHING
COVER CALIFORNIA AND HAPPY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE TONIGHT ON
OUR PROGRAM AND RESPONSES TO
YOUR QUESTIONS UNDER ITEM ONE.
A BEGIN BY PROVIDING AN UPDATE
ON OUR MOST RECENT OPEN
ENROLLMENT PERIOD IN SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIODS AND THEN
I'LL TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THE AMERICAN ARRESTED PLAN ON
AFFORDABILITY FOR CONSUMERS. AS
OF JANUARY NEARLY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAD EITHER
RENEWED OR SIGNED UP FOR NEW
COVERAGE FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
HIS NUMBER WAS AN INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OVER THE SAME TIME
PERIOD LAST YEAR I REPRESENTED
A NEW HIGH WATER MARK FOR OUR
ENROLLMENT. SINCE THE END OF
OUR TRADITIONAL OPEN ENROLLMENT
PERIOD ON JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
YOU CAN ACTIVELY PROMOTING
SPECIAL SUB SEVERAL SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT EVENTS AS PART OF
OUR CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
RESPOND TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
OF THE PANDEMIC. IN FEBRUARY WE
OPEN THE SPECIAL ENROLLMENT
PERIOD TO ALIGN WITH THE
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD THAT
WAS LAUNCHED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AT THE END OF
JANUARY. THEN ON MARCH ELEVENTH
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN WAS
SIGNED- WE'VE WORKED QUICKLY TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW AND EXPANDED
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES AVAILABLE
UNDER THAT LAW. AND ON APRIL
TWELFTH WE ANNOUNCED A NEW
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD THAT
WILL RUN THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE LOWER HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE ACT. UP COVER
CALIFORNIA WILL EMPHASIZE EARLY
SIGN UPS BY INVESTING UP TO
THREE AND A THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON TELEVISION RADIO AND
PRINT ADS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BETWEEN ALL IN JUNE. I NOW IN
THE MOVE TO THE- OF THE AMERICA
RESCUE. IN RESCUE CLINIC STEP
PROVISIONS TO MAKE THROUGH
CHAIN MORE. FOR PLANNING TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
OUR FIRST AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
FEDERAL PREMIUM SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOME BELOW
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. IT ALSO ELIMINATED THE
CAP ON FEDERAL SUBSIDIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOME ABOVE
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL- FINALLY FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR OR
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE WEEK OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
PREMIUM AND COST SHARING
SUPPORT AVAILABLE THROUGH
PROGRAM- THIS PROVISION WILL
APPLY TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE ONLY.
BY THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES PREMIUM
AFFORDABILITY WITHIN EXCHANGES
LIKE FOR CALIFORNIA. THE LAW
ENSURES THAT NO ONE HAS TO PAY
MORE THAN EIGHT POINT 5% OF
THEIR INCOME IN PREMIUMS FOR A
BENCHMARK SILVER PLANS. IT ALSO
ELIMINATES PREMIUM
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH INCOME BELOW 110050% OF
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. AND ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
ARE NOW ELIGIBLE FOR MORE HELP.
WOMEN GROUPS THAT WILL BENEFIT
FROM THESE CHANGES THAT THE
UNINSURED. THOSE WHO ENROLLED
IN THE INDIVIDUAL MARKET TODAY
OUTSIDE OF COVER CALIFORNIA AND
OF COURSE COVER CALIFORNIA
NUMBERS- CAL MEMBERS ALONE
YESTERDAY THE NEW PREMIUM TAX
CREDITS WILL PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY THREE BILLION
MEDICINAL FEDERAL PREMIUM
SAVINGS. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE
PROJECT THAT ON AVERAGE THAT
PREMIUMS WILL DECREASE BY OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS.
PER HOUSEHOLD PER MONTH
COMPARED TO WHAT COSTS WOULD
HAVE BEEN PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN. WELL THE EXACT
AMOUNT OF PREMIUM. SUBSIDY
DEPENDS ON CONSUMER SPECIFIC
SITUATION WE ESTIMATE THAT
UNINSURED CALIFORNIANS EARNING
BETWEEN NINETEEN AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR WHICH
COMPRISE TWO THIRDS OF THE
ELIGIBLE UNINSURED. CAN ENROLL
IN THE BENCHMARK SILVER PLANS
REDUCED COST SHARING FOR AN
AVERAGE OF SIXTY ONE DOLLARS
PER MONTH AND VIRTUALLY ALL
COULD GET A BRONZE PLAN FOR ONE
DOLLAR A NUMBER OF MONTHS.
EXCHANGE CONSUMERS ARE FOR
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OVER 4100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WILL
HAVE A CALIFORNIA IN MAY. WILL
RECEIVE AN AVERAGE OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH IN
FEDERAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR POTENTIAL SAVINGS OF NEARLY
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO TERRY
MOLD. FOR THE TWENTY MONTHS ARE
THE BENEFIT IS AVAILABLE
BETWEEN MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
TO ENSURE THE CALIFORNIANS CAN
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THESE
NEW AND EXPANDED BENEFITS WE
WORKED QUICKLY TO UPDATE OUR
ELIGIBILITY SYSTEM. AS OF APRIL
TWELFTH CONSUMERS WERE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR THE AMERICAN AS YOU
PLAN SUBSIDIES FOR COVERAGE
STARTING THE FIRST. ALSO IN
APRIL WE AUTOMATICALLY
REPROCESSED ELIGIBILITY FOR ALL
OF OUR EXISTING MEMBERS RECEIVE
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE. IN ORDER TO
LOWER THEIR BILLS BEGINNING MAY
FIRST. FINALLY IN JULY WILL BE
ABLE TO OFFER THE ADDITIONAL
PREMIUM AND COST SHARING
BENEFITS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
RECEIVE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
I'LL CLOSE THIS ITEM WITH THE
IMPACT TO THE STATE PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER IN PROVIDING STATE
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE TO
INDIVIDUALS OVER 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WHO ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR ASSISTANCE
UNDER THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM ALSO
PROVIDED ENHANCED PREMIUM
SUPPORT FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ENROLLEES WITH
INCOMES BELOW 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. AS YOU
COMMITTEE AGENDA NOTES THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE STATE
PREMIUMS SUBSIDY LEVELS HAVE
BEEN SUBSUMED BY THE MORE
GENEROUS FEDERAL PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES PROVIDED BY THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. AND DUE
TO THE RAPID IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FEDERAL BENEFITS IN OUR
SYSTEM THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STATE PREMIUM SUBSIDY
EXPENDITURES WILL BE LIMITED TO
THE PERIOD. OF JANUARY THROUGH
APRIL. RICH FROM MAY FIRST ON
HIS. WILL RECEIVE FEDERAL
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
IN THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. I
CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION ON
ITEM ONE AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE
WILL MOVE TO OUR PANELISTS NOW-
WE HAVE DIANA DOUGLAS POLICY
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA GEN FLORI
WITH THAT POLICY ADVOCATE THE
WASHINGTON ONLINE POVERTY. AND
MARK HERBERT VICE PRESIDENT
STRATEGIC INITIATIVES SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY. WE START
WITH ME THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD EVENING
DIANA DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE
STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION IS
ESTABLISHING STATE PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES IN TWENTY NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE NATION
IN KEEPING OUR HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKET PLACE AFFORDABLE IN FACT
THE RECENT FEDERAL EXPANSION OF
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES WHICH WILL
ENSURE NO ONE PAYS MORE THAN A
HALF PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME
TOWARDS PREMIUMS. BUILT UPON%
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABILITY WORK
WELL WE WELCOME THE INCREASED
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE WE ALSO URGE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAINTAIN
THEIR COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTH COVERAGE IN OUR HIGH
COST OF LIVING STATE THIS MEANS
A RE PURPOSING OUR EXISTING
PREMIUM SUBSIDY INVESTMENTS
WHICH WILL BE SUPPLANTED BY
FEDERAL FUNDS TO MAKE FURTHER
PROGRESS TOWARDS AFFORDABILITY
IN THE CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. BUT THE STATE OUT
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE MADE
EXCELLENT PROGRESS IN READING
AND MONTHLY PREMIUM COSTS ARE
STILL REAL AFFORDABILITY NEEDS.
FOR EXAMPLE OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES SUCH AS DEDUCTIBLES
AND COPAYMENTS CONTINUE TO
SKYROCKET. THE PERSON MAKING
THIRTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR WHOSE AND
ROLLED IN A STANDARD SILVER AND
HAS A DEDUCTIBLE OF FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WHICH EQUALS
MORE THAN A MONTH OF THEIR
SALARY NEARLY A THIRD OF PEOPLE
IN THIS INCOME RANGE CHOOSE
BROWN'S PLANTS DEDUCTIBLES OVER
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS. OUR
PROPOSAL OUTLINES POSSIBLE
ACTIONS TO REDUCE THE BURDEN OF
CARSHARING OPTION ONE USES THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE OF COST
SHARING REDUCTIONS IMPROVES
UPON IT BY LEVELING UP ALL
COVERED CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES
MAKING UNDER FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT. POVERTY TO THE NEXT
MOST GENEROUS COST SHARING
TIER. FOR EXAMPLE IN RELEASE
SINCE OVER EIGHTY SEVEN WITH A
FIFTEEN DOLLAR COPAY WOULD GET
A BUMP UP TO SILVER NINETY FOUR
AND HAVE ONLY A FIVE DOLLAR
COPAY FOR DOCTOR VISITS.
EVERYONE IN THE JUNE 524100%
POVERTY RANGE WOULD UPGRADE
INTO GOLD COST SHARING WITH
ZERO DEDUCTIBLES. ALTERNATIVELY
OPTION TWO WOULD TAKE A SIMPLE
APPROACH TO LEVEL OUT ALL
DEDUCTIBLES TWO ZERO. RELEASE
BELOW 4100% OF POVERTY AND
LOWER COPAYS FOR JUST SOME
INCOME LEVELS. EITHER OF THESE
OPTIONS WOULD GO JUST A REALLY
LONG WAY TOWARDS ENSURING
CALIFORNIANS CAN USE THEIR
HEALTH COVERAGE AND WILL ALSO
HELP ENCOURAGE. NEW PEOPLE TO
ENROLL WHO RIGHT NOW MIGHT BE
JUST HEARD WHEN THEY SEE
DEDUCTIBLES IN THE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. EITHER OPTION WOULD BE
FULLY FUNDED BY OUR EXISTING
STATE AFFORDABILITY
INVESTMENTS- COUPLED WITH JUST
SOME PORTION OF THE REVENUE
FROM THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
PENALTY. LOWER IN COST SHARING
IS A NEEDED STEP TO HELP
CONSUMERS ARE ALSO OTHER
OPTIONS AND STATE COULD PURSUE.
FOR EXAMPLE REDIRECTING STATE
SUBSIDIES TO ZERO OUT PREMIUMS
EARNED ZERO DEDUCTIBLES FOR
EVERYONE I'M SORRY YOUR OUT
PREMIUMS FOR EVERYONE MAKING
UNDER 2100% OF POVERTY- THIS
WOULD GO BEYOND THE NEW FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES AND PROVIDE MORE HELP
TO CALIFORNIANS WERE JUST ABOVE
THE MEDIC CAL THRESHOLD ON
THEIR PREMIUMS. FINALLY IS A
SEPARATE ISSUE WERE ALSO
CHAMPIONING A MODEST PROPOSAL
UNDER TO MAKE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THAT WOULD
OFFER TRUE. ZERO PREMIUMS IN
THE MARKETPLACE THAT IS ALL.
STATE SUBS TO COME THE ONE.
REMEMBER MONTH PREMIUM THAT IS
CURRENTLY. FOR STATE OR COVERS.
RESEARCHERS ON THE ANY PREMIUM
NO MATTER HOW SMALL DETERS
ENROLLMENT IN HEALTH PLANS.
THIS ONE DOLLAR PREMIUM ALSO
RESIDE IN MINISTRY TO FROM
BLACK THAT IS A CHALLENGE FOR
AUTO ENROLMENT TRANSITIONS
BETWEEN MEDIC HAL AND COVER
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA PROVIDED
PROOF OF CONCEPT FOR ADDITIONAL
PORTABILITY ASSISTANCE AND
WE'RE EXCITED THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN AGAIN TAKE A LEADERSHIP
ROLE. ESPECIALLY IN OUR HIGH
COST OF LIVING STATE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THEM TO
MOVE ON. WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. THIRTY POINT WHERE
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- I WILL BE COVERING
THAT THE QUESTION FEWEST REGARD
AFFECT- INCREASE THE COST
SHARING REDUCTION ON
ENROLLMENT- BUT IT HAS SHOWN
THAT HE AFTER PREMIUMS THE NEXT
MOST SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN
WHETHER SOMEONE WILL ENROLL IS
THAT OUT OF POCKET COSTS THAT
THE MORE SIGNIFICANT FACTOR
THAN WHAT BENEFITS ARE COVERED
WHETHER THERE'S AN INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE OR WHETHER THERE ARE
THE DOCTORS THAT THEY WANT TO
BE AVAILABLE IN THE NETWORK. IN
FACT. CORNIA PREVIOUSLY AB
EIGHTEEN AND WERE ALL. MOSCOW
ON THE TEN COREY FOR A COST
SHARING. THAT WOULD BE OUT OF
POCKET COSTS- AND HE'D SHOW A
BUMP IN ENROLLMENT NOT AS
SIGNIFICANT AS REDUCING
PREMIUMS. HOWEVER I THINK IT'S
A AT TO LOOK ONLY AT THE
INCREASE IN ENROLLMENT WHEN
LOOKING AT WHAT IT DOES TO
DECREASE OUT OF POCKET COSTS.
BECAUSE STUDIES ALSO SHOW THAT
WHEN PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD THE
COST OF THEIR CARE EVEN IF
THEY'RE COVERED THANK YOU LATE
THINKING TREATMENT THEY DON'T
GET PRESCRIPTION FILLED THEY
DELAYED PATH- AND OTHERWISE
JUST DON'T GET THE CARE THEY
NEED IN OTHER WORDS HIGH OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. THIRD THE
CONTENDED PURPOSE TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM GETTING CARE- WHAT
WHAT THE CONSUMER EXPERIENCE
ACTUALLY IS WITH. PAY A 100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. NOW
UNDER THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
THEY HAVE INCREDIBLY GENEROUS-
PREMIUM- EXPECTED CONTRIBUTION
OF THE PREMIUMS WHEN IT HAPPENS
YOU PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME BUT
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
SOMEBODY INCOME IS AT THAT RATE
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE FULL
TIME WORKERS UNDER THE CURRENT
MINIMUM WAGE. THEIR TAKE HOME
PAY IS DONE OVER A FEW THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
THAT'S GROSS BEFORE TAXES. EVEN
WITH CAPPING IT OUT 2% OF THEIR
INCOME WHILE FORTY DOLLARS MAY
NOT SEEM LIKE A LARGE PREMIUM
WHEN THEY LOOK AT WHAT THEY CAN
GET FOR FORTY THREE DOLLARS
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE THIRTY
SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE
AND BUSINESS WAYS COST SHARING
REDUCTION CURRENTLY THE
ENHANCE. THE OVER SEVENTY THREE
PLANTS- YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ARE
TRYING TO DECIDE WHETHER YOU
CAN ADD ANOTHER L. AFTER YOU
THINK ABOUT YOUR HOUSE BEING
YOUR FOOD IN YOUR
TRANSPORTATION AND THINGS THAT
YOU ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IT THEY ARE FLOATING
CALIFORNIA. CERTAINLY
HEALTHCARE START TO FEEL LIKE A
GAMBLE IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SHOULD I TAKE A FORTY TWO
DOLLAR MONTHLY BILL AND THEN I
KNOW WHEN IF I NEED TO GET THE
KING CARE I MAY BE FACED WITH A
DEDUCTIBLE THAT HIGHER THAN MY
MONTHLY INCOME. THAT FEELS LIKE
SILLY MONEY AND. NOT A GOOD
VALUE TO PEOPLE. NOW THIS IS A
CALL AND COVER CAL. OR HOW THIS
IS GOING WITH DESIGN TO WORK.
I'M INVOLVED IN THE PLAN TO
WITH COME CAL. TWENTY FOUR. AND
THAT'S FIRST FOURTEEN PLAN
THERE DID. FOR THIS GROUP OF.
WITH HUNDRED DOLLARS. THAT'S
LESS THAN HALF OF WHAT IT
CURRENTLY IS. BUT LIKE. IN CAL.
THAT HAVE GONE UP. ONLY THE
CALL GONNA EVEN. THE THEY HAVE
FOR HOW AND OTHER THINGS. SO
WHEN PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AFFECT.
THERE ARE OFTEN MADE RATIONAL
DECISION AND OTHER TODAY GOING.
CARE BECAUSE JUST CAN'T AFFORD
ENOUGH BELL OR THEIR- SEEING
THE BRONZE PLAN WHICH FOR MANY
OF THEM AT THE DOLLAR PLAN NOW.
AND THINKING OKAY I'LL GET THAT
DONE. BUT THEY NEVER PLANNED ON.
USING THEIR CARE. FOR A BIT
MORE CONSTRUCTIVE HE- PEOPLE
WHO ARE AT A HUNDRED AND THE
POVERTY LEVEL IF THEY HAVE KIDS
THEIR KIDS ARE LIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE AND UNDER MEDICARE WE
DON'T IMPOSE THESE KIND OF OUT
OF POCKET COSTS ALL OF THE
CARRIAGE GREET THE PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY GET THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS KAPPLER.
OCT BOB AND IT COMPARES LITTLE
BIT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
OVERWEIGHT- HE REALIZED FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR AND THE THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND THRESHOLD. WELL AND
THAT WILL YOU KNOW IF WE EVER
GET HER FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN AN
INCREASE IN MINIMUM WAGE TO
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR JUST
OVER. I'M ALLEVIATE INDIVIDUAL
THEY CAN'T GET THAT ENHANCE
OVER AND THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
ARE FACED WITH A FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE AND NOT ONLY
THAT IT. EXCEL PREMIUM. SO IN
SHORT WHILE THE M. RESCUE PLAN
HAS MADE HUGE AND SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS FOR CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING PREMIUMS AT THE PLATE
THAT PEOPLE COULD NOT ENVISION
PAYING- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY GET THE
CARE ONCE THERE AND ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
HERBERT. WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK
HERBERT WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY WE ARE A SMALL
BUSINESS EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND WILLIE WE
EXISTS TO HELP ENTREPRENEURS
TAKE THEIR NEXT UP ON THEIR
ENTREPRENEURIAL JOURNEY YOUR
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE OVER FOUR
MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES. FOUR
MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES I 99%
OF BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
SMALL. AND EMPLOYEE COSTS THE
WORK FORCE AND THE BUSINESS IS
CREATING MOST OF THE JOBS HAVE
LESS THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES. AND
THE REALLY TINY BUSINESSES-
EIGHT THAT WILL WITH LESS THAN
TEN EMPLOYEES CONSTITUTE 80% OF
ALL CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND
IT'S THESE REALLY SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE HAVING THE
MOST DIFFICULT TIME AFFORDING
INSURANCE IN THE SMALL GROUP
MARKET FOR THEMSELVES. AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES. ONLY ABOUT
HALF ARE ABLE TO DO SO. YOU TOO
ARE PULLING EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKETPLACE COVER CALIFORNIA
ANOTHER MARKET PLACES ACROSS
THE CROSS THE COUNTRY WERE
ESSENTIAL- FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. THEIR EMPLOYEES AND
SELF EMPLOYED ENTREPRENEURS WE
ESTIMATED THAT ROUGHLY HALF OF
ALL THE FOLKS. IN THE MARKET
PLACE I'M OR ONE OF THESE THREE
CATEGORIES. THAT'S ESPECIALLY
TRUE- AS SINCE CALIFORNIA'S
TAKING THE LEAD TO EXPAND
SUBSIDIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE AVERAGE IN MEDIAN INCOME
FOR SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WAS
AROUND IS AROUND SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WHICH PUTS THEM RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT FOUR
HUNDRED TO SIX ON A PERCENT
FPL- GAP THAT WHICH THE STATE
STEPPED IN TO FILL THE
AMERICAN. RECOVERY PLAN IS
HOUSE THAT DIDN'T DISPEL AND
OUT WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY. THE
EXPANSION OF SUBSIDIES TO MAKE
IT MORE AFFORDABLE FOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS HERE IN THE
STATE- WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
ACTORS HAVE A HUGE SAY IN HOW
AFFORDABLE COVERAGE CALIFORNIA
IS MOVING FORWARD. THAT'S
BECAUSE THE WHAT'S HAPPENED%
THIS PAST YEAR ACCORDING TO OUR
POLLING ROUGHLY THIRTY THREE
PERCENT. OF SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE REPORTED THAT THEY HAD TO
DROP. HEALTH INSURANCE WERE
REDUCED HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
AND THAT'S EVEN MORE ACUTE WHEN
WE TALKED ON SPLURGE COLOR
BETWEEN FORTY AND FIFTY
PERCENT. OF AHCH TOWARDS OF
COLOR HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
DROPPING HEALTH INSURANCE
BECAUSE THE CHALLENGE OF COST
OVER THIS PAST YEAR. AND EVEN
LOOKING FORWARD ROUGHLY 16% OF
BUSINESSES I THINKING THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE TO DO THAT- AND
AGAIN THAT IS EVEN MORE ACUTE.
FOR UNDER RESOURCE
ENTREPRENEURS ENTREPRENEURS OF
COLOR. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
ROUGHLY 60% OF SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE NOT RETURNED TO PRE
PANDEMIC EMPLOYEE LEVELS. SO
YOU HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO
STILL HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RETURN TO THEIR PLACE OF
BUSINESS THE POTENTIALLY BE
ABLE TO ACCESS SOME SORT OF
SMALL GROUP PLAN- AND THE LAST
PIECE OF INFORMATION THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL AS WE THINK
ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SUPPORTING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. IS WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN AN EXPLOSION OF
SMALL BUSINESS STARTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND OVER 20%
INCREASE FROM THE YEAR BEFORE-
AND SO WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE ENTREPRENEURS AS THEY
STARTED BUSINESSES AND PSYCHIC
BECOMES. A MORE. ROBUST
BUSINESS THAT'S ABLE TO
PROVIDING I'M- THOSE. ARE ABLE
ACCESS AND AFFORDABLE QUALITY
HEALTH INSURANCE. THROUGH
COVERED HEALTH. EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDA. SMALL BUSINESSES IN
OXNARD TRYING TO STAKE IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET AND COVER
CALIFORNIA PANDEMICS MADE EVEN
MORE CHALLENGING FOR REALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE
THAT SMALL GROUP COVERAGE- AND
WITH NEW BUSINESS STARTS COMING
INTO THE MARKETPLACE IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE A ROBUST
IN INCREDIBLY AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE ARE COVERED
CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE SO. SHE
GOT RICH DANTE SHARE THE SMALL
BIZ RESPECTIVE AND- PICTURE
TIME. I THINK US DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ANYTHING UNLESS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. OKAY THE L. A. O.
FIVE VAN JOHNSON WITH THE L. A.
O. JUST QUICKLY NOTE THAT AS
THE AGENDA AND THE SPEAKERS
HAVE HAVE SHARED- THAT THE NEW
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES AVAILABLE
UNDER THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
TO USE FULLY SUBSUMES- THE
STATE PROGRAM AT LEAST FOR MOST
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND PART
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO PRESENTING
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT I THINK A LOT
OF THE ADVOCATES OF SPOKEN UP
TODAY- FURTHER ENHANCING- THE
STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM THROUGH
LOWERING PREMIUMS DEDUCTIBLES
AND SO FORTH. OR ACTUALLY ALSO
TO RE DIRECTING THIS GENERAL
FUND FUNDING CURRENTLY
ALLOCATED TO THE STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM TO OTHER PURPOSES
THAT'S ALL THANK YOU OKAY IS L.
A. O. HAVE A POSITION ON- ON
THE- FRONT. APPS NOT WE WOULD
SAY THAT THAT IS CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATURE'S PREROGATIVE JUST
THAT- JUST THAT YOU HAVE
FLEXIBILITY BEFORE YOU IN WHICH
DECISION THAT YOU MAKE. OKAY M.
BACK TO- BUT CLINTON IN A FOR
SECOND THE COVER CALIFORNIA. DO
I MEAN DO THE NUMBERS I'M I'M
THINKING REALLY PAN OUT THAT
THE HIGHER THE DEDUCTIBLE THE
LESS CARE AT THAT IS YOU
UTILIZED. YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE
DATA AT MY FINGERTIPS ON ON
THAT TO PROVIDE TO YOU. THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH- THE STAFF ON
OKAY AND I'D LOVE TO SEE THAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR. A COUPLE
QUESTION FIRST ABOUT COVERED
CALIFORNIA SO WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF. PEOPLE SAYING FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY SIGNED FOR
THE BRONZE PLAN. AND I WISH I
HAD THAT AT MY FINGER TIPS AS
WELL- WE WILL CERTAINLY FOLLOW
UP. UNDER UNDER THIRD I WOULD
SAY OKAY BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT- CERTAIN ABOUT
ANY SO FIRST OF ALL REALLY
HAPPY THAT THIS IS THAT THE
FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT STEPPING
AND- I AGAIN I WANT TO POINT
OUT AND DAY COVERED CALIFORNIA
WITH OUR WITH OUR OWN STATE
SUBSIDIES. TO DATE FOR TWO
YEARS IN A ROW- THE AVERAGE
PREMIUM INCREASE TO COVER
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN UNDER 1% TWO
YEARS IN A ROW WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IS THIRD YEAR-
HOPEFULLY WITH- WITH THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN BILL WILL
CONTINUE. THAT TREND WILL
CONTINUE. SO IN TERMS OF FORD
ABILITY I THINK ONE OF THE
MAJOR THINGS IS ACTUALLY BE
SURE EVERYONE'S IN THE POOL-
THE RESULTS ASKING OXYGEN
BRONZE PLAN IS BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW WHAT QUALITY CONCERNS IS
THAT WE PROBABLY SHOULD. I MEAN
THE BRONZE PLAN I KNOW IT'S
THEIR ACTUAR RATES ARE UP BUT
THE COAT YOU KNOW THE
DISCUSSION IS VERY HIGH. HE
KEEPS THE PREMIUMS LOW BUT WE
PARTICULARLY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS OR OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS ACTUALLY- LOOKING AT THE
BRONZE PLANS THEY WILL HAVE
SOMEONE I CAN AFFORD BUT THEN
FINDING OUT THEY CAN'T. YOU
KNOW THE COST SHARING SO HIGH
THAT THEY ACTUALLY CAN GET
SERVICES THEY NEED ESPECIALLY
FOR ON GOING HEALTHCARE SO. THE
DEGREE THAT WE CAN INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE AND MAKE THE SILVER PLAN
OR THE OTHER PLANS MORE
COMPETITIVE THE BRONZE PLAN I
THINK IT'S- WOULD WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL AND I KNOW THE ANY
COMMENTS ABOUT THAT. CALL
CALIFORNIA. I JUST ADD BULK OF
OUR ENROLLMENTIS IN THE
SUBURBS. OKAY GNL. OF THAT
FEDERAL COST SHARING SUBSIDIES
IN THAT PLAN. AND IN GENERAL WE
DO. ADVERTISE AND DO OUR EACH
OUR MEMBERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANYONE WHO IS ELIGIBLE FOR COST
SHARING REDUCTIONS USES THE
SILVER PLANS VERY IMPORTANT TO
US OBVIOUSLY IS THAT OUR
MEMBERS CAN TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE
OF THE FEDERAL BENEFITS. BOTH
ON THE PREMIUM SIDE IN THE
CRUSHING SIDE. OKAY EXCELLENT
AND THEN I DON'T KNOW THE YOU
HAVE THE ANSWER THE QUESTION OR
ACCESS FINANCE SO THE SUBSIDIES
FOR THE AMERICAN RESCUE. PLAN
HOW LONG DO THEY LAST FOR. THE
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES LAST THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THERE'S A
SPECIAL BENEFIT ALSO FOR
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IT'S
JUST FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ALL
RIGHT SO THIS I MEAN THIS
LITERALLY IS ONLY FOR A YEAR.
SO SO I'VE I GUESS WE JUST THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S NEED TO KEEP THAT
IN MIND I KNOW THAT WHEN WE-
FUNDED THE STATE'S OF THESE
WATER THINGS YOU WANNA TRY TO
DO IS- NOT HAVE PEOPLE SIGN UP
FOR A PLAN AND HAVE YOU KNOW
THE SUBSIDY. GOING BACK IN FOR
HIM CERTAINLY YEAH WE WANNA BE
SURE THAT PEOPLE GET SEVENTIES
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN BUT IF
THAT EXPIRES AND CONGRESS IS
NOT ABLE TO EXTEND IT. WE MAY
HAVE TO STEP BACK IN- WITH OUR
SUBSIDY I'D HATE FOR US TO FALL
OFF A CLIFF THERE. AND SO JUST
IN TERMS OF LONGER TERM
PLANNING- I'M HOPING THAT WE
BUILDING WE'RE BUILDING THAT
OUT IN THE OUT YEARS THAT- IN
CASE THAT HAPPENS THAT PART WE
RESUME OUR STATE SUBSIDIES SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT. EXPERIENCE I DON'T
PEOPLE SIGNING UP FOR THE
PLANET SOMEBODY HAVING SOME OF
THESE YANKED OUT FROM UNDER
THEM. AND IF I NEED TO DO I
COMMENT ON THAT. THANK YOU
MADISON CHAPEL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FOR CERTAINLY- AWARE
OF THAT- ISSUE THAT THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. IS ONLY
I'M HERNANDEZ ON SUBSIDIES FOR
COVERAGE YOU'RE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND CREDIT YOUR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND CERTAINLY
HONEST ENOUGH THAT SAID THANK
YOU. OKAY YEAH I THINK IT'S A
DIVORCE IT'S NOT JUST THE MONEY
PART IT'S THE MESSAGING. OUT TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE SIGNING UP FOR
COVERED CALIFORNIA. AND THAT-
WITH THAT- YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
ALWAYS PAYING ATTENTION WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON IF I
HAVE TO ASK HERE WHAT THE DATE
IS I CAN IMAGINE THE GENERAL
PUBLIC DOESN'T KNOW AND SO WE
WANT TO BE SURE THAT AS WE'RE
SIGNING PEOPLE UP AND I KNOW
COVER CALIFORNIA DOES A GOOD
JOB AND EDUCATE PEOPLE. THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT SO
THAT DAYS SO THAT WE DON'T GET
PEOPLE COTTON- IN A BIND OR-
YOU'LL HAVE PEOPLE TELLING
OTHER PEOPLE THAT YOU CAN'T YOU
KNOW THEY CAN'T TRUST COVERED
CALIFORNIA OR THE STATE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY SAID ONE
THING AND NOW I FOUND MYSELF IN
A DIFFERENT SITUATION. AND SO
FORTH. OKAY THANK YOU. AND DO
WE HAVE THE- IF THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. OR- MISTER BELL DO WE
HAVE THE FULL COST THAT IT
WOULD BE TO PAY FROM THE SILVER
FROM SOBRE DOWN I GUESS. ALL
THE OUT OF POCKET. DO WE KNOW
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE IF-
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLANS GONNA
DO THIS PART AND NOW WE'RE
GONNAHAVE WHAT WE WOULD
USUALLY PAY DO WE KNOW. THE
PRICE ON THAT. MASSENGILL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
APOLOGIES WE DO NOT HAVE THAT
I'M NOT. CERTAIN IF- ONE OF
THE- PEOPLE WHO SPOKE ON THAT
PROPOSAL MAY. BE ABLE TO.
COMMENT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER OKAY. VISITING SOMEBODY
CAN GET THAT FOR US GOING
FORWARD. WE CAN CERTAINLY GET
OUT TO YES OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY OKAY IF THERE'S
NOTHING FURTHER WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR FINAL ITEM HOSPITAL
DISCHARGE DATA SHARING. OKAY
KATIE RAVEL AGAIN COVER
CALIFORNIA IS REQUESTING A
STATUTORY CHANGE TURNTABLE THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT SHARE
HOSPITAL DISCHARGE DATA
DIRECTLY WITH US AS IT
CURRENTLY DOES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THROUGH OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH ASHTON THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WE HAVE USED THE STATE
AND PRIOR YEARS CHEN FORMER
ANNUAL RENEGOTIATION PROCESS OF
OUR HEALTH PLANS. AS BACKGROUND
EACH YEAR COVER CALIFORNIA
NEWLY ENROLLS ABOUT ONE THIRD
OF OUR MEMBERSHIP. OF THE
HOSPITAL DISCHARGE DATA
PROVIDES COVER CALIFORNIA'S
CRITICAL INSIGHT INTO THE
HEALTH STATUS OF OUR NEW
ENROLLEES WHICH WE USED TO TURN
IN TURN. OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE NEXT YEAR'S PREMIUMS ARE
PRICED IN LINE WITH THE BEST
ESTIMATE OF HOW MUCH HEALTH
CARE NEW ROLE IS FLASHING NEED.
FOR CALIFORNIANS THE STATE AS
RECENTLY AS TWENTY TWENTY TO
SHOW THEY DIDN'T ALWAYS WHO
SIGNED UP DURING OUR CODE
NINETEEN SEP WERE ACTUALLY
LOWER RISK THAN THOSE THAT
SIGNED UP EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
AND AGAIN THIS IS A POWERFUL
TOOLS YOU NEGOTIATE WITH OUR
HEALTH PLANS. AS I NOTED A
MOMENT AGO IN PRIOR YEARS FOR
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS DATA THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS- BUT BECAUSE THIS
ANALYSIS HAS BECOME A KEY PART
OF OUR HEALTH PLAN ASSOCIATIONS
WERE REQUESTING THROUGH THIS
PROPOSAL DIRECT ACCESS TO THE
DATA. IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE THE
BURDEN ON OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
TO ENSURE THE FLASH AND COVER
CALIFORNIA CAN THAT AFFECTIVELY
PLAN FOR REGULAR DELIVERY AT
THE DATA OFF. UNDER THE
PROPOSAL COVER CALIFORNIA WILL
COMPLY WITH THE PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY GUARANTEES THAT
APPLY TO THE COMPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WITH THE USE OF THIS DATA. A
SIMILARLY WILL COMPLY WITH ANY
REQUIREMENTS AT THE STATE
COMMITTEE FOR PROTECTION OF
HUMAN SUBJECTS. ARE RELATED TO
THIS TO THE USE OF THIS DATA I
WOULD ALSO ADD THAT PER
CALIFORNIA AS AN EXCHANGE
ESTABLISHED UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IS. SUBJECT
TO RIGOROUS PRIVACY AND
SECURITY CONTROLS AND AUDITS
THESE FEDERAL STANDARDS SPECIFY
HUNDREDS OF PRIVACY AND
SECURITY REQUIREMENTS WE MUST
ABIDE BY IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CONFIDENTIALITY AND INTEGRITY
OF PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE.
INFORMATION THAT WE PROCESS.
FINALLY THIS. AND CARACALLA.
WILL THE AND THE- WITH REPORT
DETAILING THE IMPACT. OF TRUCK.
ON CAL AND- THE IMPACT ON OUR
HEALTH PLAN. IN THAT WOULD BE.
BY AUGUST OF TWENTY TWO THREE.
CONCLUSORY PRESENTE ON ITEM TO
I'D BE HAPPY TO KEEP. YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR IN
FINANCE ANYTHING ON THIS ONE.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR NO
COMMENT ON THIS THANK YOU. OKAY
A DOCTOR PAN. BELIAU ANYTHING
I'M SORRY MR JOHNSON. OKAY WELL
I THINK THAT WILL CONCLUDE THEN.
THIS PART OF THE HEARING AND I
WANT TO THANK MISTER BELL FOR
BEING HERE AND- DEPARTMENT
FINANCING THE L. A. O. AND I
BELIEVE NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO-
PUBLIC COMMENTS- IF WE COULD.
LOOK TO ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. THERE ARE
NOT THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE CAN BEGIN.
AND PLEASE TELL ME IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO JOIN THE QUEUE ONCE
AGAIN TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN THE QUEUE.
FIRST CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL
START WITH NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU DR
AND THEN ADMIN UNLOCKED OF HAND
AND GAVE THE ACT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HERE TO SPEAK TO
THE AUSTIN PUBLIC HEALTH
RELATED BUDGET PROPOSAL. UNDER
ISSUE ONE POINT IN THE COMING
UP PUBLIC HEALTH WE DO ALSO
URGED THE SENATE INCLUDED I'M
GOING TO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT FINALLY
WE BUILD OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH STAFFING INFRASTRUCTURE.
SECOND UNDERGONE SPENT ON ISSUE
TOO WITH THE CREATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESSAND INFORMATION WE
APPRECIATE THE OPENING VERSION
OF THE DEPARTMENT KALI TAXING
AND ALSO APPRECIATE
SECTOR-LIMóN FOR COMMENTS.
REGARDING ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. I'M READING THAT
PBL WE DO WE THAT WORK FORCE ME.
AND BAKER BE MORE INCREASE IN
THE ALLIED HEALTH WORKFORCE
PROJECT. ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
REQUIRE THAT ALL TEN THE NEW
THE- CREATE NEW WORK FOR
DEVELOP. HI FRANK- RAM FIFTY
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SIMILARLY ON THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE SIDE- LAST UNDER
ISSUE THREE WITH THE CREE OF
OFFICE HEALTH CARE. YEAH AFTER
MUCH OF WHAT OUR LABOR
FEDERATION PARTNER HAD
MENTIONED. IN A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY PROTECT AND PROMOTE
OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
ABILITY INTRIGUED ME AND ALSO
IN THE WAY THAT FACTORED IN
EXISTING COLLECTIVE. COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT OKAY JOB
THOSE GOOD MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
WITH HIGHLY SKILLED
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE VALUE WE
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THE
COST SAVINGS ARE THEN SHARED
ONE WORKER. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
ENSURE THAT COST SAVINGS
TRICKLE DOWN TO WORKERS. AT THE
PUMP THE SHAREHOLDERS FOUR
YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE
NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SENATOR
ADMITTED MEMBERS IN THIS NGUYEN
THOSE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS.
TODAY THE COMMITTEE TACKLED
SEVERAL SEVERAL VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES FINANCING AFFORDABILITY
PROMOTING HEALTH EQUITY IN
QUALITY AND EXPANDING COVERAGE.
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH PLAN
BILLION VIEWS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT GOALS SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS DISCUSSED TODAY WILL
TAKE MORE DISCUSSION AND WORK
ON ENSURING EFFECTIVENESS AND
FEASIBILITY. WE HAVE PROVIDED
FEEDBACK ON SOME OF THE
CRITICAL ISSUES ON THE AGENDA
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
A PART OF THE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD. AND HOPE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CONTINUED
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK MOVING
FORWARD AS WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I THINKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
BIGGER ISSUE TO UNDER
OSTENSIBLY CAPTAIN ACOSTA BUT
PART MEDICAL CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION. AS WE WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION COMMITTEE
TREATING THE REVISED ONE OF
ENSURE THAT THE COUNCIL REFLECT
PRIMARY CARE NEEDS OF PRIMARY
CARE REPRESENTATION WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THE CRITERIA FOR
FUNDING RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAMS REFLECT THE STATE
CONTRACTED TO SUPPORT A PRIMARY
CARE WORKFORCE. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THE COMMITTEE ON THE ISSUE AND
PUTTING HAPPEN TO HELP NURSING
WE PARTNERSHIP IN RESPONSE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PANEL BEER IN
SUPPORT OF THE REQUEST OF THE
ON GOING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES. DELIVER
CRITICAL HOME VISITING SERVICES
TO LOW INCOME AFRICAN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
EZCORP PLEASE. WELL NOW GO
NUMBER ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BREXIT I WILL BE COMMENTING
TONIGHT ON TWO ISSUES DISCUSSED
AT THE HEARING TODAY FIRST ON
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY I'M REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS. MEMBERS INCLUDE COUNTY
AFFILIATED SYSTEM AND THE FIVE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER YOU
GOTTA BEAT THE SOME FORM THE
CORE OF THE STATE'S HEALTH CARE
TAKING THAT DESPITE
REPRESENTING JUST 6% OF ALL
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE PTH
MEMBERS PROVIDE 40% OF ALL
HOSPITAL CARE TO CALIFORNIANS
REMAIN UNINSURED. AND 35% OF
ALL HOSPITAL CARE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AND THE COMMUNITY
THEY START AT TWENTY ONE PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYTEM SERVES TWO
POINT EIGHT FIVE MILLION
PATIENTS ANNUALLY AND PROVIDE
MORE THAN TEN MILLION OUT.
PATIENT VISITS EACH YEAR THEY
OPERATE MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S TOP LEVEL BURN AND
TRAUMA CENTERS AND TRAIN HALF
OF ALL NEW DOCTORS AND
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE WHICH
ARE VERY COSTLY- OPERATIONS
PUBLIC HOSPITAL SHARE MANY OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL THE
PATIENT CONCERNS I WANTED TO BE
SURE THAT EFFORT TO CONTAIN
COSTS. DON'T HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES PARTICULAR
HOSPITAL OPERATING ON THIN
MARGINS THE AUTHORITY WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND AN
ADMINISTRATION ON THE PROPOSAL
SECOND ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT I
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
ONGOING FUNDING OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
AND A PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
STUDY- I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN STAFF WITH A ONE TIME
FUNDING OR LIMITED TERM
POSITION ON GOING FUNDING AND
VITAL FOR BOLSTERING PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT NUMBER A- PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN TO MADDEN NINE COMMON
FOR TWO CLIENTS ON TO CONDITION
AND WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
IN LESS THAN TWO MINUTES. FIRST
COME INTO BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS. EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS ARE CONCERNED WITH
THE STRUCTURE OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY HAS
PROPOSED IN THE TRAILER
LANGUAGE FROM LAUNCH PAD. IN
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. AS WELL AS
AN EIGHTY ELEVEN THIRTY
SPECIFICALLY WITH ESTABLISHING
COST TARGETS BY SECTOR OR
REGION. FOR PROVIDERS TO MEET
OR SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS.
IMPOSSIBLE ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES. LOANS TO CONDITIONS
ARE VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION
AND OFFICE SPACE PROVIDERS OR
EVEN HOSPITALS- WHEN SCHEDULED
ELECTIVE PROCEDURES. EMERGENCY
POSITION HAVE NO CONTROL WHO CO
WHO COMES IN. AND THEY ARE ONLY
FOCUSED ON TREATING THE PATIENT
WHO IS EXPERIENCING AN
EMERGENCY- ABILITY TO CONTROL
COSTS AND OUTCOMES IS ACTUALLY
DIFFERENT THAN OTHER PROVIDERS.
TO SUBJECT EMERGENCY POSITIONS
TO COST TARGETS OF POSSIBLE
PENALTIES DOES NOT SEEM
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH THEY
PRACTICE. WE DO BELIEVE DATA
COMING OUT OF THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT IS A POINT ANALYZED.
AS IT REFLECTS FAILURES OTHER
PARTS OF THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
SHE WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
KEEP THESE COMMENTS IN MIND. AS
THE TRAILER LANGUAGE IS FURTHER
DEVELOPED AND WHEN YOU ARE
POSSIBLY SEE AB. ELEVEN THIRTY
IN THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
THE SECOND ISSUE I'M CALLING ON
IS FOR THE- CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN OF CARDIOLOGY. ISSUE
ONE FOR A SPENDING TRAILER LEGO
TRUCKS THE OUTCOME REPORTING
FOR CARDIAC PROCEDURES
CURRENTLY HOSPITALS AND CARDIAC
SURGEONS ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT
OUTCOMES. FOR CORONARY ARTERY
BYPASS GRAFT SURGERIES FOR MANY
TIMES REFERRED TO AS CABBAGE
pARE SPREAD LANGUAGE WOULD
EXPAND THE REPORTING TO ANY
CARDIAC PROCEDURE. THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT NEW GOING FROM ONE
PROCEDURE REQUIRED ACCORDING TO
AN UNLIMITED NUMBER. ASIAN HAS
A NUMBER OF MEMBERS ON THE
ADVISORY PANEL FOR CABBAGE
REPORTING IN ARE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THIS PROGRAM WE ARE
REVIEWING THE TRAIL LANGUAGE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CANADIAN OSTAD ON
PROVIDING FEEDBACK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MAD MEX
COLOR PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEGAN TWO BIRDS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATE THEN I'LL
PICK TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO UNDER
US PET. PARTNERS HEALTH CARE
ACT AT THE INFORMATION. HE HAD
A LONG HISTORY OF PARTNERING
WITH JOSH HAD BEEN READERSHIP
AND STAFF AND IT MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN HEALTH CARE WORK
FORCE TO COLLECTION AND
BUILDING STANDARDS. BURKE
BLIGHTED AN OPTIMISTIC THAT
THEY THREE FOCUSED BUT NOT THE
NEW ERA OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THE PROJECT REALLY
GLAD TO SEE THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES AFFIRMATION OF
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION
RECOMMENDATION. THANKS SO MUCH
TO BE DONE TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH WORKFORCE
CRISIS IN MY GUARANTEED THAT
EVERY STATE DEPARTMENT. IT'S
GROUNDED AN EQUITY LINE-
COMMITTEE TO STRAY HOW WORK FOR
THE DAY TO. IMPORT CENTRALIZING
ARE PRO AFTER FROM THE AT
LOOTING J. Y. VISA. IS
IMPORTANT. THE CHANGES WILL NOT
BE SUFFICIENT OVERCOME THE
CAPTAIN AND INEQUITIES OF OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
TODAY. BUT DEEPER ANALYSIS IS
NEEDED TO TAKE THE FULL BREADTH
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS AND
ACT APPROPRIATE ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE NEW
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE MUST ALSO
GUARANTEED THE STRIDES MADE
OSTEND OR NOT LOCKED IN THIS
INCLUDE GUARANTEEING COMMUNITY.
REPRESENTATION AND DECISION
MAKING ON WORK FORCE FUNDING
SUCH AS RESIDENCY PROGRAM
SCHOLARSHIPS. AND LOAN
REPAYMENT TO ENSURE REPORT THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO THE
INSTITUTIONS AND PROVIDERS THAT
ARE SERVING THE MOST HARD TO
REACH. DIRECTLY MARGINALIZED
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PERSONS OF
COLOR COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE OFTEN SERVED BY
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AS THE PROPOSAL
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GOD. GOOD EVENING CARE EGGMAN
AND DOCTOR PAN I AM SPEAKING TO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE UNDER FORTY TO
SIXTY FIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH MY NAME IS STACY
YOU'RE A MODEL I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES COALITION OR
RUN CO CO SPONSOR OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL YOU SHOULD STAINED AND
EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. OR C. R.
D. P. THE C. R. D. P. ISN'T
JUST ABOUT EXTENDING THE
CURRENT PILOT PROJECT BUT ABOUT
USING THIS MODEL AS PROOF OF
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF USING
COMMUNITY DEFINED PRACTICES OR
CDS IN REACHING AND SERVING
UNDERSERVED RACIAL ETHNIC AND
LGBTQ COMMUNITIES. THE C. R. D.
P. ALSO ILLUSTRATES THE
IMPORTANCE AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
CONTRACTING AND FUNDING SMALLER
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT FOCUS ON PARTICULAR
UNDERSERVED RACIAL ETHNIC AND
LGBTQ HEALTH G. B. T. Q. PLUS
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE ALREADY
LOCATED IN AND TRUSTED BY
PEOPLE FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
MUST BE COMMENDED FOR
ADMINISTERING THIS PROJECT AND
TAKING THE TIME TO CONTRACT
WITH AT LEAST THIRTY FIVE SUCH
SMALL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SPECIALIZE
IN SERVING PARTICULAR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
THIS PROJECT. YOU HAVE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THESE
ORGANIZATIONS WERE ABLE TO
PRESENT AND CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE AND CULTURALLY IS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO PEOPLE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES DURING THE
CALL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THEY WERE ALSO ABLE TO PROVIDE
SUCH SERVICES DURING THE UNREST
AND RACIAL RECKONING DUE TO
POLICE KILLINGS OF BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE WE HOPE TO SEE RT
HE IS EXTENDED AND FUNDED FOR
FOUR MORE YEARS. BRENCKLE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
SUPPORT THE TESTIMONY GIVEN BY
RON COLEMAN OF C. TEN UNDER THE
SAME ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY ALWAYS TO HEAR FOR YOU
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. NEXT TO
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MCCARTY DELGADO
WILL BE HAPPY TO DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUMS HERE
WITH A COMMENT ON THE- OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
ISSUE THREE- IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME IT'S SIMPLY LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR CURRENT CONCERNS AND
COMMENTS BUT BOTH OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED THE SPECIAL AT THE
MEASURE. THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ONE FORTY ONE LINE IS
OPEN. MEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL HEALTH PLAN
THE CALIFORNIA SPEAKING UNDER
ISSUE ONE HUNDRED THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE- ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL HEALTH CLINICS PLEASE
MAKE COLLEGE PC SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION FOCUS ON
HEALTH EQUITY PUT CORD IN THE
ANNUAL HEALTHCARE SERVICE PLAN-
HELD AT GREEN QUALITY REVIEW
PROPOSAL BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE PROCESS AND TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTING A STATEWIDE EQUITY
APPROACH SHOULD FIRST FOCUS ON
IDENTIFYING. GAPS AND NEEDS AND
ENSURING WE HAVE THE FOUNDATION
TO SUCCESSFULLY MEASURE
OUTCOMES FOR THE POPULATION WE
SERVE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FINE TUNE
THE TYPICAL COLLECTED MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LOOKS COLOR PLEASE.
NEXT WE NUMBER ONE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GIVE AT. WE ARE WORKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE CLOSED UNLESS
AMENDED TO- OFFSET ISSUE NUMBER
THREE THE OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY BOTH THE CONFINES
ON AUSTIN. AND AT ELEVEN THIRTY
WELL WE AGREE WITH MANY OF THE
GOALS OF THE AFFORDABILITY
PROPOSAL THEY ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW IT'S
WRITTEN THAT COULD IMPACT
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY CARE AND
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. THAT'S
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF DRUG
TREATMENT APPROVED TWO YEARS
AGO TO TURN OFTEN FATAL MUSCLE
WASTING CONDITION INTENT OCT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS PER CHILD
TO ADMINISTER. OUR PATIENTS ARE
ENTITLED TO RECEIVE REATMENT
LIKE THAT UNDER BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW BUT JUST A HANDFUL
OF CASES A YEAR AT A COST COULD
EASILY PUSH A CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OR THEIR SECTOR OVER A
COSTS ARE GET. WILL BE OFFICE
BE EMPOWERED TO ESTABLISH THE
COVERS FOR NEW HIGH COST
TREATMENTS LIKE THIS ONE WHAT A
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL BE EXPECTED
TO SEEK APPROVAL BEFORE
ADMINISTERING ANY TREATMENT.
WOULD THEY BE REQUIRED TO OFFER
IT WITHOUT KNOWING IF THEY BE
PENALIZED AFTER THE FACT WILL
THEY BE EXPECTED TO LIMIT
ACCESS TO COSTLY TREATMENTS
LIKE THIS ONE IN ORDER TO STAY
WITHIN THEIR TARGET. WILL STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW THE ADJUSTED TO
MAKE THAT IND OF RATIONING
LEGAL. NONE OF THESE QUESTIONS
ARE CURRENTLY ANSWERED BY
EITHER PROPOSAL BUT WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ADDRESS QUESTIONS LIKE THESE IN
THE COMING WEEKS PROVIDE
CERTAINTY FOR CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS AND OUR PATIENT A
DIFFICULT THE WON'T LIMIT LIMIT
ACCESS TO MEDICALLY NECESSARY
AND LIFE SAVING CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE NUMBER
ALLOW. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IN
BREAKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT CALLING IN REGARD TO
THE OFFICE OF AFFORDABILITY WE
SHARE THE COMMON SEVEN ARE
SUPPORTED OF THOSE COMMENTS
PRESENTED BY THE CAPTAIN
HOSPITAL'S DECISION ON THE
ISSUE I'M NOT HARD TO WORKING
THAT WAY V. COMMITTEE AND HER
NUMBER WOULD ON THE ISSUE
FURTHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO A NUMBER ONE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- TREE STARK WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE HEY UNDER THE
OSHKOSH ITEMS TODAY WE ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
TO ESTABLISH THE OPPOSITE
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY AND
THE RELATED POLICY BILLS. HI TO
PERMANENTLY VERY COMMITTED TO
AFFORDABILITY CAN WE ACTUALLY
DO BELIEVE IN THE CONCEPT AND
COULD BE DEPORTED WE ARE SIMPLY
SEEKING AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
INTEGRATED DELIVERY SYSTEMS IN
ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF THE
BILL. UNFORTUNATELY THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU FLIPPING
MESSAGES ON ONE HAND THE BILL
CALLS FOR A MOVE AWAY FROM
COPLEY AND FRAGMENTED FEE FOR
SERVICE CARE AND AWAY FROM HERE
THAT WILL WORK VOLUMES AND NOT
VALUE AND IT ALSO PROMOTES THE
ADOPTION OF NON CLAIMS BASED
PAYMENT MODELS THAT REWARD
EFFICIENT HIGH QUALITY CARE.
AND YET ON THE OTHER HAND THE
BILL DISREGARD THE VALUE THAT
FULLY INTEGRATED SYSTEM
PROVIDES BY NOT PERMITTING ME
OFF WITH TO ESTABLISH A TOP
TARGET USING A TOTAL COST OF
CARE METRIC AND THIS MAKES VERY
LITTLE SENSE IT JUST REINFORCES
THE HEALTH CARE SILOS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE TODAY AND WILL
DISCONTENT INVITED BE DEFICIENT
PAYMENT MODELS. BY FORCING
INTEGRATED SYSTEMS TO BE HELP
YOU FACTORS THAT THAT THAT
TARGET INSTEAD OF BEING
MEASURED ON A GLOBAL BASIS WE
CONTINUE TO BE PUZZLED BY THE
INHERENT CONFLICT IN THE BILL
GIVEN THE STATED GOAL. AND
FINALLY WE ARE ALSO TROUBLED BY
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SOME CREDITS ADDITION
GROUPS TO SUBMIT VERY SENSITIVE
FINANCIAL STATEMENT TO THE
OFFICE. THIS INFORMATION IS
CONFIDENTIAL WILL NOT BE
RELEVANT TO THE WORK IN THE
OFFICE AND IF MADE PUBLIC COULD
BE DETRIMENTAL TO THOSE WHO
WORK IN OUR MEDICAL GROUP. IF
NOT REMOVED THIS PROVISION
COULD RESULT IN THE RELEASE OF
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION AND
HAVE ANTI COMPETITIVE IMPACT WE
DO APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY A WEEK FROM HER WITH
A NUMBER OF THE OTHER CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
DISCUSSION WE BELIEVE THIS
PROPOSAL. IS NOT QUITE COOKED
IN NEEDS MORE WORK BUT IT IS A
WORTHWHILE EFFORT AND WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO ADULT.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE LEDGE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO COLOR. WELL NOW GO
TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION IS LIVE YOU AND
INTERESTED LEARNING I AM- THANK
YOU FOR- ALLOWING THE- I AM ONE
OF THE THIRTY. A QUICK
CALIFORNIA REDUCING VERY
PROGRAM- GRANT SHE IF WE ARE IN
L. A. COUNTY WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH IS
BILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE
DETENTION. EARLY INTERVENTION
BUT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE MINE AND
LIKE ALL OF THE OTHER- FOR
OTHER PROJECTS- IN PROGRAM. AND
POLICIES R. D. T. BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO BILL MEDICARE.
AND AS A RESULT WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO OBTAIN INDEPENDENT. FROM OUR
COUNTY. WE CAN FIRE CONTINUES
SERVICE BEGAN ON. OF DEAL AND
THE CONTROL FUND. WE AND THE
OTHER. PARTICULARLY IN L. A.
COUNTY- WE ARE THE ONES DON'T
WANT THE GROUND A GREAT THE
MENTAL HEALTH IT'S VERY. LITTLE
WONDER ON IN A DRESS HAVE
COMPETENT PRACTICE. BECAUSE L.
A. COUNTY- DOES NOT GOING TO BE
OF COUPLE BECOME TO BE KNOWN
HEALTH EXPERIENCES. HELLO FOR
EXAMPLE- ARTICULAR COMMUNITIES.
BIND W. TO PRACTICE. A SONG
WRITING AND YOU. ALL PEOPLE TO
AND BOND. TO FIND TRAUMA WHERE
YOU USUALLY GET WHEN. ME HEY IS
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE AT ISSUES ON
THE LINE IN THE ARE IN THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF IT SO WE ARE
HERE TO HELP COULD WHO NEEDS
ARE NOT AT. A FIVE COUNTY
MIDDLE- KICK IN THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEM
AND THEM BY THE MIDDLE SYSTEM
AND THEY ARE CAN ON YOU TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY MENTAL NEEDS
GOING TO BE AT AND I THINK ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE IN ALL
OF THE OTHERS. POPULATION
HEALTH A. B. I KNOW KNOW G. P.
YOU KNOW OF COLOR WILLIAMS. AND
YEAH WE ADDRESS. OUR PARTICULAR
CAR. AND THEY ARE NOT MET THE
BILL OF THE THAT COME DOWN THE
STATE OF CONVENTIONAL. CENTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE ONE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOAL BOUND I'M SPEAKING
TO ISSUE ONE UNDERSCORE TWO SIX
FIVE I'M A SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT GENDER
SPECTRUM ONE OF THE THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CONSTITUTE
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT
UNPRECEDENTED INITIATIVES
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING THE HEALTH
OF MARGINALIZD CALIFORNIA. NOW
IN ITS FIFTH YEAR THIS PRODUCT
IS DEMONSTRATING INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL RESULTS WITHIN THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. HOWEVER
STARTED ONE YOUNG PERSON ELLIE
YOU MAKE THREE YEAR OLD
TRANSGENDER YOUNG MAN I'M
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
PARTICIPATING ON A RECENT PANEL
GENDER SPECTRUM HELD AS PART OF
A SCHOOL TRAINING WE WERE
FACILITATING. AN INCREDIBLY
ARTICULATE AND CHARMING YOUNG
MAN. SENIOR I DON'T CRY FOR
HUMANS LIKELY BE JOINING SOME
OF YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE AT
SOME POINT SOON. DURING THE
PANEL ELOISE SHARED THAT HE HAD
NO SUPPORT AT HOME WHEN A
CARETAKER IS GENDER AND IN FACT
REGULARLY FACED HURTFUL
COMMENTS FROM THE VERY PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH THIS CARE. IT'S
BEEN THE CASE IN HERE CHAIRED
IS UP AND CREWS WILL THIS
FAMILY WHEN HE WAS TWELVE. YOU
CAN IMAGINE BEING STUCK AT HOME
DURING OLD IT ONLY EXACERBATED
SITUATION SHOULD YET HERE WE
HAVE THIS INCREDIBLY POPULAR.
YOUNG PERSON- ADMISSION THE
REASON HE BEEN IN TO NOT ONLY
SURVIVE BUT THRIVE DESPITE IS
ONLY BY. ORTEGA'S RECEIVING
THAT SCHOOL PARTICULARLY FROM
THIS STUDIES TEACHER. SHE IN
TURN HAS BEEN ABLE TO LEARN
TRANS YOU GROUP. ASIAN AND
PROFESSIONAL ABOUT ACTIVITIES
ARE ORGANISED THIS A PRETTY OFLEADING HER DISTRICT BY NO
MEANS WHAT I HAVE GOT TO HAVE
TO BE THE CLAIMS THAT OUR WORK
THAT EDUCATORS SOLELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR HER ABILITIES.
TO SUPPORT THIS YOUNG MAN. BUT
I WILL SAY THAT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DEEPEN THE CAPACITY OF
EDUCATORS TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS ARE SEEN.
ACCORDED THAT THE HEART OF THE
YARD YOU PROJECT YOUR DEGREE
PROJECT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO BE PART OF.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION OF SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING IN ORDER TO SUSTAIN AND
EXPAND THE COMMUNITY BASED
PRACTICE. FOR ADDITIONAL YEARS
IT COULD NOT BE MORE IN KEEPING
WITH OUR STATE GOALS FOR THE
MARKET LIKE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS GOING TO BE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THIS IS HELEN
ROCK ALBUM- I'M SPEAKING ON THE
ASHTEAD ISSUE TOO AS A MEMBER
OF THE TWENTY ONE OH FIVE
RODRIGUEZ ASK WHERE'S THAT
RECOMMENDED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS THAT THEY
COLLECT LICENSURE DATA STEFFI
GRAF WHO IS IN THE HELP
WORKFORCE AND WE'RE AT A
PRACTICE AND REPRESENTING SAN
FRANCISCO JEWISH VOCATIONAL
SERVICE. THE COSPONSORED AT
TWELVE THIRTY SIX HANG WE
SUPPORT POSH THE DATA
COLLECTION AND ARE THERE
PROPOSAL TO DO SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ADRIAN SOMETHING WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE A CHILD AND
FAMILY SRVICES WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
TODAY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PROPOSAL TO FIND
THE OFFICE JUST BY PREVENTION I
DID NUMBER FOUR UNDER THAT
DEPARTMENT. THERE IS A CRITICAL
NEED AND OUR STATE TO ADDRESS A
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGE AND THE EVIDENCE FOR
EFFECTIVE SUICIDE PREVENTION
POLICIES GROWTH EVERY DAY WE
BELIEVE THAT STATE LEADERSHIP
CAN HELP GUIDE AND ACCELERATE
THE BEST PRACTICES. BUT ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE AFTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PROBLEMS FOR
OFFERING THE BILL LAST YEAR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWELVE
YOUR INITIATE THAT OCCURRED AND
WE THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
MOVING THE PROPOSAL FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
JENNIFER LAWRENCE BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN ADDITION TO OUR
SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABILITY FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AND
THE CORRESPONDING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND FUNDING THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED LOW
WAGE WORKERS BUT STILL THEY'RE
STILL EXPECTED TO CONTRIBUTE
MORE OF THEIR WAGES HEALTH
COVERAGE. IN ADDITION WE CANNOT
GET UNIVERSAL COVERAGE IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT RAINY IN
THE COST OF CARE. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE SEPARATES TO
ESTABLISH AND ENFORCE HEALTH
EQUITY AND QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR ALL PLANS WE HAVE
SUGGESTIONS TO STRENGTHEN
LANGUAGE INCLUDING CLARIFYING
THAT THIS APPLIES TO NON KNOCKS
KEEN LICENSE MEDICAL PLANS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND
FINALLY IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
REGARDING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENT
EQUITY WE WILL ALIGN OUR COMP
WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS BUT THOSE
AND THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK THE CALIFORNIA
BY HEALTH NETWORKS AND RANKO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO I AM
CALLING TO COMMENT ON ISSUE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED ITEM NUMBER
FOUR TWO SIX FIVE MY NAME IS
SONYA YONATAN HI AND- OF
CALIFORNIANS BLACK COULDN'T
HELP PROJECT WE'RE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO HELP
IMPLEMENT THE BLACK. GIRL AND
RETRAIN BLACK MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATE ACTIVISTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I WANTED
TO SPEAK AND LET YOU KNOW OUR
THOUGHT BACK TO HELP OUT. FOR
THE STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC POPULATIONS
RESUSCITATED THE INVESTED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES REDUCTION. B. AS A
THREE RD. HE IS A RESPONSIVE
MENTAL COMMISSION TO STATE MUCH
BECAUSE TO REDUCTIONS THE OF
MENTAL ILLNESS FOR FIVE
PRIORITY POPULAR. INVESTMENT
COULD CALIFORNIA HEAD OF THE
NATION'S IN RECOGNIZING THE-
NATIONALLY THE DISPARITIES. CRT
P. ISN'T UNPRECEDENTED HISTORIC
CROSS POPULATION SOLUTION BUT
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE AT
THE STATE NATIONAL OR
INTERNATIONAL LEVEL. THE
PROJECT HAS TREMENDOUS VALUE
VALUE TO THE PRIORITY GENERALLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS THAT
IS DESIGNED CONCERNS. AFTER
MANY YEARS OF FUNDING
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL APPROACHES
INSTATED COUNTY SYSTEMS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO ON GOING INTO A
STORE TRAUMA BY REINFORCING IT
IS FORCING RACES IN THE STRIP
THE MILITARY POLICIES
PROCEDURES PRACTICES. IN A
SEPARATE. OPEN THE DOOR FOR A
NEW GENERATION OF PRACTICES AND
POLICIES COULD BEGIN
TRANSFORMING OUR FUNCTION IN
APPROACH THE CRT P. IF THE
STAFF LOOKING A PLATFORM. FOR
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
PRACTICES ORIENT BROWN'S THE
NEXT GENERATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE THE PROJECT MOST
CERTAINLY. WARRANTS EXTENDED
THE FUNDING. ENCINAL FOR DEER
IS THE VERY LEAST THE STATE
SHOULD INVEST ESPECIALLY GIVEN
WE ALL KNOW IS THE WAY OF
PUBLIC EXTRA ORDER. NEXT
OPPONENT AND I HAD OF. THE C.
R. P. IT CREDIT. NECESSARY TO
LEAVE IN OUR- AND INVENTION
WORTHY OF IN. I ALSO STAND WITH
THE COMING THREE IRONICAL
MISCONCEIVED AND AS WELL AS-
OUR COMMUNITY AND STATEWIDE
PARTNER. PARTNERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BLACKHAWK NETWORK
THANK YOU FROM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE LINE- FOUR THESE AHEAD.
ONE ONE OF FOR YOUR LINES OPEN.
WILL MOVE TOWARD NUMBER ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I AM VERY MUCH DAY TEN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. I FIND MY
EXTRA PORT OF- ISSUE TOO I
DON'T WANT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WELL WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT AN ONGOING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE
A GREAT START IN HELPING OUR
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
BECOME MORE PROACTIVE RATHER
THAN REACTIVE. WE'VE ALSO BUILT
ON NEW CONNECTIONS AND PATHWAYS
WITH THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS AND I WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS FUNDING-
HELPING OUR LOCAL DEPARTMENT
INTERFACE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL AND EVEN WORLDWIDE
DEPARTMENT MORE EFFECTIVELY AS-
MORE KIND OF WITH. LONG RISE IN
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ROBUST
CONVERSE. DURING THAT AGENDA
ITEM AND REITERATE THE PORTA
FEEDBACK FOR THE ON GOING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHTY SIX LINES OF. YES
WE CAN. DEGREE DOCTORS NEED-
CALIFORNIA REDUCING THE.
SACRAMENTO THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
VALUE EITHER. HELLO A NEW
REPORT FROM THE LONG BEACH
EVERYONE AND. STATE THAT I
SUPPORT. YOU ONE MORE DOLLARS.
THE PROJECT FOR YEARS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HOW MANY OTHER COLORS LEFT MR
MODERATOR. HELLO AT THIS TIME
WE SERVE TWELVE IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AND. GOOD EVENING. HELLO YES
GO AHEAD PLEASE. SENATORS
GENERALLY. ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
FOR THE TECHNOLOGY TO CONNECT
ORGANIZED. ONLY HALF OF EACH
OTHER IN RECOGNIZING THE BEEN
AGREED. WE ARE CURRENTLY ONE OF
THE FIVE ORGANIZATION ARE
LOOKING THE INTERSECTION OF
POKER ALL. I WE CONTINUE UNDER
PUBLIC BARGAINING. ARE. WHAT IT
IS I NEEDED ABOUT THE CARD THAT
I BOUGHT. PEOPLE MUCH. MARGINS
AT THREE THIRTY THREE
CALIFORNIA. ARCHIVE MAYBE AND
THAT THE LEADERSHIP AND. THANK
YOU MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE.
NEXT TO BE ONE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A LOT OF CHERYL LAURA BY
NAME UPON BY THOSE ABOUT OF THE
AL HELD ON ITEMS YOU CAN FIVE
IF THE COURT AND THE BRIDGE
REQUEST FOR TWO MILLION ONGOING.
FUNDING FOR LOW PUB HEALTH THE
WORKED AND INFRASTRUCTURE. AS
WELL AS PEOPLE FIVE AND FOR
HEALTH WORKFORCE IN THIS STUDY
OPPOSED EIGHTY FORTY CALIFORNA
CAN'T TO THE NEXT MONDAY YOUR
PUBLIC THANK YOU FOR GOING
THROUGH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT TO ONE FOR
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU DIANA DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH
ACT THE CALIFORNIA COMMENTING
ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE RELATED TO HEALTH EQUITY
IN QUALITY REVIEWS OF THAT BUT
THE PARTY TO SHOW COUNT ABILITY
AND QUALITY IN EQUITY METRICS
WERE PLANTED BUT THE COMMERCIAL
AND MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
MARKET. HOWEVER WE DO OPPOSED
TO FREEZING ANY PARTICULAR KIND
OF MEASURES IN PLACE- FOR TOO
LONG WE DO RECOMMEND UPDATING
THE METRICS EVERY THREE TO FIVE
YEARS ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
SCIENCE AND HEALTH CARE
PRIORITY WE ALSO ENCOURAGE-
THAT HE OUGHT TO MAKE EXPLICIT
THAT THE MAGICAL COOLEY ADDRESS
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES.
WE APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS RELATED TO OUR
CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS EFFORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR
PLEASE. NEXT WE NUMBER ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHAIRPERSON EGGMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS WENDY ****
REPRESENTING HATHAWAY SYCAMORES
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR UNDER
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REGARDING THE OFFICE OF THE
WITH THAT CONVENTION WE SUPPORT
THE ALRP THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
ALLOCATION OF STAFFING
RESOURCES. ALSO READ THE
LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAMA.
BURKE HEARING AB. TWO ONE ONE
TWO. BANDY SHIN FOR THIS NEWLY
CREATED OFFICE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE.
NEXT IS ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR DANNY OFFER
WITH THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS
NAMI CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR STAYING UP WITH US I
PROMISE I'LL BE EXTRA BRIEF
NUMBER ONE. NOT MAKE CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT NUMBER TWO WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE FUNDING REQUEST FOR
THE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION BLACKROCK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS OSCAR SANDOVAL AND I'M
BE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS SENIOR
MANAGER FOR THE WORK YOU KNOW
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA NINE SPEAKING TO
POSH BUT ISSUE NUMBER ONE IN
SECTION FOUR TWO SIX FIVE. OUR
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTS OUR
COSPONSORED EUGENE KANSEN OF
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK HAWK
NETWORKS COMMENTS ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE HEALTH
EQUITY FUND UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL
AND THIRTY EIGHT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
PROACTIVE APPROACH. TO
SUPPORTING THE ORGANIZATIONS ON
THE GROUND BETTER ADDRESSING
THE NEEDS OF HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ALL
OVER OUR STATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BIANCA I'M IN YOUR POLICY
MANAGER FOR AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY
WE ARE A RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS TO
PARTICIPATE AND CONTRIBUTE. TO
AN EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY. AND THE REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE OVER FOUR MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR AT
ELEVEN THIRTY WITH CREATE THE
OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY I THESE ARE THE
COLLECTION OF THE DATA IS
REALLY IMPORTANT HELP THAT
PARKING. WILL COST FOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS BEFORE
HEALTHCARE FOR THEMSELVES FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND FOR SELF
EMPLOYED ENTREPRENEURS. THE
TOOL CREATED BY THIS
LEGISLATION ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BY SMALL BUSINESSES
IN OUR NETWORK SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY OPINION CALLING UPON
THE MORE THAN EIGHT IN TEN.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER THE GREEN
BAY CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO EXPAND IT THE STORY
YOU'RE A BEAUTY KERR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE. ZERO AT.
GOOD EVENING HELLO MY NAME'S
NICOLE COMMUNIS I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE PREGNANT CREATORS
FUSION COMMENTING ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE COSMETIC
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVORING
INGREDIENT RIGHT TO KNOW ACT OR
SB THREE TWELVE. FTA IS VERY
INTERESTED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL AND
WE ARE CURRENTLY REVIEWING THIS
REQUEST AS TO HOW IT WILL
IMPROVE IMPLEMENTATION CAN WE
RECORD OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE PH TRENCHER I WAS THE
IMPLEMENTED CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATUTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT IS ONE FORTY NINE THESE
GUYS AND- GOOD EVENING TERRY
EGGMAN INDUCTED PAN MY NAME IS
DANIEL TOLERANT AND UNDERCOOKED
PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR THE LGBTQ
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER WE RE ONE OF
FIVE. POPULATION BASED. WHAT
SERVICES THAT ARE. BUT GIVING
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION THE LEG UP-
ENSURING THAT ONE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS TAKING PLACE
HOMEGROWN. TO THAT ORGANIZATION
BECOME STABLE AND SOUND SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO ATTRACT-
COUNTY OR STATE IN OTHER
FUNDING- WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF CONTINUING. THE C. R. D. P.
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT AND ONE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY RADICAL HE CAN
IN THE FUTURE CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND GOOD NIGHT THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. IN ZERO THERE ARE TWO
LEFT IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
VERY MOTOR TO NUMBER. ONE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KEN STARR
WOULD CARRY FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA CAMP
LEAGUE COALITIONS BUDGET
REQUEST FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FUNDING FOR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
WORKFORCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY AS
OUTLINED IN AB TWO FORTY HAVE
YOU HEARD TODAY FROM THE VERY
ELOQUENT SPEAKERS LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS DID NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT INFRASTRUCTURE TO
RESPOND TO THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC. IF THIS REQUEST FOR
GRANT FOR FUNDING IS GRANTED
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WILL BE ABLE
TO HIRE AND TRAIN STAFF AND OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO
CONDUCT THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
PERFORM HOME VISITS AND ADDRESS
OTHER CRITICAL COMMUNITY
CONCERNS THE STAFF WOULD THEN
BE TRAINED AND READY TO RESPOND
TO THE NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND THEREFORE BE
READY TO BETTER SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT PANDEMIC TO
FUND PUBLIC HEALTH. WE MUST
INVEST NOW THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER- BUT MANY WERE THE
PROJECT HERE BUT I'M GOING TO
CONCENTRATE ON JUST A FEW WE
ARE THE CO SPONSOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT BUDGET ACT IT'S
INCREDIBLY. SUCCESSFUL AND
INNOVATIVE PROJECT HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL IN REDUCING
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
IT IS WORTH CONTINUING AND I
HOPE IT STATE BY TO MAKE THAT
INVESTMENT SHROUT THE SUPPORTED
AS THE OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY IF WE ADD OUR
STATE PAPER BY HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND THIS
OFFICE WILL BE HAVE THE ABILITY
THAT THAT REGION BY REGION AND
SECTOR BY SECTOR GOLD ON COSTS.
WHICH WILL BENEFIT COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND OTHERS BY FINDING
EQUITABLE AND TRANSPARENT
TARGETS ADDRESS WRITING HOT-
LASTLY THAT COVER CALIFORNIA
AFFORDABLE EXISTENCE WE SUPPORT
THAT- SO THAT PEOPLE CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SO THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD THESE PLANS-
ALSO REPORT TO OFFICE THE
SOONEST BY PREVENTION AND ALSO
ONE OF MY COMMENTS THAT THE PAN
AND T. B. H. AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. RIGHT NEXT BE ONE
FIFTY. PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING RONALD KOEMAN FROM CP
THE CAL SENATE HEALTHCARE
RELATED ISSUE TWO UNDER ARE
SPREAD WE GENERALLY SUPPORT
ORGANIZATION TO STREAMLINE
INFORMATION TO SUPPORT ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE IN EQUITY THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION WE APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS THE PINNACLE
LEADING WITH THE JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICES OF SAN
FRANCISCO AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIXTEEN AROUND THE COLLECTION
WORKFORCE DATA FOR HELP
PROTECTIONS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
IS BEING INCORPORATED WHICH
WILL HELP US REACH OUR
WORKFORCE NEEDS. TO SUPPORT
EQUITY AS A DISCUSSION
CONTINUES WE DO WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF RESOURCES AND CAPACITY
FORWARD TO DIRECTOR LAND START
LEADERSHIP IN THIS ENDEAVOR WE
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION HERE WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE OFFICER
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY ISSUE
THREE. UNDER HOSPICE SAID WE
APPRECIATE THE MULTIPLE YEARS
OF CONVERSATION THAT HAVE
GOTTENUS TO THIS POINT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED ENFORCEABLE
TARGETS RELATED TO COST GIVEN
HOW MUCH HEALTHCARE COSTS
CONTINUE TO SURPASS WAGE GROWTH
AND INFLATION AND NOT ONLY DOES
THE OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY INCLUDE CLEAR
TARGETS ON AFFORDABILITY- FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES BUT IT ALSO
DOES SEEK TO PROMOTE MEASURES-
TO PUBLIC REPLETE REPORT
PERFORMANCE ON QUALITY AND
HEALTH EQUITY. THROUGH THE
ADOPTION OF A SET OF STANDARD
QUALITY AND ENFORCEMENT OR
STANDARD QUALITY AND EQUITY
MEASURES THAT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT UNDER D. MHC WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE VISION
AROUND THE QUALITY IN EQUITY
REVIEW- AS WE DEFINITELY NEED
TO FIND WAYS TO HOLD CLIENTS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HEALTH OUTCOMES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS THERE WAS
STAKEHOLDERS AND BEING MADE TO
FINE TUNE THE PROPOSAL LASTLY
ON ISSUE ONE UNDERCOVER
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
HELP ACCESS IS PROPOSAL RELATED
TO COST SHARING AFFORDABILITY
OPTIONS. BOTH THE LEVEL UP TO
THE NEXT MIDDLE TIER PROPOSAL
AND ALSO DOUBLES WHICH WANTED
TO PHONE COULD INCREASE
ENROLLMENT BY OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AT THIS TIME WE NO
OTHER IN THE FOR PART COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS TOMORROW
AND- AND I WILL SAY FOR RECORD
IF ANYBODY. DIDN'T GET TO MAKE
THE COMMENTS THEY LIKE TO DO TO
PLEASE COMMENT- PLEASE CONTACT
THE COMMITTEE- YOU CAN FIND THE
INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE
YEAH. BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES- WE
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR TIME
AND THEIR PARTICIPATION TODAY
AND- THIS MEETING AND- I NOW
WILL ADJOURN THE HEARING.